OKAY GOOD MORNING WE'LL START
TODAY WITH OUR- HEARING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FINANCE TODAY IS OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION DAY TO TALK
ABOUT- THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
PROPOSALS IT'S- AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO HEAR FROM THE
PARTMINER FINANCE BUT REALLY-
TALK ABOUT WHAT OUR ASSEMBLY
PRIORITIES ARE FOR HIGHER ED.
AND JUST AN OVERALL THERE'S NOT
MUCH OF A HEARING TODAY WITH
THE- THE ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT MUCH IN HERE ON
GOING FOR HIGHER AT- IT IS WHAT
IT IS IF YOU LOOK AT THE L. A-
CHARTS THEY HAVE ALL THE ON
GOING MONEY- YOU CAN'T SEE THIS
BUT YOU CAN SEE THE SMALLEST
LITTLE BLIP HERE. IS FOR HIGHER
AT ON GOING AND SO THAT IS A
PROBLEM WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS
THIS MORNING- WE OVERALL I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR HAD
THE SAME HIGHER READ GOALS
FOCUSING ON ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY. WE HEAR LOUD AND
CLEAR OF COURSE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE FOCUS ON
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH- WITH OUR
SYSTEMS WAS WELL AS WHAT THEY
CAN DO FOR OUR WORK FORCE IN OUR
REGIONAL ECONOMIES. BUT OVERALL-
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT THIS
HISTORIC BUDGET SURPLUS FOR THE
SECOND YEAR DOESN'T TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF INVESTING IN HIGHER
ED. OF THE- FIFTY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS GENERAL FUND THE
ELLIOTT NOTES VERY LITTLE FOR
HIGHER ED OUR PRIORITIES AREN'T
THAT COMPLICATED WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS YEAR AND
FRANKLY FOR THE PRIOR YEARS-
MAJOR PRIORITIES ARE EXPANDING
FINANCIAL AID. MR MEDINA AND
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON- YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR AND THE PERMANENT
FINANCE TALK ABOUT A PATH IN THE
GOAL TO HAVE DEBT FREE COLLEGE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE CERTAINLY
KNOW THAT TOO MANY STUDENTS ARE
OVER BURDENED WITH- IT WITH DATA
CENTER CAL GRANT PROGRAM IS
OVERLY COMPLICATED- YOU NEED IT
SOMETIMES A MASTER'S DEGREE TO
FILL OUT THE APPLICATION- LEAVE
WE LEAVE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
OUT AND WE DON'T ADDRESS THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE AND SO
THAT. IS SOMETHING THAT WE
STARTED TO DO LAST YEAR WERE
PROUD LAST YEAR WE GOT. A MAJOR
STEP OF THE WAY- AND I KNOW WE
TALKED TO THE GOVERNOR ABOUT
THIS LAST YEAR AND HE THAT
DIRECTION WAS TO COME BACK IN
THE BUDGET DON'T DO THEIR
LEGISLATION AND THAT'S WHAT WE-
ATTEMPT TO DO IT WE WILL DO THAT
AND OUR VERSION. AND LOW
DISAPPOINTING WE DON'T SEE ON
GOING MONEY HERE FOR- EXPANDING
FINANCIAL AID THERE IS SOME
MONEY BUT ESSENTIALLY THAT PAYS
FOR LAST YEAR'S DEAL SO. HAS
KIND DOUBLE COUNTING- WE KNOW
THAT WE HEAR FROM ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS- THE MOST THE THING WE
HEARD FROM OUR MEMBERS AT HOME.
IS THE FACT THAT THERE'S TOO
MANY QUALIFIED STUDENTS WHO
APPLY. TO UC AND CSU WHO GET
DENIED. TO MANY UC CAMPUSES ONLY
IN THAT ABOUT 10230% OF THEIR
CALIFORNIA APPLICANTS- WE HAVE
DONE A BETTER JOB. OF FOCUSING
ON MORE CALIFORNIANS AS OPPOSED
TO THE EVER INCREASING NUMBER OF
NON RESIDENTS- BUT WE CAN'T DO
BETTER IN SUPPORT ROLE MEANT WE
KNOW THEY CAN THAT THEY CONTACT
THE GOVERNOR ALLOWED. HAS A 1%
GROWTH BUT THAT. THAT REALLY
ISN'T ENOUGH TO MEET THE DEMAND
FOR CALIFORNIANS APPLYING TO UC-
AS WELL AS WE KNOW OUR LOCAL
EMPLOYERS AND STATEWIDE
EMPLOYERS ARE SAYING ANY MORE
COLLEGE GRADUATES. AND THEN
DON'T SEE ADDRESSED HERE THAT IS
ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITIES.
PLEASE STUDENT HOUSING YOU KNOW
ALL THROUGH THE HEADLINES IN
THIS FALL I'M SORRY THE SPRING.
WE HEARD ABOUT UC BERKELEY. AND
SEQUEL AT NIMBYISM AND SEND THAT
- AT THAT AT BERKELEY. BUT THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE THE- WAS OR
WASN'T ENOUGH HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS- TO LIVE AND SO WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A STUDENT
DEBT CRISIS AND AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS IN COLLEGE AND SO PUT
THOSE TWO TOGETHER. BUT WE NEED
MORE STUDENT HOUSING- SO. WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY WE THINK
WITH THIS- SURPLUS- AND AGAIN
THIS ONE IS HEAD SCRATCHING TOO
BECAUSE ONE OF THINGS FINANCE AS
WE DON'T WANT TO SPEND. ON GOING
GENERAL FINAL FINANCE PRAISED
ON. THAT 99% THE MONEY THE
SURPLUS WAS SPENT ON ONE TIME
NOT ON GOING. AND THIS HOUSING
OF COURSE IS A ONE TIME.
EXPENDITURE AND WE DON'T SEE ANY
OF THAT SO THIS WILL BE. ON OUR
PRIORITY LIST WHEN WE ADOPT OUR-
ASSEMBLY PLANNED SO WE WANT TO
BRIEFLY GO THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS THEY SHOULD
BE BRIEF BECAUSE THERE REALLY
AREN'T VERY MANY. AND THEN WE'LL
FOCUS ON SOME OF OUR PRIORITIES
FROM THE LEGISLATURE. SO WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO START WITH-
THE- WE'RE GONNA HAVE AT ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUE YES COME AND JOIN
US TO TALK ABOUT SOME YOU SEE
ISSUES SO WE'RE GONNA. WAITED A
BIT ON UC. AND WILL START NOW.
WITH OUR- CSU NAY REVISED
PROPOSALS.
THE TIMING. ONE OKAY. OKAY GOOD
MORNING WE'LL START AND YET THIS
MORNING I COLLEGES ARE
INFORMATIONAL ITEMS- THESE
AREN'T VOTING ITEMS AND WE
PROBABLY WON'T DO THAT THE
VOTING ON THE NON CONTROVERSIAL
STUFF EITHER TODAY'S WELL. SO
LET'S START ON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YES YOU MAY REVISED
POLLS. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GENEROUSLY WITH HE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ME
REVISION MAINTAINS THE FIRE
THEFT BASE INCREASE OF TWO
HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND OTHER
INVESTMENTS INTRODUCED BY THE
REGION IN JANUARY AS PART OF A
MULTI YEAR CONTRACT WITH THE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY. IN THE
REVISION PROVIDING TOLD OF A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR MILLION ONE
TIME JOURNAL FINE TO THE CSU
SYSTEM THESE INVESTMENTS SAID
THE FOLLOWING EIGHTY MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO EXPAND THE
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
POINT FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
TRYING TO FIND. THIS USED TO FOR
ENGINE AGAIN SCIENCE INNOVATION
HUB. AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT EQUIPMENT AND FACILITIES
FOR CSU UNIVERSITY FARMS FOR
COMBINED INVESTMENT OF SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR THIS PURPOSE
WITH THE AUGMENTED. ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME TRYING TO
FIND TO SUPPORT A FIRST ARE FAR
STREET CO CORK I BOTH CSU
NORTHRIDGE AND CSU EAST BAY.
LAST WEEK THE MAY REVISION ALSO
PROVIDES THAT FINDS FOR
UNIVERSITY FARM CSU FULLERTON
AND SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
AND GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF EIGHTY
THREE ONE MILLION. ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CSU
BAKERSFIELD ENERGY INNOVATION
CENTRE. ARE EXEMPT FROM
EDUCATION CODE SECTION EIGHTY
NINE SEVEN SEVEN THREE AS TO NOT
EXCEED THE CAP ON THE PERCENTAGE
OF THE CSU'S GENERAL FUND STATE
OPERATION PROCREATION. THAT CAN
BE EXPANDED TO PAY AS YOU GO
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT. WITHOUT
I SHALL CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO GO INTO
FURTHER DETAILS REQUEST OR
REQUEST OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU L. A. L. GOOD MORNING CAN
MEMBERS THE THINKING WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. HE
SHOULD HAVE BEFORE YOU A HANDOUT
SUMMARIZING THE HIGHER EDUCATION
THE REVISION PROPOSALS. IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE TWO OF THAT HAND
OUT OF FEAR TABLE THAT
SUMMARIZES THE NEAR VISION
PROPOSALS FOR CSU. IT SHOWS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS IN
THE FIRST COLUMN THE MAYOR
VISION FALLS IN THE SECOND
COLUMN IN THE DIFFERENCE IN
THAT. RIGHT MOST COLUMN. THE
LARGEST PROPOSALS FOR SEE IF YOU
IN THE MEROVINGIAN ARE FOR
SPECIFIC CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
AS MY COLLEAGUE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IT DESCRIBES. HE'S
LISTED IN THE BOTTOM HALF OF THE
TABLE AND A ONE TIME INITIATIVES
. IN GENERAL FUND SPENDING ON
CAPITAL OUTLAY CAN BE BENEFICIAL
RIGHT NOW. BOTH IN ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
AND IN ADDRESSING THE STATE'S
BUDGETARY REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT. AND
LATER I TO MY COLLEAGUE JASON
CONCENTRATES WILL PROVIDE
FURTHER DETAIL ON THAT. NONE THE
LESS WE DO HAVE A FEW CONCERNS
WITH THE SPECIFIC CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS THAT THE GOVERNOR
SELECTED. FIRST OVER THE YEARS
THE SUB COMMITTEE HAS DISCUSSED
MANY COUPLE OUTLAY PRIORITIES
FOR THE UNIVERSITIES. RANGING
FROM ADDRESSING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TO EXPANDING
ENROLLMENT CAPACITY HIGH DEMAND
CAMPUSES. SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S
NEAR VISION CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS FOR CSU DON'T CLEARLY
ALIGNED WITH THESE PRIORITIES
AND ARGUE THE ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T PROVIDED A STRONG
RATIONALE FOR SELECTING THESE
PARTICULAR PROJECTS OVER OTHER
PROJECTS THAT. ALIGN WITH THOSE
PRIORITIES. SECOND SOME OF THE
PROPOSED PROJECTS ALSO WERE NOT
IN CSU'S MULTI YEAR CAPITAL
OUTLAY PLAN. SUGGESTING THE
COMPREHENSIVE PLANNING MAY NOT
HAVE YET OCCURRED ON THESE
PROJECTS. WE THINK THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
PROJECT AT SAN DIEGO STATE'S
FRAWLEY CENTER AS THE
GOVERNOR'S. GOALS FOR THIS
CENTER ARE- REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION FROM THE
CENTERS KERN OPERATIONS.
ULTIMATELY WITH ANY OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS FOR CSU THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
REDIRECTING THESE FUNDS TO OTHER
CAPITAL PURPOSES. SUCH AS
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG OR
ADDRESSING OTHER CAPITAL
PRIORITIES THE LEGISLATURE HAS.
THANK YOU HAVE A TAKEN QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU NOW LET'S HEAR FROM
THE CSU. GOOD MORNING AT CHAIR
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RYAN STORM I AM THE ASSISTANT
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR BUDGET FOR
THE CSU OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR. TUCKER THREE TOPIC
AREAS TODAY THE FIRST IS OUR
RESPONSE TO THE MAY REVISION THE
SECOND IS THE MULTI YEAR COMPACT
IN THE THIRD COMMENTS ON WHAT
MUST STILL BE ACCOMPLISHED ON
THE CSU BUDGET. SO MY FIRST
TOPIC THE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
. SO THE CAPITAL PREVENT
PROJECTS AT THE UNIVERSITY FARMS
AT FULLER TEN IN THE IPERIAL
VALLEY ARE IMPORTANT TO THOSE
CSU CAMPUSES AND ALL OF THOSE
PROJECTS WOULD ADD TREMENDOUS
VALUE TO THE CAMPUSES. NOW THE
ASSEMBLY MAY AGREE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND FUND THOSE.
INVERSELY IF THE ASSEMBLY. THE
ASSEMBLY MAY CHOOSE NOT TO FUND
THEM. IF THAT HAPPENS IN THE L.
A. AS RECOMMENDATION TO REDIRECT
THOSE ONE TIME FUNDS TO THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES ONE BILLION
DOLLAR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
REQUEST WOULD BE A REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVE FOR US. WE SHARE THE
CONCERN RAISED BY THE LA- ON THE
ONE TIME FOSTER YOUTH PROPOSAL
FOR THE EAST BAY AND NORTHRIDGE
CAMPUSES. IN PARTICULAR THE ONE
TIME THE NATURE OF THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD CREATE ONGOING COST
PRESSURES TO SUSTAIN THOSE
PROGRAMS. AFTER THE FUNDS
EXPIRE. ALSO THE PROGRAM IS NOT
A PRIORITY OF EITHER CAMPUS
TODAY. NOW MY SECOND TOPIC
COMMENTS ON THE CHANGES TO THE
MULTI YOUR CONTACT. NO CONTACT
IS AN IMPORTANT MILESTONE FOR
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY FOR C.
ISSUES FINANCIAL SUSTAINABILITY
AND PREDICTABILITY. IT WILL NOT
FUND ALL OF THE UNIVERSITIES
NEEDS AND WE VIEW THIS BUDGET
CONTACT IS A CRITICAL SAFETY NET
TO PROTECT THE UNIVERSITY FROM
ECONOMIC FLUCTUATIONS OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. CHANGES WERE%
MADE TO THIS ISSUE CONTACTED THE
MAY REVISION- WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR ADDITIONS
TO THE REVISED COMPACT THOSE ARE
STATEMENTS OF OPENNESS PROVIDING
MORE ON GOING AND ONE TIME
TWENTY TO THE CSU TO THE EXTENT
STATE REVENUE IS AVAILABLE. AND
BECAUSE THERE IS MORE STATE
REVENUE AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW. AT
THE MAY REVISION SEGWAYS TO MY
THIRD TOPIC. WHICH IS THIS ISSUE
BUDGET REQUEST. WE'RE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ONGOING
FUNDING AND ONE TIME FUNDING%
GOVERNOR NEWSOM PROPOSED IN
JANUARY AND CONTINUES IN MAY.
THAT IS A REALLY GOOD START. THE
FUNDING GAP REMAINS BETWEEN THE
TOWARD TRUSTEES BUDGET PLAN AND
THE GOVERNOR'S. NOW THE MOST
PRESSING PRIORITY OF THE
TRUSTEES BUDGET REQUEST IS
FARING AND- EQUITABLE
COMPENSATION FOR A FACULTY AND
STAFF. SALARIES HAVE BEEN
STAGNANT FOR TWO YEARS AND
RECENT INFLATIONARY PRESSURES
MAKE COMPENSATION AGREEMENTS
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TODAY. AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE FACULTY UNION
REPRESENTS HALF REPRESENTING
HALF OF ALL SEE ISSUE EMPLOYEES
WAS FINALIZED EARLIER THIS YEAR
. HOWEVER AGREEMENTS AND
DECISIONS FOR APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY THOUSAND OTHER
REPRESENTED AND NON REPRESENTED
PLAYS ARE NOW OPEN OR WILL BE
OPEN FOR THE BUDGET YEAR. NOW TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND FULFILL
THIS ISSUE BUDGET PRIOR TO A
TRUST THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
TRUST- OTHER PRIORITIES. BY
GRADUATION INITIATIVE UNERRING
EQUITY GAPS WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADD THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS A
MONTH GOING FUNDING ABOVE THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
. ANOTHER COMPENSATION ITEM THAT
I HAVEN'T REYES BEFORE WITH YOU
IS THE- STAFF SALARIES-
STRUCTURE STUDY THAT'S A LOT OF
ESSES IN THERE SORRY. THE STUDY
REVEALED A MAJOR FUNDING-
FINDINGS IN THE AREAS OF
COMPETITIVE MARKET SALARY
STRUCTURE JOB FRAMEWORK AND
PREDICTABLE AND EQUITABLE PAY.
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES WILL
REQUIRE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING OVER AND ABOVE
THE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS I JUST
MENTIONED. ALSO WE REQUEST NINE
HUNDRED MILLION A ONE TIME
FUNDING TO HELP US REPAIR AND
MINOR RICE MODERNIZE OUR AGING
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
NO IVEN THE STATE'S HISTORIC-
FINANCIAL POSITION. I HAVE THREE
NUMBERS I S. C. REMEMBER AS YOU
MAKE YOUR FINAL BUDGET DECISIONS
FIRST OF THE SEASON BUDGET BE
INCREASED BY THREE HUNDRED ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE
TRUSTEES OFFERING BUDGET
PRIORITIES. SECOND THAT THE C.
ISSUE BUDGET BE FURTHER
INCREASED BY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING. TO IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STEPS
EVERY STUDY. IN THIRD- THAT AN
ADDITIONAL NINE HUNDRED BILLION
IN ONE TIME DOLLARS BE ADDED TO
FUND ECONOMIC FACILITIES AND
RENEWAL NEEDS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU QUESTIONS. FOR
THE PANELISTS ON CSU. ALL RIGHT
I'LL START HERE. FROM THE- FROM
THE L. A. AS TABLE HERE WE SEE
FROM THE JANUARY PROPOSAL TO THE
MAY PROPOSAL AN ON GOING FUNDING
WE ACTUALLY GO DOWN BY SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY THAT
ADJUSTMENTS ON THE ON GOING FROM
OUR AND TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE ESTIMATED COST OF PENSIONS
THAT THE STATE FUNDS AND ALSO
RETIREE HEALTH BENEFITS SUCH AS
BUT I GUESS THE BIG PICTURE IS.
FROM THE JANUARY BUDGET THERE'S
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION FOR THE CSU. IN THE IN
THE BUDGET NEW MONEY THAT MAY
VERSION THERE'S FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVEN THAT'S A DIFFERENCE
WHETHER IT'S TECHNICAL OR NOT IS
DIFFERENCE OF MINUS SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN JANUARY. SO
TWO THINGS HAVE HAPPENED SINCE
JANUARY ONE THE CSU IT TALKED
ABOUT THEIR NEEDS TO MAKE CALL.
THEIR AGREEMENTS WITH THEIR
EMPLOYEE GROUPS ARE FACULTY AND
THAT CONTRACT- WE'VE HEARD AS
FAR AS COMPACTION OTHER ISSUES
WITH OTHER CSU NON FACULTY
EMPLOYEES THAT I'M SURE WILL
SPEAK ABOUT. SO I NEED FROM CSU
FROM THE SYSTEM AND STAKEHOLDERS
THAT'S ACT NUMBER ONE ACT NUMBER
TWO. NINETY NINE BILLION DOLLARS
SURPLUS. GRANTED THAT'S NOT ALL
ONGOING LA ALSO THIS NORTH A
FIFTY ON GOING AT LEAST SO YOU
WOULD THINK WITH A NEED FROM
CSU. AND NINETY NINE BILLION.
NEW MONEY. THAT MAY REVISE WOULD
HAVE MORE MONEY FOR CSU OVER
HERE TODAY WITH LESS MONEY SO I
KNOW YOU VALUE. CSU
ADMINISTRATION AND NOW WE HAVE
YOUR CONTACT WHICH- IS YOU KNOW
YOUR PLEDGE THE GOVERNOR'S
PLEDGE. IN THIS- IN THIS- SYSTEM
OF GOVERNANCE WAS THERE'S
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR OF
COURSE BUT HOW DO YOU RECONCILE
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE THESE
NEEDS. SO MUCH MONEY. ALMOST THE
AMOUNT OF THE ENTIRE STATE
BUDGET A LITTLE OVER A DECADE
AGO IN NEW MONEY. AND THE- AND
THE COMMITTEE INVESTMENT TO THE
CSU GOES DOWN HOW DO YOU
RECONCILE THAT. GENERALLY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELL I
CAN'T SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR
COMMENT ON THE ON SURPLUS BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT
THE SUBSTANTIAL YEAR OVER YEAR
INCREASE PROPOSED AND THOUGHT
THROUGH THE MULTI YEAR CONTACT
SUPPORT CSU OPERATIONS PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY. AND PREDICTABILITY
FOR THE CSU DEFINE ONGOING NEEDS
ACCORDING TO ITS PARTIES AND
REPRESENTS SOME OF THE LARGEST
MOST CONSISTENTLY PLAN YOUR
EVERY YEAR JENNIFER INCREASES IN
RE GETS RECENT HISTORY TO THE
CSU SYSTEM THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED APPROACH IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY IS FOCUSED ON MEETING
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS. AND THE
WORKFORCE OF THE FUTURE CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS AND SUPPORT PROGRESS
TOWARD DEGREE ATTAINMENT. GOALS
WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE CSU
AND ITS LABOR PARTNERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. HE DOES DO YOU DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION THINK THAT
THE SYSTEM- NEEDS MORE ONGOING
MONEY ABOVE WHAT YOU PROPOSED IN
JANUARY TO FIND. THEIR EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION AGREEMENTS AND
NEEDS. THE MINISTER JENNIFER
WITH FINANCE AGAIN- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS REAFFIRMING
THE MULTI YEAR CONTACTED GREED
TO WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY PROPOSING GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND BELIEVES THAT THE
PREDICTABILITY AND THE
FLEXIBILITY ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE CONTACTS ARE SUFFICIENT TO
MAINTAIN UNIVERSITY OPERATIONS.
I KNOW I ASK A QUESTION YOUR
ANSWERS LIKE A PRE PROGRAMMED
ANSWER OVER HERE I GET THAT
THAT'S YOUR JOB BUT DO YOU THINK
THAT THE CSU NEEDS. MORE MONEY
TO ADDRESS THEIR AGREEMENTS WITH
THE UNIONS. YES SIR NOW. THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO-
FROM THE MULTI YEARCONTACT A
GREEDY WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OKAY AND THEN AS FAR AS
THE- THE CAPITAL PROJECTS I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE
CAPITAL PROJECTS. WITH ONE TIME
MONEY ARE- A GOOD USE OF ONE
TIME MONEY AND THAT IS AN AREA
THAT THERE WAS AN INCREASE FROM
THE JANUARY BUDGET TO THE MAY
BUDGET A LITTLE OVER ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FOUR MILLION I
GUESS- THERE'S TWO PROJECTS THAT
THEY'RE HERE. THAT THAT JUMPED
OUT OF THE LION'S SHARE OF IT
ARE FOR THE SAN DIEGO STATE
FRAWLEY CENTER AND FULLER TEN-
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN TO FULLER TEN
I'VE IS THERE RECENTLY AND
THAT'S I THINK THAT. THE IF NOT
THE LARGEST THE TOP TWO OR THREE
LARGEST THE ISSUES AND HAS A
HUGE ENROLLMENT- DEMANDS AND SO
THEY'VE CLEARLY NEED MORE. YOU
KNOW- LAB SPACE COMPUTER SCIENCE
SPACE AND HOUSING- SO I WOULD
THINK THAT THAT PROJECT WOULD BE
ABLE TO HELP WITH- ENROLLING
MORE STUDENTS OF THE CSU. BUT I
GUESS THE QUESTION ARE ARE THESE
TWO- SYSTEMS ARE USED TO ARE
PROJECTS WOULD THEY BE ON THE
LIST FOR CSU FOR THE HIGHEST
NEED TO EXPAND ACCESS
CALIFORNIANS AND CAL. IN THE CSU
. WELL CERTAINLY FOR THE FULLER
TEN PROJECT- I THINK IT GOES
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE
NORTHRIDGE CAMPUS OF FULLERTON
WORK WHO HAS THE MOST STUDENTS
IN FULLERTON AS- POTENTIALLY
NUMBER WANTED NATURE MIGHT BE
NUMBER TWO BUT CERTAINLY AT A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF STUDENTS
IN ORANGE COUNTY. I THINK ONE
THING THAT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
ABOUT THE FULLER TO PROJECT IS
THAT THIS WOULD BE AN EXPANSION
OF A BUILDING THAT- FIRST- WAS
BUILT IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
AND HASN'T HAD ANY SIGNIFICANT
RENOVATIONS OR IMPROVEMENTS. AND
FULLERTON HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN
THE LARGEST CAMPUS IN THE C.
ISSUE IT IS GROWN DRAMATICALLY
IN ITS THE ONLY CAMPUS SERVING
GENERALLY ORANGE COUNTY. SO
THERE IS A LOT OF MERIT THERE-
ONE THING ALSO WITH THAT PROJECT
IS THAT IS. WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING IS
TO ADVANCE THE WORK ON THIS
PROJECT BY ONE YEAR IS HONOR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR YEAR A
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS- PLAN-
THE MISTRESSES IS CHOOSING TO
AFFORD ADVANCE AND WORK ON THAT
PROJECT. RIGHT AWAY VERSUS
WAITING A YEAR SELL MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE FROM THAT VANTAGE
POINT. SO AS FAR AS THE BRAWLEY
ONE. IF IS THAT. IF YOU AN
ADDITIONAL WHAT IS THE BY ONE
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION SO IT IS THIS THE
HIGHEST AND BEST USE FOR STATE
MONEY TO EXPAND ACCESS FOR CS
WELL I'D SAY IT'S ONE OF THE
HIGHEST PARTIES OF THE SAN DIEGO
STATE CAMPUS IT IS NOT CURRENTLY
ON THE MULTI YEAR PLAN FOR THE
SAN DIEGO STATE CAMPUS- THERE
ARE SOME BENEFITS TO THE PROJECT
OBVIOUSLY BEING VERY CLOSE TO
LITHIUM PRODUCTION AREA. AS WELL
AS REALLY A NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
STEM RELATED DEGREES OUT IN THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY MOST OF THE
COURSE OFFERINGS AT BRAWLING ARE
RELATED TO BACHELORS OF ARTS AND
TEACHER CREDENTIALING DEGREES-
AND THAT WOULD BE A OF A PROJECT
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY EXPAND
INTO THE SCIENCES AND OTHER STEM
FIELDS SO THAT THAT COULD BE.
BENEFICIAL TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO. YEAH THIS ONE IS-
ONE THAT WE HAD NOT SEEN ON ON
YOUR CSU LAST- NOR HAD WE- HAVE
WE SEEN THIS FOR MEMBERS WHO WHO
ARE BEEN PUTTING IN REQUESTS FOR
CSU CAPITAL PROJECTS SO. WE HAVE
A BIG LIST OVER HERE BUDGET
NEEDS AND THIS ONE CAME OUT OF.
LEFT FIELD A LITTLE BIT SOME-
PLASTI VALUE IT THIS. SO I KNOW
THE L. A. HAD SOME COMMENTS ON
ON THIS ONE. DID YOU. THAT'S
CRACKED THREE NOTED THAT THIS
PROJECT AS SOON AS YOU MENTIONED
IS NOT PART OF THE MULTI YEAR
PLAN WHICH RAISES SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF PLANNING
THAT'S GONE INTO THE PROJECT TO
DATE. IT ALSO DOES REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF THE
BALI CENTER WHICH IS CURRENTLY
ESTIMATED TO ENROLL A FEW
HUNDRED STUDENTS AND AS SOON AS
YOU MENTIONED PRIMARILY IN. NON
STEM FIELDS. AND SO WE THINK
THAT COULD BENEFIT FROM
ADDITIONAL PLANNING. GOTCHA AND
WHAT WAS YOUR PROCESS PER
SECTION. ON THE- THESE FULLER TO
THE PROJECT. THIS PROJECT COULD
HAVE BENEFITS AS THE CSU NOTED
IN ACCOMMODATING ADDITIONAL
ENROLLMENT AT A HIGH DEMAND
CAMPUS WITH ITS PROGRAMS ALL
CURRENTLY IMPACTED HOWEVER IT IS
SOMEWHAT FURTHER ALONG IN CSCS
MLTI YOUR PLAN AND SO IT MAY
NOT REPRESENT THE MOST URGENT
CAPITAL PRIORITY SYSTEM WIDE. SO
WE SUGGEST YOU WEIGH THIS
AGAINST THE OTHER CAPITAL
PRIORITIES THAT MAY NOT RANK
TOWARD THE TOP OF THE LIST FOR
THE STATE. OKAY THANK YOU-
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE CSU
YOU THROW DOT. I'LL JUST
HIGHLIGHT THE ACCOUNT TO THE
CHAIR AND- I JUST WANNA SAY THAT
I SUPPORT THEM- THE SALARY STUDY
SUPPORTING THAT TOTHE EXTENT
THAT WE CANNOT BE A VERY GOOD
THING- YEAH AND- JUST APPRECIATE
AGAIN THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS WITH
REGARD TO SUPPORTING THE CSU.
AND OUR TIME HOW STARK- FUNNY
AND WE SHOULD APPLY TO ALL
LEVELS OF OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
IN THE STATES WITH THAT THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU TUCKER TWENTY
THANK THANK YOU WE WILL HOLD
THAT THE CSU ITEMS OPEN. NOW WE
WILL PROCEED WITH ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OKAY THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PLEASE PROCEED. MORNING
TURN NUMBERS DAN HANNAH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE
START OF LIKE TO REFERENCE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MULTI YEAR
ROADMAP ARRIVED AT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE FNALIZE ROADMAP CONTAINS
CLEAR BASELINES IMMEASURABLE
TARGETS FOR IMPROVEMENTS-
BUILDING TOWARDS THE GOALS
INITIALLY OUTLINES OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGETS- THE FOR THE
TEXT OF THE AGREEMENT ITSELF FOR
MORE SPECIFICITY ON THESE
TARGETS. TURNING OUT TO LOCAL
ASSISTANCE THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THE LARGE NUMBER OF
NEW INVESTMENTS. INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AS SUCH THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE MAY
REVISION FOCUSES ON PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT. TO THE
STUDENTS SENATE FUNDING FORMULA
OR SCF AND FLEXIBLE BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING TO SUPPORT DISTRICTS
WITH THE EXPECTED TRANSITION.
BACK TO IN PERSONAGENS. AND TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS OUTLINED IN
THE MULTI YEAR ROADMAP. TO THAT
END THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES AN
OVERALL PACING CREASE OF THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION. FOR THE ASIFA
SPECIFICALLY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION TO INCREASE THE
FUNDING RATES UNDER THE S. E. F.
F. AND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. TO AUGMENT THE BASIC
ALLOCATION IN RECOGNITION OF THE
INCREASING OPERATING COSTS
INCLUDING THE SIGNIFICANT
DIGITAL FOOT PRINTS. THE
DISTRICTS HAVE DEVELOPED TO
ACCOMMODATE LONG TERM SHIFTS IN
STUDENT LEARNING MODALITY DEMAND
. THESE CHANGES ALONG WITH
VARIOUS TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS
PRODUCE AN ESTIMATED DECREASE OF
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN POINT
ONE MILLION TO THE HOLD
HARMLESS. RELATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES EIGHTY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO REFLECT THE INCREASE
IN THE STATUTORY COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. FROM FIVE POINT 33%
AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO SIX
POINT FIVE SIX PERCENT. AND ONE
POINT THREE MILLION TO MAINTAIN
FUNDING FOR POINT 5% ENROLLMENT
GROWTH. THE ADMINISTRATION DOES
NOT PROPOSE STATUTORY CHANGES TO
THE S. C. ABOUT THAT THE MAYOR
VISION THAT ARE SEPARATE FROM
THE HOLD HARMLESS CHANGE.
PROPOSED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
MONITOR HOW DISTRICT ENROLLMENT
PERFORM AND EXPECTS THE
STABILITY PROVISION OF THE
OSTEOPATH AND SIGNIFICANT NEW
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT DISTRICT
FUNDING FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR. THE
MARRIAGE AND UTILIZE A
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME FUNDING
UNDER THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE. PROVIDED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION OUR
BLOCK GRANT. AND AN INCREASE OF
ONE POINT ONE BILLION FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WHICH
TOTALS ONE POINT FIVE BILLION.
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL. BLOCK GRANT FUNDS
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS
ISSUES RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC
HUNDRED AND TO REDUCE LONG TERM
OBLIGATIONS. OTHER ADJUSTMENTS
INCLUDED THE MAYOR VISION AE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONGOING FOR
ROUGHLY 5% INCREASE TO THE
STUDENT EQUITY ACHIEVEMENT
PROGRAM. FORTY FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME FOR THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
SCHOOL MEALS PATHWAY PROGRAM. A
DECREASE OF FIFTY MILLION FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ESTIMATE
TO THE STUDENT SUCCESS
COMPLETION GRANT TO REFLECT
UPDATED CAL GRANT ESTIMATES.
SIXTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
ONGOING PROPOSITION A GENERAL
FUND TO ALIGN THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM OURS IRATE. BUT THE SCF
CREDIT RATE. AS OPPOSED TO NON
CREDIT RATING. TEN MILLION
ONGOING ABOVE WAS PROVIDED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TALK ABOUT THE
NEXT UP PROGRAM. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
PROVIDING- REVISING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO REMOVE THE STATUTORY
CAP ON DISTRICTS. AND ALLOW
ALLOCATIONS TO BE PROVIDED
SPECIFICALLY TO COLLEGES- THIS
IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE MORE
FLEXIBILITY ON HOW THE FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED. TEN MILLION TO
ESTABLISH THE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES SOME ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES. AND FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ON GOING TO
BACK FILL A DECREASE AND FEDERAL
MATCH FUNDING FOR FOSTER AND
KINSHIP CARE PROGRAMS. TURNING
TO STATE OPERATIONS THE MAYOR
VISION POSES AN INCREASE OF TWO
POINT SIX MILLION. NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. BUT THE CHANCES OFFICE%
REFLECTS SEVENTY POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION. OF
THE CRADLE TO GRAVE DATA SYSTEM
SUPPORT DISTRICTS TOWARDS
MEETING THE GOALS OUTLINED IN
THE MULTIROTOR MA'AM. ASSIST
COLLEGES WITH OFFERING
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING. AND
BUILD CAPACITY TO ACCOMMODATE
THE INCREASE AND CONTRACTS AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. FURTHER
THE MAYOR VISIONS SHIFTS TEN
POSITIONS THAT WERE POSED AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO BE FUNDED
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. TO BE FUNDED
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. THIS BRINGS THE
TOTAL BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSALS TO THREE POINT NINE
MILLION FOR TWENTY SIX POSITIONS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. WHAT HAPPENED WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU HELLO
GOOD MORNING PAUL STEEN HOUSING
WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE PAGE THREE OF THE L. A.
O. HAND OUT. COMPARES PROPOSED
SPENDING ON COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BETWEEN THE JANUARY BUDGET AND
THE MAY REVISION ALL OF MY
COMMENTS TO A FEW MAJOR MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS BUT HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. YOU MIGHT
HAVE. FIRST WE FIND MERIT WITH
FOCUS SEEN NEW ON GOING FUNDS ON
APPORTIONMENT INCREASES BOTH THE
COST OF LIVING. ADJUSTMENTS THE
COLAS AND DEBASING CREASES
BEYOND THE CALL OF THAT ARE IN
THE MAY REVISION. OKOLO WILL
HELP DISTRICTS AND EMPLOYEES
ADDRESS. OF RISING COST
PRESSURES AND THEN ADDING
FURTHER BASE MONEY TO
APPORTIONMENT SOON AS THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
ALSO WOULD HELP COLLEGES ADDRESS
RISING COSTS BUT ALSO WOULD HAVE
THE EFFECT OF FUNDING MORE
DISTRICTS BASED ON THE FORMULA.
RATHER THAN FUNNY THEM BASED ON
THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISIONS. WE
THINK THAT WOULD BE A GOOD THING
IT WOULD CREATE BETTER
INENTIVES FOR DISTRICTS TO
SERVE STUDENTS BETTER. THAT WE
THINK PROVIDING BASING CREASES
IS REASONABLE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CHOOSE A DIFFERENT AMOUNT
OF COURSE AND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING OR DECIDE
ON IS DIFFERENT SPLIT BETWEEN
THE BASIC ALLOCATION THAT MISTER
HANOVER MENTION. AND RATE-INCREASES AND YOU CAN MAKE THAT
DECISION BASED ON LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. THE MAY REVISION
FOCUSES ONE TIME FUNDS ON TWO
MAJOR PURPOSES YOU COULD SEE
THAT ON THE PAGE THREE UNDER ONE
TIME INITIATIVES YOU SEE THE TOP
TWO ROWS THERE. SO THERE'S
FUNDING FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND A DISCRETIONARY BLOCK GRANT
THAT WOULD ALLOW COLLEGES TO.
USE THE FUNDS TO ADDRESS LOCAL
NEEDS. ALTHOUGH WE FIND MERIT
WITH BOTH OF THESE PROPOSALS AS
YOU BUILD THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE AND YOUR OVERALL
STATE BUDGET PACKAGE. YOU MAY
WANT TO CHANGE THE ALLOCATION
AMOUNTS DEPENDING ON OVERALL
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES WERE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU AND STAFF
IN THE COMING WEEKS AS YOU MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SHOULD BE GOOD. YEAH. OKAY
PERFECT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THIRD TIME'S A CHARM WAS THAT
EVER AT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RECALL IS CANCERS OFFICE I WANT
TO FIRST THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR SOME OF THE CONTINUED
PRIORITIES THAT CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
OUTLINED INCLUDING CAL GRANTS
AND HOUSING AND I WANT TO FOCUS
ON A FEW AREAS- THAT- PROVIDE
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
ME COLLEGES I'LL BEGIN WITH A
ROAD MAP OUTLINED FOR CALIFORNIA
GIVE ME COLLEGES THERE'S GREAT
ALIGNMENT IN THE ROAD MAP IN THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS WHICH HAS
EXISTED SNCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
MANY DISTRICTS ALSO HAVE LOCAL
VISION GOALS THESE GOALS ARE
FOCUSED ON STUDENT EQUITY
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AND SUCCESS
AND RECOGNIZE THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE COLLEGES HAVE IN RISING
TIDES IT REDUCING REGIONAL
EQUITY GAPS AND ENSURING
ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND SO WE HAVE
STRONG SUPPORT IN THAT AND
BELIEVE IT WOULD PROVIDE GREATER
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN THE EFFORTS OF
OUR COLLEGES AND HAVE STATE
LEADERS JOIN US IN THESE
IMPORTANT EFFORTS AND
STRATEGIES. WITH REGARDS TO THE
SCF AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE PROPOSED A
BASE INCREASES AND PER STUDENT
FUNDING INCREASES ENSURE THAT
MORE OF OUR COLLEGES CAN
TRANSITION EFFECTIVELY TO THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
WHICH TENANTS INCLUDE EQUITY
SUCCESS I AND- MANY OF THE GOALS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHARES
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS CAN
TRANSFER- I EARNED A LIVING
WAGES. OR GRADUATE. WE ALSO- ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE A PROPOSAL BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR TWENTY
SIX POSITIONS LET ME SHARE A
LITTLE BIT WHY. THE CALIFORNIA
RECALL CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
CANNOT UTILIZE PROP NINETY
RESOURCES FOR POSITIONS OR ONE
OF THE ONLY SYSTEMS AND HIGHER
READ WERE THE ONLY SYSTEM AND
HIGHER READ THAT REQUIRES
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY JUST TO
HIRE ANY ONE PERSON. AND IN
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN WE'VE SEEN
AN INCREASE- OF PROGRAMS THAT WE
ADMINISTER FROM FIFTY NINE TO A
HUNDRED AND FIVE WOULD STILL
WITH THE SAME. POSITION OF
AUTHORITY OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN FIRST SYSTEM THAT
SERVES A HUNDRED SIXTEEN
COLLEGES A SEVENTY EIGHT AT
CENTERS SEVENTY THREE DISTRICTS
AND ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
STUDENTS. THESE POSITIONS ENSURE
THAT WE CAN EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT MANY OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S OWN PRIORITIES
INCLUDING RISING SCHOLARS-
INCLUDING TRANSFER ON AND
EQUITABLE PLACEMENT REFORM SOME
KEY EFFORTS THAT NOT ONLY CAN
HELP STUDENT SUCCESS BUT ENSURE
THAT WE ARE MEETING THE
DELIVERABLES THAT YOU EXPECT
FROM US. SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THESE AREAS. I WANT
TO WRAP UP BY SAYING THAT WE
STILL THINK- THAT THERE IS X.
EXTENSIVE OPPORTUNITY AS A
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY MENTIONED TO
LEVERAGE THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO
SUPPORT CAL GRANT REFORM THAT'S
STILL ONE OF THE AREAS AND PINCH
POINTS OF OUR STUDENTS SUCCESS.
64% OF STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SAY THAT FINANCIAL
AID AND LACK OF RESOURCES IS ONE
OF THEIR PRIMARY OBSTACLES TO
SUCCESS AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT
LEVERAGING AT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
FOR CAL GRANT REFORM IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE EQUITABLE
FRAMEWORK THAT HAS BEEN ALIGNED
BY. A. SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY. WITH REGARDS
TO HOUSING- WANT THAT'S A GREAT
USE OF ONE TIME RESOURCE SAYS AN
INVESTMENT IN THE FIVE PROPOSED
PROJECTS AND THE SEVEN ELIGIBLE
WOULD DOUBLE THE HOUSING THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AGAIN AND A GREAT USE-OF ONE TIME RESOURCES. AND
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR
COLLEGES WITH THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU QUESTIONS FOR A
COMMITTEE CALLS MR O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU. MY FIRST QUESTION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BOB
WHAT I'M LOOKING- THE OVERALL
THE ADDITIONS TO THE BUDGET
WHICH ARE POSITIVE A POSITIVE
DIRECTION- MY FEARS THAT JUST
DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH- AS THE
MEAT. LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU WHY
. WHY I BELIEVE THAT IF YOU LOOK
AT CPI EIGHT POINT FIVE PERSONS
STIRS INCREASES PERSONS WHAT
THANK TWO POINT SEVEN STIRS TO
POINT ABOUT TWO POINT THREE FIVE
ON AVERAGE IF YOU MIX THE TWO
SYSTEMS SO EIGHT POINT FIVE TWO
POINT THREE FIVE PLUS OTHER COST
PRESSURES UNIQUE. TO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SOME STAFFING
ISSUES- SOME DECLINING
ENROLLMENT CENTER SO THAT THEIR
YOU'RE WELL ABOVE 10% AND IF I
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS HERE. IT'S
AROUND EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
ISSUE PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT
NORTH OF THAT- OF ADDITIONAL
ONGOING MONIES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OF READY PROJECTS DRUM
ONE TIME I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE ONE TIME MONEY ON
SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
ON GOING MONEY. IT JUST DOESN'T
SEEM TO EVEN KEEP THEM UP WITH
LAST YEAR- DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT
ON THAT IN OTHER WORDS WHAT I'M
SAYING IS. THEIR COSTS ARE GOING
UP FASTER. THAN THEN THE
INCREASE IN IN IN IN THE BUDGET.
AS AS AS I SEE IT RIGHT HERE THE
PROPOSED- THE MAY REVISE. DO DO
YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT-
DANDARA BERMAN A FINANCE- SO I
THINK TO ADDRESS YOU'RE GOING TO
I THINK THE MEASURES AND STUFF
AND WHETHER THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURES BEING
FACED BY DISTRICTS- AND I THINK
TO THAT NO WE KNOW THAT THAT THE
MAY REVISION DOES REFLECT STRONG
USE OF ONGOING RESOURCES
AVAILABLE UNDERNEATH THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE. TO TRY TO HELP
DISTRICTS WITH THIS WHETHER IT'S
THE SIX POINT 56% COLA INCREASE
THE THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION ONGOING FOR BASING
CREASES AND THE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION WHICH WILL BE
A ONE TIME DOES PROVIDE A ONE
TIME IT DOES PROVIDE A FLEXIBLE
USE OF FINDINGS THAT THEY CAN
HELP DISTRICTS REDUCE THEIR LONG
TERM OBLIGATIONS SO. AND AGAIN
THE FUNDING IS AVAILABLE OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS SO THEN I THINK
THIS BUDGET DOES REPRESENT A
STRONG NEW INFLUX OF RESOURCES
TO THE PROPER TO THE TO
COMMUNICATE SYSTEM AND AGAIN-
REFLECTS A PRUDENT USE OF
ONGOING ONE TIME FUNDING-
UNDERNEATH THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE WAS A
DECENT START I'VE JUST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE NOT NECESSARILY A
GOOD FINISH BUT I HOPE WE CAN
GET A GOOD FINISH AS WELL. AS
THE PROCESS MOVES FOR BUT I JUST
HOPE PEOPLE ON THIS COMMITTEE
EVEN PAY ATTENTION TO THE FACT
THAT WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE IS
COSTS ARE GOING UP OR GOING UP
AND THEN WE HEAR- HISTORIC
DOLLARS WELL HISTORIC ADDITION
DURING HISTORIC INFLATION AND
STORK OTHER COST PRESSURES
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN. THAT A
SCHOOL IS- THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
SYSTEM IS GETTING MORE MONEY AND
JUST ANOTHER QUESTION PROBABLY
FOR THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I
BELIEVE IT'S SEVENTEEN NEW
POSITIONS TO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE COULD YOU MAYBE WALK ME
THROUGH I THAT WOULD BE. YEAH A
LOT MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL- IN MANY WAYS THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OPEN NOW WE
ARE WORKING WE WORK UNDER THE
CAL H. R. MODEL WHICH HAS US
THAT THREE DAYS AS A TELEWORK
AGREEMENT A JUST A PIRATE I JUST
THINK THAT'S CRAZY SHOULD BE IN
THAT BUILDING WORKING TO SERVE
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
CLASSROOMS ARE OPEN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SHOULD BE
OPEN AS IS. THIS COMMITTEE BUT
THAT'S MY OPINION THAT Q. GOING
. THERE THERE IS CHANCES ARE.
SAM AND THEIR TWENTY TWO TO
THREE BY RIP. ACT REQUESTED
THIRTY ONE POSITIONS. AND SO THE
TWENTY SIX THAT YOU SEE HERE
REALLY ARE ALIGNED- WITH NEW
PROGRAMS AND COMMITMENTS
DELIVERABLES. THAT HAVE BEEN
ADDED OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
AND SO THESE POSITIONS- WOULD
SPECIALIZE IN- VARIOUS-
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIES
INCLUDING TRANSFER REFORM-
INCLUDING FOCUSING ON SOME OF
THE- PROGRAMS THAT SERVE.
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS SINCE
AND STUDENTS THAT. ARE IN
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
INCLUDING- RISING SCHOLARS
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OVERALL BASIC
NEEDS STRATEGIES ACROSS OUR
CAMPUSES. THERE'S ALSO A FOCUS
ON BACCALAUREATE DEGREES WHICH
IS- OF. SOME BEGAN AS A LEAD
FROM AN ASSEMBLY BILL- THAT
REQUIRES AN EXTENSIVE REVIEW
PROCESS IN COLLABORATION WITH.
OUR FOR YOUR PARTNERS AND SO-
MANY OF THESE POSITIONS AND
HAPPY TO WALK THROUGH IN MORE
DETAIL- UP WITH A WHAT THESE
WOULD TO. OVERALL AS AN AGENCY
WE REPORT ON AN AVERAGE OF OVER
TWO HUNDRED HOURS WEEKLY
OVERTIME. AND SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS REALLY REDUCE
THAT- AGAIN BECAUSE IN SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN WE'VE SEEN- AN
INCREASE FROM FIFTY NINE
PROGRAMS THAT WE ADMINISTER TO
A- HUNDRED AND NINE. AND SO
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO KEEP PACE
WITH THE NEW ADDED WORKLOAD- AND
THESE POSITIONS WOULD HELP DO
THAT. OKAY THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT PERSPECTIVE BUT-
REALLY WHETHER MUCH RUBBER MEETS
THE ROAD IS NOT INSIDE THE
CHANCES OF HIS OUT OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS THE
STATE RIGHT. THAT'S WHERE THEY
NEED THE SERVICES. SO I JUST.
SEEMS LIKE A LOT TO ME TODAY BUT
WILL. HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT I PRE EIGHT. THE
PERSPECTIVE YOU- AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT QUESTION FOR THE
I THINK BY THE L. A. L. SO I
THINK THAT THE REVENUE FOR PROP
NINETY EIGHT IS SIMILAR FROM
WHAT'S IN FINANCE FROM WHAT YOU
HAD ALLOCATED IN WHAT ARE. KIND
OF SPREAD SHEETS AND ANALYSIS
HAS PER PROP NINETY EIGHT. AND I
THINK THE DIFFERENCE IS. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS HAS- MORE ONE
TIME WITH ONGOING MONEY. SAID
THEYUSE THE USE OF BIG CHUNK TO
PUT IN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
WHAT FOR IT WHICH IS A ONE TIME
THING WITH ONGOING MONEY SO THAT
YOU KNOW YOU CAN USE THAT OTHER
PLACES WELL WORD OF COURSE
EVALUATING THAT. AND THEN IF WE
HAVE THIS OTHER DEBATE ABOUT
THIS WHAT MR O'DONNELL PROBABLY
KNOWS THAT EVEN WITH THIS YOU
KNOW COSTS HAVE GONE UP- YOU
KNOW COSTS FOR DISTRICTS
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION RETIREMENT
COSTS AND SO FORTH SO EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE HAVING THIS
HISTORIC BOB YOU KNOW IT'S
ALMOST EVEN WITH WHAT THEIR
COSTS ARE SO THEN THAT OTHER
PIECE THIS EQUATION IS THIS
FUNDING FORMULA AND SOME
DISTRICTS WERE. ARMLESS AS WE
TRY TO IMPLEMENT THIS FROM A FEW
YEARS AGO. WHERE ARE WE AT AND
WHAT WHAT. MORE WOULD BE NEED TO
GET ALL DISTRICTS TO BE.
SENSUALLY HOLE WITH THIS FUNDING
FORMULA WITH THE WHOLE HOLD
HARMLESS STUFF SO IT WHAT WHAT
MORE RESOURCES WILL BE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE- IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE FUNDING FORMULA CHANGES.
SURE WE'LL JUST REGROUP WITH
REGARD YEAR- FIRST- INQUIRY ON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT THAT'S
CORRECT THE- THERE IS A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT CAN CAN BE
SPENT IN AN ONGOING WAY I'M
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WHAT
THE GOVERNOR CHOOSES WITH NAY
REVISION IS TO DEDICATE A FAIR
AMOUNT OF THAT TO ONE TIME
PURPOSES KIND OF A- CUSHION IN
CASE THERE IS A DOWNTURN FUTURE
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO BACK IN AND
MAKE PROGRAMMATIC CUTS YU NOTED
TO BASE. PROGRAM SET BUT THAT'S
A DECISION FOR LEGISLATURES SIDE
LEGISLATURE OF COURSE DECIDES ON
ALLOCATIONS SO YOU MAY DECIDE TO
PUT MORE MONEY INTO ON GOING-
PURPOSES FOR THAT COMMITTEE
COLLEGES ARE K. TWELVE FOR THAT
MATTER- THEN THE GOVERNOR DOES
ON THE STUDENT CENTERED. FUNDING
FORMULA. ARE CURRENTLY THERE IS
ONE DISTRICT THAT IS ACTUALLY
FUNDED BY THE FORMULA. THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
THE REST ARE FUNDED BY WHAT'S
KNOWN AS STABILITY. OR ANOTHER
PROVISION A HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION SO ONLY ONE. WE'VE
STARTED LOOKING IT AT MODELING
AND WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- COULD DO- THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MORON BUT- IT. IT LOOKS LIKE
WITH WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL OR AND SOME MORE MONEY
IT COULD BE. IT COULD MAKE A
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS IN GETTING.
DISTRICTS OFF STABILITY AND OFF
HOLD HARMLESS AND ACTUALLY
FUNDED BY THE FORMULA SO THAT
SOMETHING WILL BE WORKING MORE
WITH FINANCE IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE C. ON DOING SOME OF THIS
MODELING AND WORKING WITH STAFF
BUT- IT LOOKS PROMISING AS A AS
A WAY TO PUT SOME MONEY INTO.
THE BASIC ALLOCATION OR PUT
MONEY INTO THESE BASE RATE
INCREASES AGAIN BEYOND THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT. AND BE
ABLE TO TAKE A LOT OF DISTRICTS
OFF THAT HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION
THEY'VE BEEN KIND OF STUCK ON
FOR YEARS AND GET HIM FUNDED BY
THE FORMULA. MISTER CHECK THANK
YOU FOLLOW UP QUESTION FOR MR
O'DONNELL IT YET. I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HAVE THIS NUMBER. IT IS
DO YOU HAVE A FIGURE A NUMBER-
AS FAR AS WHAT WHAT IS THE
GOVERNOR. IN IN THIS MAY REVISE
HOW MUCH IS- BEING STATED AS ONE
TIME WHEN IT'S REALLY ONGOING.
DO YOU HAVE A NUMBER TODAY I
DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CAN GET THAT
WOULD YOU BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
KEY TO THIS WHOLE CONVERSATION.
HOW MUCH IS BEING SCORED AS ONE
TIME ACTUALLY ON GOING IT COULD
BE SCORED IS ON GOING YEAH
SOMETHING YEAH THAT'S THAT'S
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. THAT I MEAN THAT
SPEAKS TO. THE ENTIRE. THE YOU
KNOW. K. FOURTEEN PRE K.
FOURTEEN. SYSTEM YEAH HI. WELL I
GUESS I RECALLS WITH THIS BALL
IS ON THE AGENDA. ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE SAY IS
THAT OF THE ONE POINT ONE
BILLION I'M GOING TO PROPOSE
ONLY FOR TWENTY FIVE SO THAT'S
YOU KNOW. FIVE AND SIX HUNDRED
PLUS THAT'S NOT IS THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE. WELL I'M THINKING
ABOUT OVERALL PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT WHAT WE HAD LOOKED AT WAS
ABOUT TEN BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE. IN MAY REVISE FOR ONE
TIME PURPOSES AND TEN BILLION IN
ON GOING. AND I WOULD NEED TO GO
BACK AND LOOK TO SEE WHAT. WHERE
THE GOVERNOR ACTUALLY LANDED
WITH THE MAY REVISION AND HOW
MUCH OF THE- THAT LATTER GROUP
THAT THAT GROUP TO COULD. OF
MONEY THAT COULD BE IS AN
ONGOING PURPOSE. THE GOVERNOR IN
FACT SHOWS TO USE FOR ONE TIME
PURPOSES OKAY. MISTER CHAIR YES
SIR FOR CLARIFICATION. THEN THE
QUESTION TO YOU IS I KNOW YOU'RE
NOT YOU NEED TO GO BACK AND
REFERENCE NUMBERS EXCITED DO
SOME RESEARCH. COME TO LOOK AT-
CERTAINLY K. FOURTEEN THE ENTIRE
NINETY EIGHT AND MAYBE EVEN THAT
SEGREGATED. THANK YOU. SO BACK
TO BACK TO THE QUESTION ABOUT
FUNDING FORMULA WAS THERE A
NUMBER YOU CAN GIVE US WHAT DO
WE NEED TO. PROPERLY FUNDS THE
CHANGES IN THE FUNDING FORMULA
TO ACCOMMODATE DISTRICTS AND NOT
HAVE ANY HARDSHIPS ON THEIR END
. THIS IS SOMETHING. WE LOOKED
AT RECENTLY AND IT WAS A BASE.
BASIC ALLOCATION SO ALLOCATION
FOR FIXED COSTS YOU COULD DO
SOMETHING LIKE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND THEN
YOU COULD DO A INCREASES IT
RATES THE ACTUAL RATES BEYOND
COLA OF SEVERAL PERCENTAGE
POINTS YOU KNOW MAYBE 6% OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. AND THAT
WOULD GET. THAT WOULD GET THEM
ALL BUT MAY BE. EIGHT OR SO
DISTRICTS OFF HOLD HARMLESS- BUT
THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS YOU CAN
DO THAT YOU COULD DO LESS OF THE
BASIC ALLOCATION AGAIN LESS
MONEY FOR FIXED COSTS. AND MORE
ON THE- ON THE BASE RATE
INCREASES AND OF COURSE YOU HAVE
TO MAKE ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT WHAT
WHAT'S IN ROME IT GONNA DO IS
ENROLLMENT GOING TO COME BACK
AND HOW MUCH IS IT COULD COME
BACK AND- OUR OUTCOMES AMONG.
STUDENTS GOING TO CHANGE BECAUSE
ALL THAT GOES INTO THE FORMULA-
BUT- AGAIN IF YOU GET AN IDEA
IT'S NOT THIS IS WHAT THE
GOVERNOR FOR POSING AS NOT. IT
IS FAIRLY SUBSTANTIAL I CAN MAKE
YOU KNOW SOME SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN GETTING DISTRICTS
OFF THE HOLD HARMLESS AND FUNNY
BY THE FORMULA. OKAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE. WELL I
JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP FROM YOUR
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR BECAUSE
YOU'RE RIGHT TO BE AGENDA DOES
SAY IT'S ONE POINT ONE BILLION
THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR FROM PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND THE MAY REVISE
HAS FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION BEING USED. FOR ONGOING
. SO FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHY NOT MORE ON GOING-
THE SERVER I I'D I WOULD. THAT
THIS IS A PRUDENT BALANCE AT ONE
TIME AND ONGOING RESOURCES
UNDERNEATH THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE GIVEN
GIVEN UNCERTAINTIES ABOUT THE
FUTURE- SYSTEM IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OF WHATEVER
KIND OF PRUDENT BALANCE OF ONE.
FRATELLO THEN I THERE AREAS WERE
WE'RE WOULD WRECK TO MORE ON
GOING. TO BE MORE PRUDENT TO AND
HAVE A BETTER BALANCE. I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE A SPECIFIC AMOUNT
IN MIND. WE ARE A BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT. RISK OF RECESSION AND WE
WROTE ABOUT THAT IN UR ANALYSIS
THAT WAS JUST RELEASED. SO WE
THINK IT IS PRUDENT TO. PUT MORE
MONEY INTO K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION
ONGOING PURPOSE PUT MORE MONEY
INTO THE- FORMULAS OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA FOR K.
TWELVE IN THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA. FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT KEEPING IN MIND
THAT THERE IS. SOMEWHAT OF A
REST FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE OF DOING SO YOU HAVE
THE RISK AGAIN IF THERE'S A
RECESSION AND ALSO. COURSES THIS
ISSUE WITH THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT THAT THE
STATE FACES AND SO. DOLLARS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE USES WITH EVEN
WITHIN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FOR SALAS CRUCIBLE PURPOSES MY
CAPITAL OUTLAY CAN HELP. THE
STATE WITH HIS OVERALL STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT
REQUIREMENTS SO LEGISLATURE HAS
A LOT TO KIND OF KEEP IN MIND
AND SO WILL BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU IN THE COMING WEEKS I
COMING UP WITH THAT RIGHT
BALANCE. ONE TIME AND ONGOING
WITHIN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
WHAT MIGHT BE SELL EXCLUDABLE
WITHIN PROP NINETY EIGHT OR
OUTSIDE OF PROP NINETY EIGHT TO
HELP WITH. THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS WHEN A
REQUIREMENT KEEPING IN MIND OF
COURSE. SOME INDICATORS SHOW
THAT A RECESSION OF SOME
MAGNITUDE COULD HAPPEN WITHIN
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS SO
THINKING ABOUT RESERVES AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BOTH. OKAY
THANK YOU SING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS UNDER OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WILL GO BACK TO THE TOP
AND- HOLD HOLD HOLD OPEN
COMMUNICATIVE SOME WILL GO BACK
TO THE TOP AND GO TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS.
JARGON MISTER. YES PLEASE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED MORE MISTER CHAIR
AND- MEMBERS JACK'S WORLD PUBLIC
FINANCE I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU ALL
THIS MORNING- ABOUT THE MAY
REVISION AS IT RELATES TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA- THE MAY
REVISION MAINTAINS. THE 5% BASE
INCREASE OF TWO HUNDRED POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. ANY OTHER INVESTMENTS
INTRODUCED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. IN JANUARY AS
PART OF OUR MULTI YOUR CONTACT
WITH THE UC. THE MAY REVISION
ALSO PROPOSES A NUMBER OF NEW
INVESTMENTS IN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. I'LL BEGIN BY
DISCUSSING THE CONCEPTS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS BROUGHT
FORWARD THEY ARE. THREE HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR A NEW INSTITUTE FOR
IMMUNOLOGY AND IMMUNOTHERAPY AT
UCLA. MINISTRATION ALSO PLANS TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THIS PURPOSE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO EXCUSE ME THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWENTY AT TWENTY FOUR FISCAL
YEAR- THIRTEEN MILLION ONGOING
FREE- YOU SEE LABOR CENTERS
SPECIFICALLY- THIS WAS INTENDED
TO PROVIDE. THREE MILLION EACH
TO THE THREE LABOR CENTER SINCE
SYSTEM. THREE MILLION FOR
ACTIVITIES AT CAMPUSES WITHOUT
CENTERS AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EACH FOR BOTH
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
PROGRAMS THAT THE TWO CAMPUSES
THAT HAVETHEM- FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE CENTER
FOR RESPONSIBLE DECENTRALIZED
INTELLIGENCE. AT UC BERKELEY TO
FUND RESEARCH- AND PROGRAMMING
AROUND THE BLOCK CHAIN AND WEBER
THREE TECHNOLOGY- FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE RALPH J. BUNCHE CENTER FOR.
AMERICAN STUDIES UCLA- TWO
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR YOU SEE FIRED VISORS IN
ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT IS
PLANNED FOR THIS PURPOSE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY. THREE TWENTY FOUR
FISCAL YEAR- ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION- ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND OF
WHICH IS ON GOING. TO INTEGRATE
MEMBERS OF. THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES AND TO THE
ASSIST PLATFORM THIS PLATFORM IS
A- A PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH US
YOU CAN TRANSFER. WITH CRITICAL
INFORMATION ON HOW CLASSES AND
COURSES THEY'VE EARNED WILL
TRANSFER TO A PARTICULAR
INSTITUTION- AND AN INCREASE OF-
TWO POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO BACK FOR THE CLEANING
PROPOSITION FIX FIFTY SIX
TOBACCO TAX REVENUES. THAT
SUPPORT A FIXED ALLOCATION OF
FORTY MILLION- FOR GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION AT UC- THIS
INCREASE WILL MAINTAIN THE LEVEL
OF RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
GRADUATION A GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION- AT THAT FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR LEVEL- THE MAYOR VISION
ALSO INCLUDES A FEW CHANGES TO
HOW EXISTING PROPOSALS AND
PROGRAMS OPERATE- THE MOST
NOTABLE CHANGES INCLUDE ADDING
LANGUAGE DIRECTING YOU SEE. TO
COORDINATE WITH STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS TO GUIDETHE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR CLIMATE RESEARCH- THAT
WE OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
TO BETTER ALIGN WITH THE STATE'S
RESEARCH NEEDS. ARE THE MAYOR
VISION ALSO ADDED LANGUAGE TO
THE- OVERALL ONE TIME PLANET
PACKAGE A TO PROVIDE LEGAL
CLARITY OVER ITS USES AS IT
RELATES TO UC'S NONPROFIT
STATUS- ANOTHER AYE KEY LANGUAGE
CHANGES THE EXPANSION OF FUNDS.
PROVIDED FOR BASIC NEEDS TO
INCLUDE HYGIENE RODUCTS. AND
THERE ARE- ALSO SEVERAL
TECHNICAL CHANGES ADDRESSED IN
OUR MAY LETTER- THAT I CAN
DISCUSS THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. AGAIN I DO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE VISION
WITH YOU THIS MORNING AND I-
ALLOW LET THE PART. NEXT
PRESENTER- SPEAK. THANK YOU L.
L. GRAYSON CONCENTRA SALLY- IN
CASE IT'S HELPFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE IF YOU'RE WORKING FROM
R. ELLIE- HAND OUT THE LOOKS
LIKE THIS IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
ONE OF THAT HAND OUT YOU'LL SEE
ALL THE GENERAL FUND- PROPOSALS
FOR YOU SEE UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND UNDER THE MAY
REVISION AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO
FOCUS ON WHAT'SNEW IN THE MAY
REVISION THAT THIRD COLUMN SHOWS
THE CHANGE BETWEEN THE TWO
PACKAGES- AS IMMIGRATION NOTED
YOU KNOW THE LARGEST PROPOSAL
HERE. AS OF TO PROVIDE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THREE
HUNDRED MILLION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN THE-
BUT YOUR PLUS ONE. FOR A NEW UC
LOS ANGELES INSTITUTE. FOR
IMMUNOLOGY AND IMMUNOTHERAPY. SO
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME OF FOCUS MY
COMMENTS ON THAT PROPOSAL. THAN
HAPPY TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS ON ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THAT COME UP. NOW THIS PROPOSAL
IN PARTICULAR ON THE FOCUS ON
CAPITAL OUTLAY IT'S A COMMON
THEME THROUGHOUT YOUR AGENDA
THIS THIS HEARING OF MY MANY
OTHER SEGMENTS THE LARGEST
PROPOSALS ARE ONE TIME CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSAL'S. GENERALLY WE
THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO FOCUS
ON A ONE TIME CAPITAL OUTLAY
SPENDING THIS YEAR- STATE IS
CURRENTLY FACING SOME CHALLENGES
MEETINGS BUDGETARY REQUIREMENTS.
AND SPENDING FUNDING ON CAPITAL
OUTLAY HELPS WITH THAT. BECAUSE
THOSE FUNDS ARE EXCLUDED FROM
THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT
CALCULATION. THAT SAID THIS
PROPOSAL IS A BIT OF A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY IN OUR VIEW. ALL THE
PROPOSAL- DOES NOT SEEM TO ALIGN
WITH MANY OF THE PRESSING
CAPITAL OUTLAY ISSUES THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS DISCUSSED IN
PREVIOUS HEARINGS IT DOESN'T
APPEAR TO ADDRESS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OR SEISMIC
RENOVATION. IT DOES NOT ADDRESS
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING WHICH
IS A TOPIC THAT I COMMITTEES
DISCUSSED A LOT. IT ALSO- BASED
ON OUR UNDERSTANDING DOES NOT
APPEAR TO BE PRIMARILY FOCUSED
ON EXPANDING IN MOMENT CAPACITY
AT. UC OR CSU. THE PROPOSAL ALSO
APPEARS TO OFFER SOME SERVICES
THAT ARE THAT SEEMS SIMILAR TO
THE SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED
EXISTING USUALLY INSTITUTES. AND
IN GENERAL IS A THERE'S JUST A
LOT OF SIGNIFICANT LACK OF
DETAILS THAT THE MATURATION OF
PROVIDED ON THIS PROPOSAL. WE
THINK THIS IS THE KIND OF OPPOSE
A LEGISLATURE COULD REJECT THIS
YEAR. AND THEN REDISTRIBUTE
THOSE FUNDS TOWARDS OTHER HIGH
CAPITAL PRIORITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU L. AT UC GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN GUARDIAN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AND SAY EVER
TENANTS REPRESENTING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
PROPOSAL TO STRENGTHEN TO
UNIVERSITY AND BETTER SERVE OUR
STUDENTS TO A FIVE YEAR FUNDING
COMPACT THAT OFFERS RELIABLE
FUNDING SUPPORT FOR CAMPUSES
COUPLED WITH AMBITIOUS POLICY
GOALS. RELIABLE ON GOING STATE
FUNDING INCREASES TOGETHER WITH
OUR TUITION STABILITY PLAN ARE
IMPORTANT TO UC CAMPUSES AND
COVERING COST INCREASES AND
ENSURING STUDENT SUCCESS THROUGH
MORSE MORE COURSE OFFERINGS
ADVISING AND OTHER SERVICES. UP
WE FULLY SUPPORT THE SHARED
GOALS ARTICULATED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED COMPACT
WHICH FOCUSES ON ACCESS SUCCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND INTER
SEGMENTAL COLLABORATION THE
UNIVERSITY UNIVERSITY SEIZE THE
GOALS OUTLINED IN THE MULTI YEAR
COMPACT AS A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE UNIVERSITY
ON TO WAYS TO ACHIEVE THE
OUTLINED AMBITIOUS GOALS WHICH
REPRESENT THE IDEALS WE WOULD
ALL LIKE TO SEE A CHEAT. THE
COMPACT INCLUDES ANNUAL
COMPREHENSIVE REQUIREMENTS. IN
ADDITION TO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FEELS COMFORTABLE
WITH THE UNIVERSITIES PROGRESS
TOWARDS THE SHARED GOALS WE
WOULD PROVIDE BRIEFINGS THE
LEGISLATORS AND THEIR STAFF- IN
TERMS OF THE UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET
REQUESTS- THAT I HOPE THIS
COMMITTEE WILL CONSIDER- WE DID
HAVE SOME ON GOING FUNDING
REQUEST FOR STUDENTS SUPPORT
INCLUDING SAY PAP. UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS SUPPORT AND A CARCERAL
SYSTEM IMPACTED STUDENTS AS WELL
AS THE UC CANCER CONSORTIUM AND
WE- THE UC REGENTS ARE
REQUESTING ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS BOTH FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
SEISMIC RETROFITS- AND CLASSROOM
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS WE'RE
ALSO REQUESTING NINE MILLION ONE
TIME FOR. PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL
HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU UP
THE FEW QUESTIONS HERE AT THE
GET GO SO THAT THE COMPACT AS
FAR AS THE LEGAL THRESHOLD THERE
REALLY IS NOTHING THAT WE ARE
PUTTING IN THE BUDGET THE
COMPACT IS A BASICALLY AN
AGREEMENT WHAT THE GOVERNOR
WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE EVERY
JANUARY IN THE JANUARY BUDGET.
SO OUTSIDE OF THE ENROLLMENT
TARGETS THERE'S NOTHING. IN THE
BUDGET EVERY YEAR. STATUTORILY
ABOUT THE COMPACT SEKARANG.
MISTER CHAIR I BELIEVE. YEAH
OKAY SO OF THAT THE ONE THING
THAT IS IN THERE IS THE
ENROLLMENT TARGET WHICH WE-
SUPPORT HAVING. AN ACTUAL
NUMBER- BECAUSE WE DID GET KINDA
HOODWINK LAST YEAR BY THE UC
WHERE THE SPEAKER IN THE PROTEST
MANILA JUST NATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR WE'RE SUPER EXCITED
ABOUT IN A ROMAN NUMBER OF SIX
THOUSAND AND IT CAME BACK LIKE
WHAT'S THAT'S GOING TO BE COUPLE
YEARS OUT AND DOUBLE COUNTED THE
NON RESIDENT RESIDENT TRANSFER
AND SO. WE WANT TO HAVE THIS IN
WRITING EVERY YEAR GOING FORWARD
THE ENROLLMENT PERIOD- AND THEN
I WILL SAY THAT THE 1% IS A IS A
GREAT START. BUT WE THINK THAT
THERE IS- AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
REALLY NOT A LOT MORE MONEY TO
GO OUT AND HAVE A HIGHER NUMBER
MAYBE EVEN 2% AND YOU KNOW WE
SEE THIS YEAR THAT. AS SAID
EARLIER AT UC ONLY BETWEEN TEN
AND 30% OF OUR- QUALIFIED-
APPLICANTS- GET IN. WE HEAR IT
ALL THE TIME FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS I HEAR FROM A
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE I'M
NOT GONNA NAME WHO THEY ARE
WHOSE. WHOSE A SON OR DAUGHTER.
AT THE AMAZING- GRADES- THE
DREAM SCHOOL WAS YOU IT WAS
UCLA. THEY GOT INTO IVY LEAGUE
SCHOOLS BUT COULDN'T GET INTO.
THE SCHOOL HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AT UCLA SO THAT IS IT IS IT TOP-
PRAYER THEY WERE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- PRIORITIZE- AS FAR
AS- ENROLLMENT AND ACCESS A
COUPLE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS- ONE
WE'LL GET TO THIS LATER WITH-
WITH. MR NATE COMMISSION
PROPOSAL BUT WITH ENROLLMENT-
NEEDS WE NEED OF COURSE STUDENT
HOUSING WHICH YOU KNOW IS A TOP
PRIORITY OF THE C. AND-
RESOURCES FOR CAMPUS GROWTH SO.
THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS HERE FOR A ONE TIMER
PREPARATION AT THE UCLA-
INSTITUTE OF IMMUNOLOGY AND
IMMUNOTHERAPY I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THIS REALLY MEANS- AND I GUESS
WHAT I'M WONDERING- IF ARE THESE
. MONEY IS GOING TO HELP EXPAND
ENROLLMENT AT UCLA. THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION WILL HELP EXPAND
INVOLVEMENT SO THE QUESTIONS FOR
UCLA UC SO DO YOU THINK MISS-
SAY HAD THAT THESE THESE DOLLARS
WILL HELP EXPAND ENROLLMENT AT
UCLA- THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
TERM MCCARTY- DO YOU PROPOSED
CENTER AT UCLA IS NOT IN THE
CAMPUS LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT
PLAN. AND THUS I AM ON CERTAIN
AT THIS TIME IF WILL IF IT WILL
ADD ANY CLASSROOM SPACE I'LL
TAKE OUT THE NOW SO CONVERSELY.
DO YOU THINK IF WE PUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
CAPITAL. TO EXPAND- FACILITIES
THAT MERCED AND RIVERSIDE AS A
MISTER MEDINA AND HAD THE MISTER
OF ARTISTS MADE ME TOUCH ON A
BIT. WITH THAT HELP EXPAND
ENROLLMENT AT UC. OF YES SIR
THAT WOULD BECAUSE THOSE
BUILDINGS CONTAIN CLASSROOMS AND
ARE MORE OUR STUDENT SERVICES
FOCUSED. YES I THINK IT JUST
GOES BACK TO COMMONSENSE. WE
HAVE A BUDGET FOR YOU SEE WE
HAVE A MASSIVE NEED FOR MORE
FACILITIES AND MORE HOUSING. WE
HERE AT WE HAVE NINETY NINE
BILLION DOLLARS. BUNCH OF IT ONE
TIME EVER SPENDING ON THINGS
THAT DON'T EQUATE TO THE NEED
SELL. THESE DON'T MIX WHICH
LEADS TO FRUSTRATION AMONG
LAWMAKERS AND THEIR CONSTITUENTS
SO- DULY NOTED TAT WEEK THAT
CERTAINLY I THINK THE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT. AS FAR AS THE- AS
FAR AS THE NOTION FOR. DEBT FREE
COLLEGE THAT'S VERY MUCH SOME
MUSIC TO OUR EARS THAT THROUGH
IS. SPOKEN ABOUT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S- COMPACT IDEA FOR HIS
ANNUAL JANUARY BUDGET- WE THINK
A LOT OF THAT IS FINANCIAL AID.
WITH THE STUDENT COMMISSIONER AT
TALK TO IN A IN A SACK IN THE%
SECOND. BUT YOU SEE ACT WHAT IS
IT I KNOW MR DRAKE SAID THAT HE
HAS A GOAL OF. WITHIN A DECADE%
OR SO TO HAVE ALL UC GRADUATE
HOW DO YOU SEE AS A DEBT FREE
INSTITUTIONS SO. HOW WOULD THAT
PLAY OUT WITH. STATE ALLOCATION
AND STUDENT FEES FOR EXAMPLE
FROM UC. OR IS HE COUNTING ON
ARE YOU GUYS COUNTING ON US TO
DO SOMETHING BIG WITH THE- IN
THE WITH THE CAL GRANT MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP REFORM. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DEBT
FREE PLAN IS RELIANT FIRST OF
ALL IT'S LIMITED TO CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STUDENTS SO WE WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A DEBT FREE
UNIVERSITY IT'S FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STUDENTS- AND IT IS
RELIANT ON THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP REFORM THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED LAST YEAR AND
A FULL FUNDING OFF THAT. SO YES
IT IS RELIANT ON THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUING TO PUT MONEY TOWARDS
FINANCIAL AID PLANS WE'RE ALSO
HOPING THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL EXPAND THE PELL
GRANT- IN THE FUTURE THAT WOULD
ALSO HELP US IN THE IN THAT
GOAL- AND IT IS ALSO RELIANT ON
THE STUDENTS MAINTAINING A SELF
HELP LEVEL. WHICH WAS SET LST
YEAR IN STATUTE BY THE
LEGISLATURE SO THE STUDENTS
WOULD STILL HAVE TO EITHER WORK
AND THEY IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
WORK THEY CAN STILL BORROW BUT
WE WANT THERE TO BE A DEBT FREE
OPTION FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE YEAH. I
THINK THAT'S AMAZING I JUST
WANNA POINT OUT ONE SIGNIFICANT
IRONY HERE- ONE IS YEAH WE THINK
THAT THERE SHOULD BE DEBT FREE
COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA. WILL BE
NICE TO HAVE FREE COLLEGE BUT
YOU KNOW I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S
WORTH THE TAXPAYERS SUBSIDIZING.
MY KIDS HOPEFULLY WHEN THE GOOD
YOU SEE WHEN THEY FOR TUITION I
THINK WE SHOULD USE OUR SCARCE
RESOURCES ELSEWHERE BUT HAVING
DEBT FREE IS WHAT YOU JUST SAID
SO STUDENTS WOULD HAVE TO. THE
FAMILY PAYS THEIR ESTIMATED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION BASED UPON
THEIR INCOME THE STUDENTS WORK
FIFTEEN HOURS A WEEK AND WE
PROVIDE ALREADY WE PROVIDE
TUITION- ESSENTIALLY ASSISTANCE%
FOR PRETTY MUCH EVERY STUDENT
NEED BUT IT'S THE NON TUITION.
COSTS SO WE NEED- THIS THIS CAL
GRANT FINANCIAL AID REFORM AND
SO DO YOU SEE AN ADMINISTRATION
TALK ABOUT THIS AND PRAISE THIS.
BUT THEN IN THIS IN A COMMISSION
THEY DON'T FIND THAT THING THAT
YOU NEED TO GET DEBT FREE
COLLEGE SO THE QUESTION IS FOR
FINANCE HOW CAN WE TALK ABOUT
THIS PASSED THE DEBT FREE E.
COLLEGE FOR. SEE IF YOU DON'T DO
THE THINGS THAT YOU SEE IS
SAYING IS NEEDED. TO MAKE
COLLEGE DEBT FREE FOR YOU SEE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES. THE
COMPACT DOES ESTABLISH A GOAL OF
CREATING THAT FREE PATHWAYS- I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET THAT CONTAINED
TWO OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSIONS OF FINANCIAL AID IN
STATE HISTORY. BOTH THE
EXPANSION OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS AND
THE EXPANSION OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP SO PROGRESS IS
BEING MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS A STORK INVESTMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE IN STUDENT AID
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE-
SEGMENTS. TO KEEPS COLLEGE
AFFORDABLE AND ATTAINABLE FOR A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT STUDENTS. I
THOUGHT I'D LIKE THAT AND THEN
TRYING TO FOCUS ON HOW THE UC
AND CSU CAN. WORK ON THEIR SIDE
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY WHETHER IT'S
GRADUATION RATES FOR YOU CSU OR
COST FOR. FREE FOR YOU SEE. BUT
A BIG PIECE OF THE PUZZLE HERE
WAS FINISHING THE JOB WITH. WITH
FINANCIALLY REFORM SO LAST YEAR
WE GOT HALF WE GOT HALF A LOW I
KNOW THAT SOME PEOPLE WERE
DISAPPOINTED I SAID NOW IT'S
AMAZING WE GOT. HALF A CUP OF
WATER SO LET'S GO GET THE OTHER
HALF. THAT THIS TO MEDINA WAS
HERE HE THIS IS HIS. SISTER'S
WORK AS FINAL YEAR TALK GETTING
THIS OVER THE FINISH LINE. SO IS
THERE A COMMITMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO DO THE OTHER
HALF OF THIS TO FINISH THE
FINANCIALLY REFORM TO ALLOW. YOU
SEE IN THE SEGMENTS TO OFFER
DEBT FREE EDUCATION. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- A REVISION
PLAN- CONTINUES INVESTMENTS FROM
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACTING LOOKING FOR TO
CONVERSATION ON ON BUT AS AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS. OKAY
I THINK YOU JUST. LAST YEAR'S
AGREEMENT AND IT'S OUR HOPE
AGAIN THAT WITH THIS. AT A
MASSIVE SPIKE IN REVENUE SOMEONE
TIME SOME ON GOING THAT WE COULD
FOCUS ON ONE OF THE TOP
PRIORITIES IN THE ASSEMBLY.
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY YOU KNOW
THE COST OF COLLEGE IS GOING UP
IT'S NOT TUITION ITS HOUSING
BOOKS TRANSPORTATION AND SO
FORTH SO- OUR STUDENTS NEED IT
OUR FAMILIES THE THAT OUR
ECONOMY NEEDS IT. SO THAT THAT
THIS IS A TOP PRIORITY- FOR THE
FOR THE ASSEMBLY. AND THEN-
LASTLY JUST THAT THE STUDENT
HOUSING. I KNOW THAT THERE'S
CONTINUE MONEY FROM LAST YEAR'S
HOUSING PROPOSAL- AND I KNOW UC
AND CSU BOTH- HAVE BEEN FOCUSING
ON THE NEED FOR MORE ONE TIME
MONEY PER STUDENT HOUSING SO
THAT OBVIOUSLY IS A PRIORITY OF
MINE IN THE LEAD IN THE ASSEMBLY
SO WILL BE PUTTING THAT FOR IN
OUR IN OUR PACKAGE AS WELL-
QUESTIONS I KNOW THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES IS JOINING US-
TODAY HAS A GAS THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TODAY NO
VOTING. SO SHE'S HERE AS AS A-
AS OUR COLLEAGUE AND WANT TO
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR FOR LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY
AT THE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I AM
ALSO FILLING IN FOR QUALITY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE VOICE OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE. OUR REGION IS
HEARD COLLEAGUES LIKE THE REST
OF YOU I BELIEVE THAT FUNDING IN
OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IS AMONG THE
BEST INVESTMENT WE CAN MAKE IN
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE FOR
DECADES WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOWARD IMPROVING ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION YET WE MUST
HAVE AN HONEST CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE IN EQUITY IN THE
FAIRNESS ON OUR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES. THEY ARE
NOT ALL I COULDN'T BELIEVE
FUNDED BROADER STATES HISTORY
BOTH THE AMEND EMPIRE AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE BEEN UNDER
FUNDED UNDER APPRECIATED AND
UNDER REPRESENTED THIS LEVEL OF
NEGLECT APLACE THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES IN BOTH
REGIONS. I CONTINUE TO BE
CONCERNED THAT OUR TWO FLAGSHIP
UC CAMPUSES CONSISTENTLY GET THE
BIG TICKET INVESTMENTS ITEMS
MORE FREQUENTLY- THEN OUR OTHER
CAMPUSES ESPECIALLY UC RIVERSIDE
AND UC MERCED WHICH IS WHY I'M
PROUD TO BE A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREY'S AB
TWENTY FORTY SIX THE M. NINE
RISING FUND. I WHICH REPRESENTS
THE FIRST STRONG STEP IN
RECTIFYING THE HISTORICAL IN
EQUITY FUNDING. AMONG SO UC
CAMPUSES. ALL STUDENTS. THE SAME
HI EXPECT. ALL STUDENTS. OF
WHERE THEY LIVE IN OUR STATE OR
ATTEND SCHOOL DESERVE THE
INDIVIDUAL RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
TO MEET THOSE EXPECTATIONS WE
CANNOT CLAIM TO PRIORITIZE
DIVERSITY. EQUITY AND INCLUSION
IN HIGHER EDUCATION WHERE WE
IGNORE THAT SOME UC CAMPUSES
SERVE OUR MOST NEEDY AND
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS YEAH IT
RECEIVE THE LEAST SUPPORT. AND
ONE. REFLECTED IN OUR STATE
BUDGET. WE CANNOT SIMPLY
RECOGNIZE THE IMMENSE WORK OUR
UNIVERSITIES ARE DOING LIKE UC
RIVERSIDE AND UC MERCED- WOULD
THERE IMPROVING STUDENT OUTCOMES
FOR OUR HIGHEST PROPORTION OF
UNDER REPRESENTED HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED STUDENTS AND HAVE.
SIMULTANEOUSLY STRUGGLED TO
INVEST- INSTRUCT OUR STUDENTS.
I'M PROUD OF THE WORK THAT MY
COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE DONE.
INCLUDING SENATOR RICHARD ROTH
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. IN
CONTINUING TO EXPAND UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE WE
HAVE BEEN VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S SUPPORT IN THOSE
EFFORTS- BUT YET. WE RECEIVE AN
INVESTMENTS WE HAVE YET TO
RECEIVE AN INVESTMENT FOR THE
USER SCHOOL OF MEDICINE. ON THE
GLOBAL FUNDING SINCE ITS
FOUNDING. WHICH WOULD BE
PROMISING TO INCREASE PATHWAYS
FOR MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS. IN
THE UNDERSERVED AND ONE EMPIRE.
AND THIS ISN'TJUST ABOUT
GRADUATE STUDENTS ARE
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS WE ALSO
KNOW THAT AS OF LAS YEAR UC
RIVERSIDE RECEIVED THE LOWEST
AMOUNT OF FUNDING ON A PER
STUDENT BASIS AMONG ALL UC
CAMPUSES. THIS IS EVEN MORE
PROBLEMATIC WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THAT THE STATE ALLOCATES FUNDING
TO UC CAMPUSES BASED ON STUDENT
ENROLLMENT. THESE FORMULAS
CONTINUE TO PERPETUATE THIS
VICIOUS CYCLE OF UC RIVERSIDE UC
MERCED NOT RECEIVING THEIR FAIR
SHARE FINDING ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY EDUCATE OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS THE
INLAND EMPIRE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WHERE THE HARDEST HIT BY
KOBE NINETEEN FACES SOME OF THE
WORST HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES. AND
INCREASE UNEMPLOYMENT AND WHY
NEED INCOME GAPS. REVERSING
THESE GROWING DISPARITIES IS
DEPENDENT ON OUR ABILITY TO
INVEST IN A REGIONAL UC CAMPUSES
TO IGNITE ECONOMIC MOBILITY WERE
CALIFORNIA GROWTH IS
CONCENTRATED. AS PART OF THE
IRONY TO ALL OF THIS. THE INLAND
EMPIRE IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING REGIONS OF OUR STATE AND
HAS BEEN FOR SOME TIME IN THAT
YOU THE UC CAMPUSES IN OUR
REGION IS CONSISTENTLY
UNDERFUNDED I STATED I DO WANT
TO BE CLEAR I DON'T X. TAKE
EXEMPTION TO THE UCLA FUNDING-
IN THE MAY REVISE. ALL I AM
ASKING FOR ALL WE ARE ASKING FOR
IS THAT ARE IN LINE UC CAMPUSES
GET CLOSER TO THE SAME AMOUNT OF
ATTENTION AND FUNDING AS OUR
FLAGSHIP CAMPUSES THIS IS
WITHOUT A DOUBT WILL INCLUSIVELY
BENEFIT OUR MOST DIVERSE
POPULATION IN OUR STATE WHILE
CREATING GREATER ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND JOB CREATION.
COLLEAGUES I BELIEVE THIS IS A
TIMELY TRANSFORMATIONAL
INVESTMENT BENEFITING OUR UC'S
MOST DIVERSE POPULATION AND I
TRULY THINK- ARE BUDGET CHAIR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- DID YOU WANT A QUESTION
FOR ANY FOR ANY OF THE FOLKS ARE
JUST ONE AND PUT THAT STATEMENT
OUT THERE. I JUST WANTED TO PUT
THAT STATEMENT I KNOW THAT I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION ON THE
ROAMING CAPACITIES AND WHERE WE
CAN IMPROVE. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTIONS. MEMBER S. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU COOK YOU
TALKED ABOUT THIS AT THE VERY
BEGINNING YOU QUESTIONS- ALMOST
LIKE AN ATTORNEY YOU SET IT ALL
UP AND THEN YOU ASK THE QUESTION
LATER. ABOUT THE FIVE THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- FOR THE
IMMUNOLOGY AND IMMUNOTHERAPY AT
UCLA. AND YOUR QUESTION
REGARDING. WHAT THAT DOES TO
ENROLLMENT IF WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT
AND HERE WE HAVE YOU SEE ARE YOU
SEE MERCED. EXAMPLES OF WHERE
THE FUNDING CAN BE INVESTED AND
IT IS SPECIFICALLY GOING TO BE
INVESTED FOR INCREASED
ENROLLMENT. I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO LOOK AT. A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO
UCLA AND I DON'T SEE THIS AS A
TROJAN- AT I'M NOT SAYING THIS
AGAINST MY BROUGH AND BROTHERS
AND SISTERS. I'M JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE INVESTMENT OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO UCLA
WHICH COULD. IN MY HUMBLE HUMBLE
OPINION BE USED IN A WAY THAT
DOES EXACTLY AS ARCHER'S TALKED
ABOUT. TO USE IT AS AN
INVESTMENT WHETHER IT'S FOR
HOUSING OR- TOOK TO FULLY FUND
OUR MEDICAL SCHOOL YOU SEE THAT
YOU SEE ARE. THESE ARE
INVESTMENTS THAT WILL INCREASE
THE ENROLLMENT AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD HOPE
THAT. WE WOULD LOOK AT AS WE
FINALIZE OUR BUDGET. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI. YEAH AS A
VICE CHAIR OF A HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND ALSO FORMER-
PROFESSOR AT THE SEVERAL HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS SO I AM
JEANNIE INTERESTED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND- OR SO ON THE
FUNDING AND AMONG MANY OTHER
AREAS SO I- AS CHAIR IT WAS-
MENTIONING THE- HI EDUCATION
AFFORDABILITY AND CAN ALSO
BRANDS AND THE SOME STUDENT
DEBTS- NOT FOCUS ON THE AREA OF
A RESTAURANT THAT'S- I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW- I NORTH IRAQ- I
KNOW FIRST OF ALL I THINK- WE
ARE SO PROUD OF THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS A SUCH A FINE. EDUCATION
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM- HOLDEN
THEY HAD TO SAY THAT THE A IN
THE WORD THE UC SYSTEM SINCE CSU
ASSISTANCE IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE PROVINCE THE
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES TO SO
MANY PROGRAM SO. A MUNIVEST IS
SO AND THEN ALSO WE PROVIDE MANY
DIFFERENT- THE SCHOLARSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES- THROUGH FEDERAL
OR STATE GRANTS- AND BROKE MY
ARM PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIPS
ETCETERA BUT- IN MANY STUDENTS
ARE END UP. WITH THE COLLEGES.
THAT YEAH THEN I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW WHO ARE THE CHAU WHO. TO
FALL. AMONG MANY DIFFERENT
FINANCIAL AID TO PROGRAM. ARE
THEY ARE. OBVIOUSLY LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS THAT WOULD QUALIFY MORE
MORE THAN A TO A HIGH. INCOME
CATEGORY SO ARE THESE THE PEOPLE
WERE FROM HEIAU. INCOME MECHELEN
OR A MIDDLE CLASS. BOB DOLE'S
CHAU AND THEY ARE NOT QUALIFIED
TO. N- AMONG THOSE CHAU GROUPS
SO I'M SURE THEY ORDER PAY OFF
FOR ESTATE WORK- ESTATE EARN
HOWEVER I RAN INTO A SITUATION-
OF MOBILE FRIEND- AT THE
DISTRICT OVER THE WEEKEND- WHO'S
SO SUDDEN- S. SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SEARCH OF COLLEGES THAT.
AND A SUDDEN HE SUFFERED A
STROKE AND COULDN'T WALK UP. HE
HAD TO WALK OUT WITH A PAIR OF
PARENTS TO HELP. IN THE- NOT BE
ABLE TO PAY FUNCTION WELL AND
GOOD GET A JOB BUT AS OF THE OF
STUDENTS- SO- UP THE PARENTS WHO
WERE LOOKING INTO THE PROGRAM
SAID THAT MAY BE IN THAT KIND OF
A SITUATION. HOW THE- THIS SON
COULD BE QUALIFIED TO FOR SOME
KIND OF A- THE LOWER. WAIVER
PROGRAM AND- WHAT THE COLLEGES
OF PAY ATTENTION TO THOSE KIND
OF SITUATIONS SO- THE- ANY
PROGRAMS TO WAS DEPARTMENTS OF
DEALING WITH OF THAT KIND OF
SITUATIONS AND HOW TO HELP
STUDENTS WHO GRADUATE A OF SO
MUCH DATA AND UP UNABLE TO FIND
A JOB THAT THEY CAN PAY BACK.
AFTER THE OWNER LIVING EXPENSES
AND THE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
UNFORTUNATE THE HEALTH ISSUES-
AND ANY ACCIDENTS- A COULD
HAPPEN OF TO DO YOU KNOW HEALTH
AND- I AM CONCERNED THE HOW OF
WHETHER THOSE ARE THE GROUP OF
PEOPLE REPORT ARE- FOUR- IN THE
SHADE NOT MANY PEOPLE MAY
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING SO I
WONDER WHAT THE- INTERESTED MAY
SHOOTERS TO PAY ANY ATTENTION OR
ANY DATA. ON THAT AREA. THANK
YOU FOR THE CALL SIR OF THE
UNIVERSE OF IS VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT STUDENT DEBT LOAD- THAT'S
PART OF THE REASON WHY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED COMPACT
INCLUDES THE GOAL OF DEVELOPING
DEBT FREE PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS.
IN TERMS OF WHO IS CURRENTLY
RECEIVING FINANCIAL AID ABOUT
57% OF OUR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES- DO NOT OF. THE
DATE THEY RECEIVE FINANCIAL AID
AND GRANTS TO COVER THEIR FULL
TUITION AND FEES- BUT STILL MANY
STUDENTS HAVE THEIR LIVING COST
OF NOT COVERED BY FINANCIAL AID
AND THAT IS WHERE A LOT OF THE
BURDEN COMES IN FOR STUDENTS IS
THE COST OF RENT. THE COST OF
FOOD- AND OTHER- COST OF LIVING
ITEMS OF. THE WAY THE UNIVERSITY
PACKAGES FINANCIAL AID IS WE
LOOK AT THE STUDENTS PER RENTAL
INCOME. OF AND THEN WE'LL LOOK
AT SOMETHING CALLED THE EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION WHICH IS IN
A FEDERAL FUNDING FORMULA- AND
THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE VERY LOW
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION CAN
RECEIVE CAL GRANTS PELL GRANTS
AND- UNIVERSITY STUDENT AID
BECAUSE WE TAKE SOME OF THE
TUITION PAYMENTS. ACTUALLY WE
TAKE ABOUT THE THIRD AND WE WILL
BE INCREASING THAT TO FORTY FIVE
PERCENT. WE TAKE A PORTION OF
THE TUITION AND GIVE IT TO
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS AS
FINANCIAL AID TO HELP THEM COVER
NOT ONLY THEIR TUITION AND FEES
BUT THEY'RE LIVING COSTS. BUT
THE HIGHER THAT THE STUDENTS PER
RENTAL INCOME THE GREATER THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THE PARENTS
ARE EXPECTED TO GIVE TO THE
STUDENTS FINANCIAL AID OR TO THE
STUDENTS ARE COST OF ATTENDING
THE UNIVERSITY BOTH THE FEES AND
THEIR- AND THEY'RE LIVING COSTS.
AND SOME PARENTS ARE UNABLE TO
GIVE THE STUDENT THE THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND A YEAR THAT IT COSTS TO
GO TO A UC. OF AND THEN THE
STUDENT MAY BE FORCED TO TAKE
OUT LOANS. NOW THE AVERAGE LOAN
AT YOU SEE IS JUST UNDER
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WHO TAKE OUT
LOANS AT THAT'S A GRADUATION
THEIR TOTAL LOANS. OF THAT IS
MUCH LOWER THAN OTHER- OTHER
AMERICAN UNIVERSITIES SO WE ARE
DOING FAIRLY WELL AND TRYING TO
KEEP THAT UP LOAD UNDER CONTROL
BUT THE OF RISING COSTS OF
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA- IS REALLY
PUTTING PRESSURE ON STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO COME UP WITH
THAT EXTRA MONEY TO PAY FOR THAT
HOUSING. THAT'S WHY THE
ASSEMBLY'S PLANS OF INCREASING
THE AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING
GRANT PROGRAM SO THT THE
UNIVERSITY COULD BUILD MORE
DORMITORIES IT'S A IT'S A VERY
GOOD PLAN THAT WILL HAVE LONG
TERM POSITIVE CONSEQUENCES. FOR
MANY STUDENTS BUT WE ARE LOOKING
AT THESE COSTS UNFORTUNATELY.
THE UNIVERSITY DOES NOT CONTROL
FRONT COST NEAR THE CAMPUSES OF
THE LANDLORDS ARE ABLE TO RAISE
THE RENT OUT AND FINANCIAL AID
IS NOT ABLE TO KEEP UP ALWAYS
WITH THOSE COSTS. SURE HOPE.
JERRY SUMMARIZE- AS IF- SHARON
THAT IS INCURRING NOW FROM THE
STUDENTS SO WHO DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH IN COMMON THAT THEY GOT
OF SHOULD OWN. A GRANDES BUT NOT
SUFFICIENT TO COVER EVERYTHING
AND THEN THEY END UP. WITH THE
MORE THAT. AND- SO IN OTHER
WORDS SO THE LOW INCOME FAMILY
SHOULDN'T SO WE'RE BE HIGHER-
RATE. THEY HAVE THERE ARE MORE-
THE LOW INCOME STUDENTS TO WHAT
END UP WITH THE MOISTURE AND
THAT THE CAN WE SAY THAT. I
DON'T HAVE THE PARENTAL INCOME
BREAKDOWN OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEATH IN FRONT OF ME DAIS
INDIAN- I WILL GET THAT FOR YOU-
BUT WE HAVEN'T WE HAVE IN THE
PAST HAVE HAD ISSUES WITH-
STUDENTS WHO ARE OLDER. BUT OF
AND COME TO THE UNIVERSITY
HOWEVER AGED OUT OF CAL GRANTS
OF COMING TO THE UNIVERSITY AND
BEING VERY LOW INCOME HAVING TO
TAKE ON A LOT OF DEBT- THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN STEPS IN
RECENT YEARS WITH REFORM. TO FIX
SOME OF THAT LAST YEAR YOU
APPROVED- A- PATHWAY FOR
STUDENTS WHO COME THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO RECEIVE CAL
GRANT REGARDLESS OF THEIR AGE SO
THAT WILL FIX SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES. OF AFFORDABILITY SO IT
DID YOU WELL IT DOES SAY THAT
THE AVERAGE JUST DURING THAT IS
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PERSON UPON GRADUATION AVERAGE
AVERAGE IS EIGHT ABOUT EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO
TAKE OUT DEBT BUT NOT ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS TAKE OUT DEBT. NOW SHE
AND- DO YOU HAVE ANY PROGRAM
MONITORING- THOSE WHO WHO ARE
GRADUATING WITH THAT THAT THE-
HOW THEY ARE DOING AND WHAT KIND
OF A JOB- GO WITH THE INCOME
WITH THE ENOUGH SALARY TO PAY
THAT- THAT DOWN- AND OF FINDING
SOME WAYS SO BECAUSE TOP I KNOW
THAT- I WAS STATE AND OR SO
FEDERAL. DEPEND UPON WHAT THE
AREA PROFESSIONAL AREAS IF YOU
GO NTO LOW INCOME AREA WHAT
RURAL AREAS YOU SERVE- I'VE GOT
SOME KIND OF A PROGRAM SET UP
FOR FIVE YEARS TO SIX YEARS
SOUTH AND CORN WILL BE. APROPOS
pFIVE YEARS SAID ON ENTIRE AMOUNT
B. EVENTUALLY- LOAN WILL BE
FORGIVEN- WHETHER YOU GUYS THEM
HOW TO- TO PAY DOWN IF THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY ENOUGH CASH
ARAMBULA R. ONE POCKET. OF SO WE
CAN STEER THEM HOW TO ELIMINATE
THE ASSURANCE THAT THE SO I
THINK OF COLLEGE MAY BE- GOOD
SHOW WILSHIRE GIVE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION- FOR THOSE CHILDREN
SO WHO ARE GRADUATING WITH
ASSURANCE TAX. THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENTS SIR- WE DO NOT MONITOR
OF THE TYPES OF JOBS THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH HIGH LEVELS OF
DEBT END UP RECEIVING WE DO OF
FOLLOW OUR STUDENTS TO SEE- WHAT
KIND OF CAREERS THEY GO INTO AND
THEIR INCOME LEVELS IN THOSE
CAREERS AND OUR LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS WITHIN FIVE YEARS OF
GRADUATING ARE EARNING DOUBLE
THE INCOME ON AVERAGE THAT THEIR
PARENTS AREN'T. SO THERE IS A
LOT OF ECONOMIC MOBILITY
PROVIDED BY THE UC DEGREE- IN
TERMS OF LETTING STUDENTS KNOW
ABOUT- EMPLOYMENT PAY OFF
PROGRAMS OF DEBT I'M NOT CERTAIN
IF WE HAVE THOSE KINDS OF
ADVISING HAPPENING THAT YOU SEE. MISTER TERRIFY MAY REBEKAH
KIRK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU FOR YOUR LINE
OF QUESTIONING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI I WANTED TO MENTION THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DID
INCLUDE A TEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION. THAT
IS LARGELY FOCUSED ON
COMMUNICATION AND OUTREACH TO
STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS IN
REPAYMENT. FOR THE TYPES OF
INFORMATION PROVISION THAT
YOU'RE REFERENCING WE DO HAVE A
PROPOSAL FROM JANUARY THAT WOULD
BE FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
IN REPAYMENT ON STUDENT LOANS.
ABOUT THEIR OPTIONS ABOUT
POTENTIAL FORGIVENESS OPTIONS.
AND OTHER INFORMATION ON HOW
THEY MAY WANT TO RESTRUCTURE
THOSE LOANS IF APPLICABLE. YOU
KNOW YOU ADDRESSING YOU KNOW ANY
AVAILABLE RESOURCES SELECT
ESPERANZA MAY NOT BE AWARE SO-
IF THE- UNIVERSITY HAS- SOME
DEPARTMENT THE WORLD SHOULD RUN
THAT THE RESOURCE CENTER OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. THE VETERAN
CENTER VETERANS CIRCLE TO
VETERANS AFFAIRS TO STUDENTS SO.
WITH THE STUDENT THAT- AND
GRADUATING AND THE THEY ARE
HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME. AND
WHERE CAN THEY TURN TO IT THEY
CAN GO TO THEIR- IN ARMADA AND-
DON'T FIND A CHILDREN EDEL FEAST
AUSTRALIND. THE RESOURCE CENTER
AND THE CAST SOME IN OKAY SO HOW
TO HOW. TO A NORTHEAST THAT'S-
JUST A SUGGEST. THANK YOU
SOMEONE OVERLY THANK YOU SIR I
JUST WANT TO ECHO YOUR POINTS
THE POINTS THAT OF OUR BEEN MAY
REALLY WELL CLEAR IS I THINK
THAT WE SHOULD BE SPENT MORE
INCREASING THE PASSING
SUPPORTING OF STUDENTS ARE GOING
TO USE THE RIGHT CLASSROOM
HOUSING SPACE AS YOU TALKED
ABOUT- SO WITH ALL THE GREAT
POINTS OF OUR BEEN MADE BUT I
DID WANT TO ASK YOU KNOW IN THE
ENVISIONING FOR THE UCLA CENTER
OR ALL THESE OTHER GREAT CENTERS
OFFICE THE SOUND THE GREAT
IDEAS. THEY'RE ALL ONE TIME
INITIATIVES SO WHAT IS IN THE
VISION WITH THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ARE YOU
CONSTRUCTING A NEW CAMPUS OR
WHAT. BUT YEAH. SO THE- THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED- IN THE MAY REVISION
TWO HUNDRED THAT WE WILL ADD TEN
TO PROVIDE IT. TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WOULD
BE FOR CONSTRUCTION YES OF THE
FACILITY. A NEW FACILITY THAT
THE UCLA HAS NOT INCORPORATE
INTO THE LONG RANGE PLAN. RIGHT
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. OKAY WELL I
MEAN IT'S VERY INTERESTING I
THINK I STILL THINK I SAW LINE
IT COMES WITH A CHAIR AND I
STILL THINK WE SHOULD HAVE MORE
CAPACITY FOR CLASSROOM SPACE.
AND A HOUSING THANK YOU. YEAH
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON.
FROM THIS CODES NEXT ISSUE.
HASTINGS POSTED COMMISSION. THIS
YEAR NUMBER.
FOUR
OKAY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
CHERRY MEMBERS EXACTLY LIKE
CHÁVEZ WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WILL BEGIN MY
PRESENTATION TODAY BY GOING OVER
SOME CHANGES AND THAT CALIFORNIA
SAID IN A COMMISSION'S BUDGET.
ENTRANCE IN THE KAGUM PROGRAM.
THE MAY REVISION FOR THE COCHRAN
PROGRAM REFLECTS AN ESTIMATED
DECREASE OF TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
POINT NINE MILLION. ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND A
DECREASE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT POINT NINE MILLION
I'M GOING. GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BASED ON THE REVISED ESTIMATES
OF THE NUMBER OF NEW AND RENEW
CALL GRANT AWARDEES. THIS
INCREMENTAL CASELOAD ADJUSTMENT
REFLECT MORE MODEST YEAR OVER
YEAR GROW NICE TO MAKE COMMON
EXPENDITURES COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROJECTIONS.
SIMILARLY AS WE OBSERVE A
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE LAST
THREE YEARS CHAU IN MORE MODEST
YEAR OVER YEAR GROWTH. THE
CASELOAD DECLINES CAN BE
ATTRIBUTED TO LOWER PAY RATES
LARGELY SCCC NCSU. THE
ADJUSTMENT IS ALSO A REFLECTION
OF MORE REVISED ESTIMATES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EXPANSION PROGRAM. AND AS WE
HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE WITH THE
PROGRAM AND BETTER DATA WILL BE
ABLE TO DO A BETTER ESTIMATES OF
THE PROGRAM COSTS. AT THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON A
ROMAN. BUT THE POINT OF FINANCE
BELIEVE THAT THESE SUPPLIES ARE
TEMPORARY AND WE WILL SEE THIS
TREND REPAIRS IN THE NEAR FUTURE
. ADDITIONALLY THE MAY REVISED
INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND I'M GOING TO GENERAL
FUND. AND THREE POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE NEW FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS AND
THOSE AMENDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. NOW I
WOULD LIKE TO P. BUT ADD TO SOME
OF THE TRAILER BILL THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING FOR MAY REVISION- A
REVISION INCLUDES TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT ESTABLISH A MORE
DYNAMIC SYSTEM. TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ADT OR ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER COMMITMENTS.
MADE BY THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. IT ALSO
CLARIFIES CRITERIA BY WHICH
THESE INSTITUTIONS CAN MAINTAIN
TO COVER IN A WORSE AT NINE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
TWENTY DOCTORS. IN THE ABSENCE
OF TIME I WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY
INDICATE OF THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES SEVERAL TECHNICAL
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. TO AMEND
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM THE DREAMER SERVICE
INCENTIVE GROW PROGRAM AND THE
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENT COURT THE
FOR RATES AND COVERAGE ABILITY.
I'M HAPPY TO DISCUSS THIS FOR A
FEW HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU LET'S NOW HEAR FROM
THE L. A. L. AND THEN STUDENT
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE FOUR IN THE L. A.
O. HAND OUT YOU'LL SEE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND A REVISION
. THE MAIN TEAM SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET IS THE
DAMAGE ASSESSMENT HOW CAN COST
ESTIMATES. BASED ON MORE RECENT
PROGRAM DATA. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES ARTICULATED THE REASONS
FOR THIS DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENTS
AND WE THINK THAT THERE VICE
COST ESTIMATE IS REASONABLE. WE
ARE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT TO REVIEW SOME
SMALLER ADJUSTMENTS PROPOSED
MARRIAGE AND INCLUDING THE
VARIOUS TRAILER LANGUAGE
PROPOSALS INTRODUCED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND WILL
BE IN TOUCH WITH THEIR STAFF
WITH YOUR STAFF SHORTLY WITH
FEEDBACK ON THOSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE A COMMISSION GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN GUARDIAN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I'M J. PRIMERICA
ON BEHALF OF THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
MORNING AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY- FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AT THE START OF
TODAY'S HEARING AROUND. THE
IMPORTANCE OF INCLUDING CAL
GRANT REFORM IN THE TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE STATE BUDGET. NOT
ONLY WILL THIS HELP ADVANCE THE
STATE'S GOAL OF TRYING TO
ESTABLISH DEBT FREE PATHWAYS TO
COLLEGE DEGREES. IT WILL ALSO
HELP FURTHER OUR PROGRESS ON THE
OTHER GOALS REFLECTED IN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMPACT'S
AROUND STUDENT ACCESS AND DEGREE
ATTAINMENT WE KNOW THAT
AFFORDABILITY IS ONE OF THE KEY
FACTORS THAT- IS PREVENTING
STUDENTS FROM ENROLLING
CURRENTLY- AND THAT'S BASED ON
SURVEY DATA THAT'S BEEN
COLLECTED BY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. WE
ALSO NOTE THAT- CAL GRANT
RECEIPT IS AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT
FOR HOW STUDENTS CAN PERSIST AND
SUCCEED IN THEIR PROGRAMS ONCE
THEY DO ENROLL AND OF COURSE
HELPS US IN THE WORK TO CLOSE
THE PERSISTENT EQUITY GAPS THAT
ARE FACED. BY SO MANY STUDENTS
TODAY. SO WE DO HOPE THAT IN THE
WEEKS TO COME WILL BE ABLE TO
FIND A PATHWAY TOWARDS INCLUDING
CAL GRANT REFORM- IN THE FINAL
BUDGET. I'LL NOW TURN MY
COMMENTS TO- WHAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISION THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PRESENTED. AT THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION IS
GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
AND FUNDING FOR THE COMMISSION
IN THE MAY REVISION BRINGING THE
TOTAL NEW PROPOSED POSITIONS
AFTER JANUARY IN MAY REVISION.
TO EIGHT POSITIONS- WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION OF
INDUSTRIAL CAPACITY NEEDS A THE
COMMISSION WE DO NOT FEEL THIS
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSES THE
RESOURCING NEEDS TO MAINTAIN
HIGH QUALITY EXPERIENCES FOR
STUDENTS. FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
CAMPUS STAFF PARTNERS- AND IN
OUR INITIAL REQUEST THIS DO NEED
COMMISSION HAD REQUESTED TWENTY
SEVEN POSITIONS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR I. T. CONSULTING
SERVICES. THE AS YOU NOTED IN
YOUR COMMENTS EARLIER THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
STATE BUDGET MADE HISTORIC
INCREASES TO FINANCIAL AID THAT
ALLOW US TO BETTER SERVE MORE.
HOWEVER THESE INCREASES WERE NOT
PAIRED WITH INCREASES TO THE
RESOURCES THAT THE COMMISSION
RECEIVES TO IMPLEMENT THESE
PROGRAMS. FUNDS MANAGED BY THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION INCREASED
FROM TWO POINT SIX NINE BILLION
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO A
PROPOSED LEVEL OF THREE POINT
FIVE FIVE BILLION IN THE MAY
REVISION THAT YOU'RE CONSIDERING
TODAY. 32% INCREASE. AND THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION IS STILL
DMINISTERING OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDS THAT
WERE APPROPRIATED AND LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. SO WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT BOTH THE PROPOSED LEVELS
OF FUNDING FOR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND THOSE ONE TIME DOLLARS
THAT WE'RE STILL MANAGING.
THAT'S ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAN WAS
APPROPRIATED TO THE COMMISSION
IN TWENTY. TWENTY ONE- THAT'S A
69% INCREASE IN THE LOCAL
LISTINGS BUDGET THAT WE'RE
MANAGING. THAT OVER THAT SAME
PERIOD THIS DO NEED COMMISSIONS
RECEIVED ONLY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS MORE AN ANNUAL STATE
OPERATIONS FUNDING THAT'S
ASSUMING THAT THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WILL STRETCH OUR
RESOURCES OVER THE LIFESPANS OF
THESE NEW PROGRAMS. SOME OF
WHICH WILL. BE MANAGING FOR UP
TO NINE YEARS. THAT'S ABOUT A
14% INCREASE ABOVE THE PRIOR
FUNDING LEVEL AND OVER THIS TIME
THERE'S BEEN A 0% INCREASE NO
NEW STAFF POSITIONS THAT HAVE
YET BEEN AUTHORIZED FOR THE
COMMISSION. WE ARE OF COURSE
THRILLED TO SEE THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZE COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY BUT TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THESE
PROGRAMS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
IS ADEQUATELY RESOURCE. THE
COMMISSION IS ALSO- ANTICIPATING
OTHER NEW WORKLOADS THAT HAVE
BEEN DRIVEN BY STATUTORY CHANGES
AT THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. AND WE OF COURSE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE NEW APPROACH TO
FINANCIAL AID COMPLETION FOR
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS THAT WAS
REFLECTED IN ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTY NINE AND CHAMPION BY
MAJORITY LEADER REYES- THAT
TAKES EFFECT THIS FALL. AND
ANTICIPATING THE ADDITIONAL A
REQUEST FOR ASSISTANCE FROM
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AS WELL AS
OUR HIGH SCHOOLS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE HELPING STUDENTS APPLY FOR
AID WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION CAN
MEET THAT DEMAND FOR ADDITIONAL
SEE ZACKS SUPPORT STAFF FOR HIGH
SCHOOL PARTNERS. TRAINING
EFFORTS DATA SHARING WITH K.
TWELVE OUTREACH MATERIALS AND
RESOURCES AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ALSO MOVING
FORWARD WITH STREAMLINING OF THE
FREE APPLICATION FOR FEDERAL
STUDENT AID THE FACTS UP THESE
CHANGES REQUIRE THAT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION UPDATE OUR GRANT
PROCESSING SYSTEMS AND MAKE A
pLANDING CHANGES TO THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION. THAT WE ADMINISTER
FOR IMMIGRANT AND UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS GIVEN THOSE TWO MAJOR
UPCOMING PROJECTS THAT CONTINUE
TO WORK ON OTHER FRONTS FOR OUR
I. T. DIVISION I HAVE TO POINT
OUT. THAT THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND AND ONE TIME
FUNDS WE REQUESTED FOR IT
CONSULTINGSERVICES WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION AND
REVIEW THAT IS A REALLY CRITICAL
INVESTMENT TOWARDS SUCCESS AND
TO MITIGATE RISKS THAT WOULD
EMERGE IF WE DIVERT EXISTING IT
STAFF. TO THOSE PROJECTS. SO
FINALLY I'LL JUST NOTE THAT
THOSE NEEDS I'VE ADDRESSED
REFLECT CURRENT WORKLOAD AT THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION WE KNOW
WHEN WE LOOK FOR TWO OTHER
PROPOSALS BEING CONSIDERED IN
THE BUDGET THIS YEAR. AND
LEGISLATION AND JUST WOULD ASK
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO THINK
ABOUT THE APPROPRIATE RESOURCES
FOR C. SACK. TO MEET. THESE
NEEDS AND TO HIT THE MARK FOR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU YOU KNOW WE START TALKING
ABOUT THIS AT THE OUTSET. AND
THEN WITH. THE UC- ITEM AS WELL.
THIS IS A TOP PRIORITY OF THE
ASSEMBLY I NOTE THE SENATE AS
WELL- YOU KNOW EXPANDING
FINANCIAL AID TO EXPAND COLLEGE.
OPPORTUNITY VIA COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY AND SO- YOU KNOW
WE'VE DONE SOME GREAT WORK IN
THE CAL GRANT REFORM MERION I
THINK YOU KNOW THE MINISTRATION
THE GOVERNOR AND A NON OF WHICH
I KNOW WE TRY TO KEEP.
CONVERSATIONS PRIVATE SOMETIMES
BETWEEN US. AND THE GOVERNOR BUT
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT THE
GOVERNOR AND I TALKED ABOUT.
YEAR AGO WHEN HE WAS SIGNING THE
HIGHER READ BILLS. DOWN IN LOS
ANGELES- HE WASN'T SIGNING THE
CAL GRANT REFORM BILL THAT DATES
I KNEW THAT WAS AGAIN THE
SIGNATURE. AND I SAW HIM. THE I
SAID YOU KNOW GOVERNOR I KNOW
REALIZE THAT WE'RE NOT SAYING
THAT BILL TODAY. AND HE SAYS
YEAH THAT'S KIND OF A BUDGET
THING AND I SAID WELL GOD REST
WILL IT YOU KNOW THAT. YOU KNOW
WELL SOME OF THE ADVOCATES ARE
DISAPPOINTED. I'M NOT BECAUSE
THE GLASS WAS YOU KNOW A TO. YOU
KNOW TWO BILLION DOLLAR GLASS
AND- AND WE SENSUALLY CAUGHT. IN
I'M NOT A SIX TWO BY MISTAKE WE
GOT HALF HAPPEL THAT CLASS IS
ACTUALLY. AND GARCIA SO CAN HE
COME BACK THE NEXT KEEP COMING
BACK AND SO THAT'S IT THAT'S A
WORK WHERE WE'RE DOING HERE
TODAY. AND- IT'S A BIG PART OF
OUR- VISION FOR CALIFORNIA IS-
HAVING MORE STUDENTS GRADUATE
WITHOUT MASSIVE DEBT LOADS AND-
FRANKLY MORE STUDENTS GRADUATING
IN FOUR YEARS. GETTING IN THE
WORK FORCE FILLING THE JOBS OF
TODAY AND TOMORROW. AND WE
REALIZE WE HAVE SOME OF THEM THE
MONEY'S IN- THE BUDGET THIS YEAR
FROM LAST YEAR'S DEAL AGAIN KIND
OF WHAT I SPOKE TO THE GOVERNOR
ABOUT- BUT I WILL NOTE THAT THE
UC DID TALK ABOUT THIS. VISION
FOR DEBT FREE COLLEGE. AND THE
WAY THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS
THIS. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
LESS UC'S GONNA JACK OF STUDENT
FEES WHICH I DOUBT THEY'RE GONNA
DO UNLESS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DROPS INFUSION OF. FINANCIAL AID
MONEY MAYBE THE SLIGHTLY
INCREASED PALO HELP BUT THE
LYNCH PIN TO DEBT FREE IS THIS
THING HERE SO WHAT IS THE
VISION. IN THE OUT YEARS TO MAKE
THIS REALITY TO MAKE COLLEGE
DEBT FREE IN CALIFORNIA. I'M IN
FINANCE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CHAIR- I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION BUDGET
IS COMMITTED TO A SUSTAINABLE
USE OF STATE FINANCIAL AID
RESOURCES AT THE BUDGET PROVIDES
DIFFERENT- RESOURCES THROUGH THE
COMMITMENT WITH THE DIFFERENT
SECTORS- HOUSING AND THE AS YOU
MENTION LAST YEAR WE HAVE THE
BIGGEST INVESTMENT IN THE KAKERA
REFORMISTS INSISTS AND NACHMAN.
ANY PROVIDED FINANCIALLY FOR ALL
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
WHO CURRENTLY DIDN'T QUALIFY FOR
THE PROGRAM- DEMONSTRATION
REFLECTS THE NEEDED- CAUTION
FISCAL BUDGET OUT WILL AT THE
SAME TIME MEDIAN THAT THE MASS
OF- PROVIING FINANCIALLY FOR
THE STUDENTS- AND BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR COMMENTS
BACK. YEAH AND AGAIN WE DON'T WE
WANT TO KEEP WORKING ON THIS AND
I DOUBT I'LL TAKE THAT- BUT YOU
SAID EARLIER. THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK IS
IMPORTANT I'M TALKING TO. MR
HOUSE PUMP NOW I PENSION
PAYMENT. SWELLED YES THIRTY-
THIS IS A PIECE OF THE PUZZLE-
SO THE OTHER THING IS THAT WE
SAW. IN THE L. A. L. OUTLINED
THAT THE MONEY THAT WE NEED TO
FIND OUR CURRENT CAL GRANT
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
ESSENTIALLY HAS GONE DOWN. BY
THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. I WILL NOTE
THAT THE PROPOSAL THAT MR MEDINA
AND I ARE PUTTING TOGETHER THIS
THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION.
SO THREE TWENTY EIGHT SOUNDS A
LOT LIKE. THREE FIFTEEN SO HOW
DID THESE THINGS CHIVE SINCE WE
HAVE THIS SOFTENING IN AND MONEY
IS NEEDED. FOR THIS TO GET
COMMISSION WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES. SO DOES ANYBODY
WANT TO MISTER CHAIR- FINANCE
VIEWS THAT. THIS CHANGE OF
OPPOSING IN THE CASE OF THIS
TRANSITORY- OBVIOUSLY THE
PANDEMIC HAS HAD A NUMBER OF
IMPACTS ON A ROLL NECK ROAD WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT TREND WILL
REVERSE. AND THE PROGRAM WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW AT PACES WE'VE
SEEN IN THE PAST- AND- MISTER
CHAIR YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO CALL
ME JACK. OKAY THANK YOU JACK.
MISS RICHARD MAGISTAD ONE BRIEF
COMMENT ON THAT POINT. UP WHICH
IS JUST THAT AT THIS TIME WHERE
WE HAVE THE SUPPRESSED LEVELS OF
ENROLLMENT AT OUR INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION- PART OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S REFLECTED IN
LEGISLATION AS YOU KNOW IS TO
ENSURE THAT ANY CURRENT
RECIPIENTS. OF OUR CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS WOULD BE GRANDPARENT IT
IN AND WOULD BE- PERMITTED TO
RETAIN THEIR CALTRAIN
ELIGIBILITY AS WE MOVE TO A NEW
SIMPLIFIED SYSTEM FOR FINANCIAL
AID. SO FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THINKING ABOUT THE ONE TIME
COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS TRANSITION- THE MOST. THE
LEAST EXPENSIVE- TIME IS FOR US
TO MOVE AHEAD WITH ME REFORMING
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS WHEN YOU
HAVE THE FEWEST STUDENTS- TO
GRANDPARENT IN. BASED ON THEIR
PRIOR ELIGIBILITY SO THIS WOULD-
WE BELIEVE LIKELY RESULT IN
DECREASED ONE TIME TRANSITION
COSTS FOR THAT GRAND PARENTING
PERIOD AND YOUR POINT- THAT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
ONGOING. WAS BASED ON THE PRIOR
ESTIMATES OF STUDENT MOMENT
PARTICIPATION SO WE'LL BE
WORKING UPDATE THOSE NUMBERS BUT
CERTAINLY- THREE FIFTEEN LESS
THAN THE THREE TWENTY EIGHT.
YEAH AND I WOULD JUST ARGUE THE
OBVIOUS AT THIS WOULD SOFTEN THE
IMPLEMENTATION COST OF IT AS WE
LOOK TO FOCUS ON. THE OUT YEARS
AND SO AGAIN THIS IS GONNA BE IN
OUR PROPOSAL. IT IS A TOP-
ASSEMBLY PRIORITY IN A NOTE THIS
WAS A TOP PRIORITY IN THE
SENATE- THERE BUDGET PROPOSAL AS
WELL SO- WE'LL WE'LL WE'LL STAY
TUNED IN YEAH WE DID LAST YEAR.
HAD THE LARGEST INCREASE- OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEEDY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS FINANCIALLY
NEEDY. DID COMMITTEE CALL CENTER
NOW BEING ABLE TO BE. A SERVICE
OF THE LARGEST INCREASE SINCE
YOU KNOW DEPUTIES WROTE THE BILL
IN TWO THOUSAND SO TWENTY TWO
YEARS SO THAT THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT. AND- BUT- WE THINK
THAT THERE'S STILL TOO MUCH
CONFUSION PEOPLE APPLY YOU KNOW
WE HAVE ALL THESE RULES TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT. AS OPPOSED TO
FOCUSING ON HOW DO WE MAKE
STUDENTS. ELIGIBLE SO MEMBER
REYES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING
YOU BECAUSE YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THIS AREA I THINK THAT
PUTTING THE EMPHASIS ON THE FACT
THAT FINANCIAL AID IS AT THE TOP
IF WE DO WANT COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY WE'VE GOT TO FIND
WAYS TO HELP OUR STUDENTS AND I
THINK THAT THE REQUEST BY- BY C.
SACK OF FOR THE ADDITIONAL
STAFF. AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT
WE'VE GIVEN YOU EXTRA WORK WITH
THE FINANCIAL AID REQUIREMENT IN
AB FOUR SIX NINE AND I'M REALLY
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO DO AND MAKING SURE THAT
THAT GOT PASSED AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR BECAUSE THE MORE
STUDENTS KNOW THE MORE THEY THEY
THEY- THEY ARE TOLD THAT THEY
HAVE TO PUT HER FINANCIAL AID
ONCE A FINANCIALLY FORM WAS
FILLED OUT THE MORE LIKELY TO GO
TO COLLEGE WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE WANT. BUT AS CHAIRMAN-
MCCARTY WAS SAYING WE'VE GOT TO
LOOK AT COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
AND THE BEST WAY TO TAKE CARE OF
THAT AS YOU KNOW IS THAT THE
LEGAL QUESTION QUESTIONING CROSS
EXAMINATION WAS BEING DONE
EARLIER- BUT WHAT IS NEEDED IT'S
A FINANCIALLY PACKAGE- YOUR
REQUEST FOR THE TWENTY SEVEN
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS PLUS ONE I.
T. I. IT JUST SEEMS ABSOLUTELY
REASONABLE I RECOGNIZE WE GOT
EIGHT POSITIONS WERE. ON THE
RIGHT. TRACK THERE- ALSO YOU USE
MAN THAT THE SOME HUNDRED FOR
THOUSAND ONE TIME FOR I. T. AND
IN IN OUR. THE AGENDA TO ABOUT
THE THAT ARE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
IS. OUTDATED TOO COMPLICATED AND
IS UNAVAILABLE TO MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND. NEEDY
CALIFORNIA CALLED STUDENTS SO MY
QUESTION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS WHY DIDN'T THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED CHANGE
IN THAT AREA. I'M SORRY-
MAJORITY LEADER- AND WHICH TO
SPECIFIC AREA. SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE I. T. THAT TRY TO MAKE THIS
THAT THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS MORE
ACCESSIBLE LESS COMPLICATED AND
JUST BRING IT UP TO DATE. YEAH
SO LAST YEAR AND THE PREVIOUS
YEAR WE HAVE THE GRANT DELIVERY
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION ACT WHICH
PROVIDE ENOUGH FUNDING FOR
SEASIDE TO UPDATE THEIR WEBSITE
AN OLDER BACK IN ON THE I. T.
POOR STILL THERE ARE STILL
CURRENTLY UPDATING ALL THOSE-
EFFORTS ABOUT SHOULD PROVIDE A
LOT MORE EFFICIENCY FOR THE
PROGRAM IT. I'M JUST ARE YOU
UNDER THE BUS OR BUSINESS YEAH
MISTER JEFF I MAY JUST ADD.
MAJORITY METER RATES WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
IN YOUR LEADERSHIP ON HELPING
MORE STUDENTS APPLY FOR AN
ACCESS FINANCIAL AID WE ARE
REALLY EAGER TO HELP PARTNER
WITH OUR HIGH SCHOOLS AND LOCAL
PARTNERS TO CARRY THAT THROUGH
THIS FALL- I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THE GRANT DELIVERY SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT HAS
ALREADY CHANGED THE USER
EXPERIENCE FOR ACCUSERS THE
STUDENTS- THESE IT CONSULTING
SERVICES NEEDS- THAT I'VE
REFERENCED- IN MY COMMENTS. ARE
ACTUALLY CREATED BY NEW
STATUTORILY TRIPPIN MANDATES ON
THE COMMISSION AROUND BOTH- THE
FINANCIALLY COMPLETION
REQUIREMENT SO THAT WE COULD
PROVIDE BETTER AND MORE ACCURATE
DATA TO OUR K. TWELVE PARTNERS
IMPLEMENTING THAT REQUIREMENT SO
THEY KNOW WHICH STUDENTS HAVE
APPLIED AND WHO HAS. NOT YET-
AND IT'S ALSO NEEDED IN ORDER
FOR US TO A DR GRANT PROCESSING
SYSTEM TO ALIGN WITH FEDERAL
CHANGES TO THE FASTER THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY ALSO RESULT IN AN
EASIER EXPERIENCE FOR STUDENTS
THE REQUESTED THAT THEY HAVE TO
ASK BUT A DIFFERENT WAY THAT WE
NEED TO PROCESS THEIR DATA FOR
WORK PURPOSES. AND I APPRECIATED
THAT THE COMMENTS FROM
INSTRUCTORS GABBY IT'S GREAT TO
HAVE YOU HERE TO PROVIDE THE
INPUT SO THAT WE KNOW WHAT HAD
THAT THE FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN
FOR ABOUT PROVIDED. AND WE KNOW
HOW IT'S ALREADY BEING USED AND
WHERE WE NEED TO GO I THINK THAT
THE EASIER. WE MAKE THIS THE
BETTER TO THIS STUDENTS TO RIGHT
THE SAME THING WE WANT TO
INCREASE. AND WE COLLEGE FOR. WE
WANT THEM WE WANT OUR STUDENTS
TO COME OUT. DEBT FREE- BY THE
TIME THEY THEY LEAVE. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE IN THIS AREA. RECOGNIZING
THAT THIS IS CENTRAL TO
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE'RE DOING
WHETHER IT'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WHERE THE UC USER OF THE CSU'S.
MAKING SURE THAT FINANCIAL AID
IS TAKEN CARE OF AND- WE MAKE IT
AS UNCOMPLICATED AS POSSIBLE.
BECAUSE THIS IS OUR GREATEST
INVESTMENT RIGHT HERE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
EXCELLENT- COMMENTS MR LEE YEAH
COME HERE NOW FOR TO TRY. OKAY
THE WHOLE THIS ISSUE OPEN. LAST
ISSUE THAT THAT WE HAVE TO MARIE
SHE'S WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO THE
VOTE ONLY WE WILL HEAR THAT NAY
REVISED PROPOSALS FROM HASTINGS
BRIEFLY AND THEN THE STATE
LIBRARY AND THEN GET TO PUBLIC
COMMENT HE SINGS COLLEGE OF LAW
. LET ME BRING THIS UP. THE
COLLEGE OF LAW FUNDED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN SAN
FRANCISCO. FORMALLY KNOWN AS A
WORD WITH THE LETTER H. ALL.
THAT ABOUT THAT ABOUT RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING M. S. JR MEMBERS
JEFF WELTMAN FINANCE THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO INVESTMENTS
AT UC HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE
LAW- THE FIRST IS NINETY MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
ONE HUNDRED MCALLISTER STREET
PROJECT- ONE HUNDRED MCALLISTER
STREET IS A MULTI USE BUILDING-
THAT HAS BOTH STEAKHOUSING AND-
ACADEMIC SPACE THE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTED IN NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE- IS IN NEED OF CRITICAL
IMPROVEMENTS- PARTICULARLY
RELATING TO SEISMIC RISKS- THESE
RESOURCES WILL MAKE THE FINISH
OF THE PROJECT FINANCIALLY
VIABLE- ALONG WITH OTHER-
FINANCING- ORGANIZED BY-
HASTINGS. THE SECOND INVESTMENT
IS EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
TO SUPPORT PROCESSES HERE WITH
CHANGING THE NAME OF THE
INSTITUTION OUR FINANCE LETTER
ALSO INCLUDES PROVISIONAL BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE RESTRICTING THE
RELEASE OF THOSE FUNDS. UNTIL
THE PROCESS OF- CHANGING THE
NAME IS COMPLETE- THANK YOU I'M
READY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
PUMP. OKAY THANK YOU L. L.
FACING HER SELLING L. IF YOUR
PHONE ALONG ON THE OTHER HAND
OUT WE'RE NOT CURRENTLY ON PAGE
SIX. NOT AGAIN SHOWS THE
HASTINGS GENERAL FUND PROPOSALS
UNDER GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MAY
REVISION. ALL FOCUS MY COMMENTS
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME ON WHAT IS
BY FAR THE LARGEST OF THE TWO
PROPOSALS WHICH IS THE-
MCALLISTER TOWER ON RENOVATION
PROJECTS. NOW THIS PROJECT IS A
CRITICAL SEISMIC RENOVATION
PROJECT. AHMED HAS MUCH BETTER
BACK UP IN MANY OF THE OTHER MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS ON THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING. AND AS
WE NOTED PREVIOUSLY IT'S
REASONABLE FOR THE STATE TO-
START SPENDING ONE TIME FUNDING
ON CAPITAL PROJECTS GIVEN SOME
OF THE BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS
FACING THIS YEAR. THAT SAID. WE
DON'T WANT TO RAISE THREE ISSUES
FOR CONSIDERATION AS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT THIS PROJECT. THE
FIRST IS THAT THIS PROJECT IS
BEING PROPOSED OUTSIDE OF THE OF
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM- THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED IF YOU
RECALL THIS HE SINGS ACTUALLY
SUBMITTED A GROUP APPLICATION TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM AND
WAS DEEMED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO BE INELIGIBLE. ON
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE HASN'T
FINALIZED HOW IT INTENDS TO
REFLECT PROJECTS IN THE GRANT
PROGRAM IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ASSESS. HOW THIS. SPECIFIC
PROJECT- IT'S CHECKS UP AGAINST
THOSE OF OTHER PROJECTS IN THE
GRANT PROGRAM. THE SECOND ISSUE
I WANT TO RAISE IS THAT-
ACCORDING TO HASTINGS BECAUSE
THIS. PROPOSAL WOULD SPONSOR THE
MINIMUM AMOUNT NEEDED TO MAKE
THE PROJECT FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE
THE PROPOSED RENTS FOR THE
BUILDING WOULD BE ABOUT 30% OF
EIGHTY PERCENT. OF THE SCHOOLS
AREA MEDIAN INCOME. THAT'S
HIGHER THAN THE EXPECTATION- SET
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
IN THE GRANT PROGRAM WHICH IS
30% 250% A VERY MEDIAN INCOME.
ANOTHER ISSUE WE WANT TO RAISE
FOR CONSIDERATION IS THAT- THIS
IS A HOUSING PROPOSAL- HOUSING
PROPOSALS- TEND TO BE. SELF
SUPPORTED FROM STUDENT FEE
REVENUE BY CONTRAST ACADEMIC
PROJECTS TEND TO BE TEND TO NOT
HAVE THAT SORT OF FEEL ABILITY
OF SELF SUPPORTING FEE REVENUE.
AND THE UNIVERSITIES HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL SEISMIC RENOVATION
BACKLOGS- FOR THE ACADEMIC
FACILITIES WE RECOMMEND YOU KEEP
THAT IN MIND WHEN YOU'RE WEARING
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER STEWART WITH
THE COLLEGE OF LAW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- HAPPY TO BE HERE
TODAY. THE THE MAY REVISE
ADDRESSES TWO OF THE CRITICAL
ISSUES THAT ARE FACING THE
COLLEGE TODAY. OF FIRST IS THE
NAME CHANGE ISSUE AND WE ARE
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH WOMEN
RAMOS AS WELL AS SENATOR UMBERG
ON THE SENATE SIDE TO PURSUE.
AND SUPPORT AB NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX WHICH IS A NEW FOR MAKING
ITS WAY THROUGH THE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS- SO THIS
FINANCIAL SUPPORT WE A WILD. YOU
ARGUABLY NOT ENOUGH IT IS THE
BEGINNING OF A DISCUSSION THAT
WE CAN HAVE AS WE PROGRESS
FORWARD AND WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT EFFORT. US FOR OUR HOUSING
PROJECT IS WHICH IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IT IS A- A MAJOR NEXT
STEP IN OUR ECONOMIC BILLS
CONCEPT WHERE WE- PROVIDE- OF.
HOUSING ACADEMIC SUPPORT
FACILITIES CAMPUS AMENITIES FOR
STUDENTS FROM MULTIPLE
INSTITUTIONS- CURRENTLY WE'RE
DEVELOPING A PROJECT THAT WILL
HOUSE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
UCSF STUDENTS UC DAVIS STUDENTS.
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH UC
BERKELEY AS- POTENTIALLY BEING
OF AN ELEMENT OF THE SOLUTION
FOR THEIR PROBLEMS. THE PROJECT
AT HAND IS A NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE ERROR BUILDING THAT IS IN
NEED A SEISMIC. STRENGTHENING IT
IS MIXED UE OF THE- A NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE. GRANTED
STILL PROVIDE PROOF THE
DIFFERENTLY BELOW MARKET RENTS-
IN THIS AUDIENCE ARE OUR
POPULATION IS GRADUATE AND
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL STUDENTS.
AND THAT'S SOMEWHAT
DISTINGUISHED FROM THE AB ONE
SIXTEEN THAT WAS A MORE HEAVILY
FOCUSED ON UNDERGRADS. SO WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING THIS PROJECT
UNDER WAY AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
OKAY THANK YOU- THANK YOU SO
THIS- THAT THE NAME CHANGE THIS
KIND OF SPEAKS FOR ITSELF OF
WHAT HAPPENED THE ONE TIME MONEY
FOR THE HOUSING IS THIS IS I
KNOW HASTINGS HAS SOME- A
PROGRAM THERE WERE YOU PARTNER
WITH. WHAT'S THE OTHER
INSTITUTION YOU PARTNER WITH
CURRENTLY IT'S U. C. S. F. UC
DAVIS IS ALSO ON CAMP YEAH UCSF
GOTCHA SO THIS. STUDENT HOUSING
THE HELPFUL TO NON LAW SCHOOL
STUDENTS AS WELL WE ALSO HAVE A
COOPERATION AGREEMENT WITH SAN
FISCAL STATE UNIVERSITY AGAIN
FOCUSING MORE HEAVILY ON LOOKING
GRADUATE STUDENTS BECAUSE THAT
HAVE- A MORE APPROPRIATE TO-
POPULATION FOR THE COMMUNITY
THAT WE LIVE IN. AND WE GOT WE
ARE WORKING TO IMPROVE
CONDITIONS IN THE TENDERLOIN BUT
IT'S STILL NOT QUITE RIGHT FOR
UNDERGRADS OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF QUESTIONS ON
THIS THING NO QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WITH THAT
WE'LL HEAR NOW THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARY. WALSALL'S. THIS
IS ALL. YEAH.
HELLO JENNIFER THE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE MAY
REVISION PROVIDES SAID TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND AND ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
ONE TIME FOR JOBS FOR A TOTAL OF
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY THESE
INVESTMENTS CONSIST OF THE
FOLLOWING THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND ONGOING GENERAL
FUND FOR THREE POINT FIVE
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT INCREASED
ADMINISTRATIVE AND PERSONAL
WORKLOAD. THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVETHOUSAND ONGOING GENERAL
FUND FOR COMMUNICATIONS AND
OUTREACH TO LOCAL LIBRARIES FOR
THREE POSITIONS TO EXPAND PUBLIC
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION TO
CALIFORNIA LOCAL LIBRARIES AND
PATRONS AND UNDERSERVED AND MILK
MULTI LINGUAL COMMUNITIES THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING TO FIND TO
MODERNIZE STATE LIBRARY SERVICES
WITH AN AUTOMATED LOAN SYSTEM
AND PROVIDE SUBSCRIPTIONS TO
EVOKES AND SPECIALIZED ONLINE
DATABASES FOR RESEARCH BY STATE
AGENCIES AND POLICYMAKERS. AND
ONE POINT NINE ONE ONGOING
GENERAL FUND FOR TECHNICAL SHIFT
IN CITY OPERATIONS EXPENDITURES
FOR EIGHT POSITIONS FROM FEDERAL
FINE TO TRYING TO FIND TO
SUPPORT WITH A CORRESPONDING
DECREASE IN FEDERAL FUNDS THIS
ACTION PROVIDES GREATER
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
LIBRARY SERVICES ATTACK
TECHNOLOGY ACT ALLIANCE AND WILL
RESULT IN THESE FOR OUR FRIENDS
BEING REDIRECTED TO SUPPORT
LOCAL LIBRARIES AND FINALLY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION ONE TIME
TRYING TO FIND TO SUPPORT TWO
ADDITIONAL YEARS OF ONLINE JOB
TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT RESOURCES TARGETING
OLDER ADULTS AND VETERANS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY SUPPORTED BY ONE
TIME FOR TO FIND AT CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL LIBRARIES. WHICH BUILDS
UPON AND COMPLIMENTS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AUGMENTATION
OF EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND LASTLY I WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
AMENDMENTS TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO THE
COMPREHENSIVE DIGITALISATION
STRATEGY BY AUTHORIZING ELEVEN
MILLION ONE TIME TO BE AVAILABLE
FOR ENCUMBRANCE AND EXPECT YOUR
EXPENDITURE UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES REPORTING
LANGUAGE SIMILAR TO THE L. A.
RECOMMENDATION REPORTING
DEADLINES OF OCTOBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND OCTOBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN AND
DATES ARE. NOTABLY DIFFERENT TO
HELP INFORM AND ALIGN WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DEVELOPMENT.
WITH THE ACTUAL COME MY PRE.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO GO INTO ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
ALAIA. DRIESSEN CONCENTRA SELLY
OAK AGAIN IF YOU'RE FOLLOWING
ALONG ON THE L. A- HANDOUT WE'RE
NOW ON PAGE FIVE THAT SHOWS ALL
THE GENERAL FUND PROPOSALS FOR
THE STATE LIBRARY. AND YOU CAN
SEE ON SORT OF THE BOTTOM LINE
TOTAL THERE THOUGH TOTAL MAYOR
VISION CHANGE HERE IS. UNDER
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS SO THESE
ARE AMONG YOURS SMALLER SMALLER-
PROPOSALS IN TERMS OF DOLLAR
AMOUNTS. WE'RE STILL WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
OBTAIN INFORMATION ON THESE
PROPOSALS WE RECENTLY GOT SOME
INFORMATION THIS MORNING SOURCE
STILL CURRENTLY REVIEWING THAT
INFORMATION PLAN ON SUBMITTING-
OUR COMMENTS- WE'RE SPECIFICALLY
TO STAFF IN THE- VERY SOON.
THANK YOU STATE LIBRARY. GREG
LUCAS FROM THE STATE LIBRARY
CHEN AND JASON HAVE DESCRIBED
WHAT'S IN THE GOVERNOR'S MY
REVISION. THERE'S NOTHING I CAN
REALLY ADD TO THAT. OKAY THANK
YOU WE THINK THESE PROPOSALS-
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THESE- THE
CITY FROM THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL. HOLD THIS OPEN AND
PROCEED NOW TO PUBLIC COMMENT
WHAT WE ARE NOT GOING TO HEAR
THE SCHOLARS SHARE ITEM WILL
JUST VOTE ON THAT WITH OUR
PACKAGE NEXT WEEK QUESTION YES
AND THEN ALSO THE VOTE ONLY
ISSUES WHAT WE WANT TO DO THAT
TODAY WE'LL DO THAT NEXT TIME.
YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
LIBRARY DR CHOI. YEAH AMONG US
CATEGORIES OF- OF FUNDING- FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IS- AS FOR.
LEARN AT THE LIVE PRO. I WONDER
WHY- LIBRARY HAS TO GO INTO
LUNCH PROGRAM SO WHAT IS THIS
FOR A YOUR PROGRAM SO YOU ARE.
WE IS JUST SELF FEEDING SOME
PAPER HUNGRY- THE I MEAN THERE
ARE SO MANY AGENCIES SO WE'LL
TAKE CARE OF- LUNCH PROGRAMS
BUT- I NEVER HEARD ABOUT THE
LIBRARY PROVIDING LUNCH. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I GENERALLY
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROVIDED A
WITH THE SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PROVIDE PASS AUGMENTATIONS.
SUMMER PROGRAMS WHICH TYPICALLY-
MOST A LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
DO NOT PROVIDE LUNCHES DURING
THE SUMMER MONTHS WHERE SCHOOL
IS DURING OFF SEASON AND SO DO
PREFER TO PROVIDE THOSE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES TO CHILDREN
AND UNDERSERVED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES- THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAS JOINTLY
AS SUPPORTED THESE ACTIVITIES
TO- HELP FEED AND- FAMILIES- AND
HIGH NEED IN LOW INCOME AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- AS PART
OF A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT WITH
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES. SO
BASICALLY- JUST PROVIDING LUNCH
DURING THE PROGRAM THAT THE WEST
DURING THE CELL WHILE WE HAVE A
LAB. USES CON- JUST A FOR THE
CONVENIENCE OF NOT. NOT FOR THE
FEEDING PURPOSES BUT THE FOR THE
PROGRAM PURPOSES IS THAT WHAT I
LOVE SEVEN. I WILL DEFER TO THE
STATE LIBRARIAN FOR SPECIFICS ON
LOCATIONS WELL IT'S NOT FOR
CONVENIENCE RIGHT. IN THE
SUMMERTIME IT'S THE FEDERAL
LUNCH PROGRAM THAT WORKS IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR THE SCHOOLS CLOSED THEY
HAND THE BATON THE LIBRARIES IN
THE SUMMER EVEN WITH LIBRARIES
DOING THIS IN ABOUT TWO HUNDRED-
AND EIGHTY FIVE OR MORE
LIBRARIES SERVE THESE MAILS
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EACH SUMMER. EVEN WITH THEM
DOING THAT OF THE TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION KIDS IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS RIGHT WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THESE LUNCH IS ONLY 10% OF
THOSE KIDS GET A MEAL IN THE
SUMMER. SO WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE
AT THE LIBRARIES IS IN ADDITION
TO ALL THESE OTHER AGENCIES
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT I MEAN
WE'RE STILL ONLY REACHING 10% OF
THE KIDS WHAT LIBRARIES BRING TO
THEM TELL ME WHAT YOU KNOW
ALREADY OF COURSE WHAT LIBRARIES
BRING TO IT IS. THE IN RICHMOND
AND THE SUMMER READING PROGRAMS
I'VE BEEN TO THESE THINGS THE
KIDS COME OUT OF THE OF THE
LUNCH PLACE WHERE THEY HAVE A
MEAL. AND TO A PERSON THEY ASKED
WHERE DO WE SIGN UP FOR SUMMER
READING. SO LIBRARIES OFFER TO
FOR YOU KNOW OVER TIME THREE FOR
RECEIVING A FOR RIGHT WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT THEY
PROVIDE ONE OF THE MISSING
PIECES THOUGH IF I MAY. IS THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM ONLY PROVIDES
MEALS FOR KIDS AND THE VERY
RIGID ABOUT THAT SO HUNGRY
FAMILIES COME TO THE LIBRARY FOR
A MEAL IN THE SUMMERTIME RIGHT
AND THE PARENTS GET SET OFF
SOMEWHERE ELSE RIGHT WELL THE
KIDS GET A MEAL. AND SO THERE'S
A THERE'S A BROADER ISSUE WITH
THESE FEDERAL WAIVERS RIGHT THAT
THAT THEY PUT IN PLACE DIFFERENT
RULES TO FACILITATE HANDING OUT
THESE LUNCHES DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND SO THERE'S. WIDE
SPREAD SUPPORT FOR KEEPING THE
SPENT WAIVER AND- TO FIX-
SERVING THESE MAIL OF THE SOME.
SO IT ISN'T IT ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT LIBRARIES ARE BEING FORCED
TO DO IT BEGAN AS US WEST WITH
SEVENTEEN LIBRARIES WHO WANTED
TO DO IT. AND WITH THIS HELP
WE'VE EXPANDED IT TO TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE LIKE I SAY EVEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC WHEN THE
PHYSICAL DOORS WERE CLOSED THE
CREATIVITY OF LIBRARIES ALLOW
THEM TO SERVE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEALS N THAT SUMMER OF
THAT BE TWENTY TWENTY. YEAH DID
I ANSWER YOUR QUESTION YES
SOUNDS SOUNDS LIKE A LIBRARY SO
I HAVE IS A STEPPED UP. WHEN THE
SCHOOL IS UP CLOSE IT IS
SPECIALLY DURING THE SUMMERTIME
YEAH WELL THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT
WORK RIGHT IS- IS FORGING THESE
KIND OF RELATIONSHIPS AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE SCHOOLS
RIGHT SO THAT LIKE THE BATON
GETS HANDED OFF. YOU KNOW AND
EASY WAY CAN OFTEN OFTEN
SOMETIMES THE SCHOOL CAFETERIAS
IN THOSE FACILITIES WILL STILL
BE USED FOR THAT KIND OF MEAL
STORAGE AND PREPARATION. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. OKAY THANK YOU WITH
THAT WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
AND- INCLUDE THE HEARING IT
PROCEED NOW PUBLIC COMMENTS SO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE OR LESS. ONE MAN- LAST
SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS AND- WE
JUST. YEAH WE'LL START WITH THE
IN PERSON- TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR CAN
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH SEIU
LIKE YOU WE SHARE THE
DISAPPOINTMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION NOT INCLUDING
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR THE CSU
STUDENT AND STAFF- WE ECHO THE
SUPPORT BY THE CSU TODAY FOR
INVESTMENTS- IN AUGMENTIN BUDGET
URGED ASSEMBLY TO ADOPT THE
PROPOSAL BY THE SENATE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED MILLION.
WHICH WOULD FULLY FUND THE CSU
WE REQUEST FOR THE SALARY STUDY
AND CFA IS A TENTATIVE AGREEMENT
AS WELL AS THE PENDING- ON FACT-
THE NON FACULTY- BARGAINING
UNITS PENDING AGREEMENTS- ON A
BRIGHTER NOTE WE WOULD LIKE TO
SAY WE SUPPORT THE INVESTMENT IN
THE UC LABOR SIGNERS WE ARE
PROUD TO COME ON IN SUPPORT. OF
THE CAL GRANT REFORM PROPOSAL
AND WE ALSO ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE INVESTMENT IN THE SUMMER
BRIDGE OR CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH THE
TEN MILLION ON GOING DOLLARS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING TERAKHIR
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME IS
AMBER MAY SEND THE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY. AND I'M VERY
PLEASED TO. BE HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE CCSD SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY POLICY FELLOWS. AND
WE ARE HERE TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT ONE TIME FUNDS OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO DELIVER C.
CST SCIENCE FELLOWS THESE ARE PS
PHD SCIENTISTS AND ENGINEERS WHO
COME TO SARAMENTO FOR A YEAR OF
SERVICE. TO BRING SCIENCE INTO
THE PROCESS AND SERVICE TRUSTED
STAFF. THESE FUNDS WOULD HELP
ENSURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
DELIVER AT LEAST TEN FELLOWS TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
PERPETUITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING I'M WE HAVE A GUY
WITH THAT I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE POINT THE
PROJECT AND I'M HERE JUST TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
. FOR A THREE MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION TO OUR FIND. THIS
WOULD AGAIN WOULD HELP US EXPAND
ACCESS TO ALL ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
INCLUDE TRANSFERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. IN ADDITION I WOULD LIKE
WE WOULD LIKE TO KIND OF FIRE
FUNDING SO WE COULD RECEIVE ARE
FINDING IN A TIMELY. FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE THANK YOU. YEAH GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF
FIRST OF ALL- MY NAME'S BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN A CONTROLLER AND-
INTERIM DIRECTOR OF SECONDARY
PROGRAMS FOR THE POINT THE
PROJECT. I AM ALSO AN ELECTED-
MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC CENTER
COMMITTEE REPRESENTING THE FIFTY
SEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT- AND I
WANT TO START OFF WITH
GRATITUDE. FOR ALL THE SUPPORT
THAT YOU ALREADY PROVIDED FOR
THE POINT THE PROJECT AND ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE TO ALSO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. IN THE ARE. OF
THE THREE POINT FIVE DOLLARS TO
ALLOW US TO SERVE MORE STUDENTS
EXPAND OUR PROGRAMMING. AND
CONTINUE ON OUR OUR FORTY YEAR
TRAJECTORY THAT WE HAVE IN TERMS
OF US SERVING UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
OTHER DAYS ARE ABBY I AM A
SYSTEM IMPACTED UC RIVERSIDE
ALANIS AND ALSO LIMITS OF UC
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW. NOW
I RUN THE BERKELEY UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS PROGRAM AND WE'RE HERE
TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT OUR
REQUEST FOR FOUR MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDING. WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
MADE THE INVESTMENT FOR
INCARCERATED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND FORMALLY
AND CAL STATE STUDENTS. AND
WE'RE ASKING YOU TO CLOSE THE
GAP BY FUNDING THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS OF THE UC SYSTEM CAN
ALSO BE ACCESSIBLE TO THOSE
STUDENTS. THANK YOU IN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MICHELLE
MAXWELL AND I AM THE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR FOR THE INCARCERATED
SCHOLARS PROGRAM WITH THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
. ARM TODAY THERE ARE NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND CARS RATED STUDENTS IN
OUR CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY TAKING
COLLEGE COMMUNITY CLASSES. I'M
AT WE ABOUT A YEAR AGO I WAS ONE
OF THOSE STUDENTS- WHEN THIS
CAR'S REGISTER. WORKING SOMEBODY
FROM THE END SCHOLARS SO THAT I
COULD TRANSFER INTO THE UC
SYSTEM UPON FOR ALL. IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT THAT I
RECEIVE THAT I AM ABLE TO STAND
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY. IF IT
WERE NOT FOR THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS I DON'T KNOW WHERE I
WOULD BE. ARMS SO IT IS BECAUSE
OF THIS THAT I'M ASKING YOU
SUPPORT OUR- ASK FOR TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INCARCERATED STUDENTS. ALSO I
AND LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE LIFTED PROGRAM. WHICH WILL
ALSO PROVIDE- BACHELOR'S DEGREE
PROGRAMS TO INCARCERATED
STUDENTS. AND THAT IS FROM THE
UC IRVINE. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS ERIN MCCALL AND I AM A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED SENIOR AT
UC BERKELEY- I TOO AM HERE TO
SUPPORT THE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
AND IT'S A IT'S A FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR ASK I'M NOT- AND- JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION. AND YEAH SO
I'M PETER E. HAAS PUBLIC SERVICE
LEADER A IN A MEMBER OF THE
LEADERSHIP TEAM AT THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
UNDERGROUND'S COLORS CHANGED MY
LIFE THAT MY INVOLVEMENT WITH
THE PROGRAM IS HELPING TO
MANIFEST IS A LEADER WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT I NEVER REALLY
IDENTIFIEDWITH THE FOR. IT
WOULD BE REALLY AWESOME IF YOU
GUYS WOULD SUPPORT OUR PROGRAM
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN BERS- MY NAME IS BY
SEAN NOW WITH U. S. FIRE-
NONPROFIT LEADING. THE WORK AND
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY- AND
IMPACTING OVER HALF OF NEARLY
HALF A MILLION STUDENTS ACROSS
THE NATION. WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT A COUPLE ITEMS-
FIRSTLY. NOT REALLY AGAIN THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
THE ASSEMBLY LEADERSHIPS ARE
CHAMPIONING.OF THE CAL GRANT-
BUDGET ASK THIS IS A SINGLE YOU
THE BIGGEST MOST IMPORTANT.
THING THAT WE CAN DO TO. MOVE
THE COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
MOVEMENT FORWARD- SO WE
APPRECIATE YOU FOR PUSHING FOR
THAT AND TO CONTINUING. THE IN
THE NEGOTIATION PROCESS THAT'S
TO COME. SO WHY TO ALL IN THE-
THE WHAT WAS. IN THE OFFSEASON
LINE ITEM AROUND THIS EXACT
BUDGET STAFFING- BUDGET ARMED WE
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR INCLUDED
. SOME FUNDING IN THE MAYBE WAS
THE APPRECIATE THAT BUT WE DO
REALLY THINK. THIS ESSENTIAL FOR
US TO FULLY INVEST. IN THE
STAFFING NEEDS OF C. SACK TO
HELP WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE- PROSECUTOR MANDATE- THAT'S
GOING TO BE FORTY. IN IN OUR
FORCE NEXT YEAR- BAND OF FINAL.
BOB ASKED WE HAVE IS WE WANTED
TO ELEVATE THE ABOUT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ASK FOR THE FBI WE
APPRECIATE HAVING THAT TEN
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING. WOULD
LIKE TO SEE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR MORE. ARE THAT THE FBI
BUDGET TO A TOTAL OF THIRTY
MILLION THIS IS ESSENTIAL FOR.
SUPPORTING STUDENT BORROWERS-
OUTREACH- AND- YEAH SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR FREE. TIME THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING A CHAIRED
MEMBERS AS- ONCE IN WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION. ALSO
READ RECENT A GRADUATE OF SACK
STATE- WE ARE REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE ATTENTION OF THE-
LEGISLATURE IN THE GOVERNOR TO
HIGHER ED SPECIFICALLY. WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE INNOVATION
OF THE GOVERNOR'S. CONTACTOR
PROSE ALL AND THE C. ISSUES
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
MILLION. DOLLAR RECURRING
FUNDING REQUEST AND OF COURSE-
INVESTMENTS. IN INFRASTRUCTURE
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM. AND WE ALSO
SURE THE GOVERNOR'S EXCITEMENT
FOR DEBT FREE COLLEGE FUTURE AND
WE KNOW THAT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO FIND.
THE CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK
WILL HELP US GET THERE THIS IS
GOING TO SUPPORT. A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS- ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. YEAH. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN PARTY IN
MEMBERS JOSHUA HAGEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY I APOLOGIZE HOPE YOU
CAN HEAR ME THE MIKE IS SHORTER
THAN I AM. FOR AND FOREMOST WE
JUST LIKE TO THINK YOU FOR YOUR
CAN LEADERSHIP TO PAVE A PATH
TOWARDS DEBT FREE COLLEGE
CHAIRMAN PARTY WE JUST ALSO LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AT THE TOP F THIS HEARING UNDER
. HOW IMPORTANT IT IS INCLUDE
CAL GRANT. IN THE FINE STATE
BUDGET. IN SUPPORT OF THIS WORK
WE WOULD JUST REQUEST YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS FOR THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
FIND THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK. THAT INVESTMENTS
GOING TO BE CRITICAL TO ENSURE
THAT OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS CAN
ACHIEVE THEIR COLLEGE GOALS
WITHOUT INCURRING UNDUE AMOUNTS
OF STUDENT DEBT IN SIMPLIFY THE
FINANCIALLY PROCESS FOR ALL
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BRUCE MY NAME IS
KATHERINE HUTCHINSON AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES
UNION. OUR ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS SIXTEEN
THOUSAND ON PROPERTY STAFF AT
THE C. ISSUES ACROSS SIX
BARGAINING UNITS. I'M HERE TO
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR BUDGET
AUGMENTATION OF TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION TO
IMPLEMENT THE RESULTS OF THE
SORRY STUDY FOR NON FACULTY
EMPLOYEES AT THE C. ISSUES. THE
STUDY WHICH WAS COMPLETED BY
INDEPENDENT CONSULTANT MERCER.
CONFIRMED THAT NON FACULTY STAFF
FACE SIGNIFICANT WAGE STAGNATION
AND SHOW THAT STAFF ARE
RECEIVING NON COMPETITIVE
SALARIES THAT ARE TOP PERCENT
BEHIND THE MARKET ON AVERAGE.
THE STUDY WAS COMPLETED ON
ACCELERATE TIMELINE TO BE PART
OF THESE BUDGET DELIVERED
DELIBERATIONS. SO WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THIS PROPOSAL
IS NOT INCLUDING THE MAY
REVISION. BUT WE HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR CAN
COME TO AN AGREEMENT TO FUND
THIS IMPORTANT A PERFORATION IN
THE FINAL BUDGET ALONG WITH THE
FACULTY. AUGMENTATION NON
FACULTY EMPLOYEES ARE CENTRAL TO
BOTH STUDENT AND FACULTY SUCCESS
ON THE CSU CAMPUSES WITHOUT US.
THIS ISSUE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
THRIVE. WE DESERVE TO BE PAID A
FAIR LIVING WAGE SO WE ARE
RESPECTIVELY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BUDGET OPTIMIZATION
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TERRY WILSON
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE EMPLOYEES
UNION. I WORK AT FRESNO STATE
UNIT NINE AS ADMINISTRATIVE
ANALYST SPECIALIST. I'M HERE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF PRESIDENT
HUNTINGTON THAT ARE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION OF TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION. TO
IMPLEMENT THE RESULTS OF THE
SALARY STUDY FOR NON FACULTY
EMPLOYEES. AT THE CSU. THE
MERGER STUDY FOUND THAT NON
FACULTY STAFF ON AVERAGE 12%
BEHIND THE MID MARKET RATE. AND
EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT WAGE
STAGNATION. TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES MARSHALL RECOMMENDS
INSTITUTING A NINE STEP SALARY
SCHEDULE THAT WILL. WITH
SATISFACTORY PERFORMANCE HELP
EMPLOYEES MEET MID MARKET RATES
IN FIVE YEARS. NON FACULTY
EMPLOYEES LIKE ME ARE ESSENTIAL
TO BOTH STUDENTS AND FACULTY
SUCCESS. ON THE CSU CAMPUSES
WITHOUT US TO SEE IF YOU WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO THRIVE. WE
DESERVE TO BE PAID A FAIR LIVING
WAGE AND RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BUDGET
AUGMENTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JESSICA WEST BAY I AM A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES UNION. I
WORK AT CHICO STATE IN UNIT
SEVEN AS A BUYER THREE IN THE
PROCUREMENT AND CONTRACT
SERVICES DEPARTMENT I WANT TO
AMPLIFY THE PREVIOUS STATEMENTS
FROM PRESIDENT HUTCHINSON AND
TERRY WILSON. I WANT TO STRESS
THAT NON FACULTY STAFF LIKE
MYSELF ARE ESSENTIAL TO BOTH
STUDENTS AND FACULTY ESPECIALLY
IN THE C. S. USED TO GI TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE INITIATIVE. AND
SUPPORTING THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS I STRONGLY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT A
BUDGET AUGMENTATION OF TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT. THE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE SALARY STUDY FOR NON FACULTY
EMPLOYEES AT THE CSU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
BERMAN NAME SAFELY I'M WITH THE
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATION
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR THE ASSEMBLY
IN YOUR SUPPORT ON A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUT ONE TIME
BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR THE CSU
ASIAN BILINGUAL TEACHER PROGRAM
EDUCATE TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM CONSORTIUM THE
LEGISLATURE SHOWN HAS ITS
COMMITMENT ON DIVERSIFYING OUR
TEACHER CREDENTIAL PIPELINE AND
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
SUCCESSFUL DOOR IMMERSION
PROGRAMS I OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE
SUCCESS OF THE STORM RUSSIAN
PROGRAMS WE MUST RECOGNIZE THE
CURRENT PIPELINE ISSUE THAT
EXISTS AN ASIAN LANGUAGE
BILINGUAL AT YOU. ACCREDITATION
ACCORDING TO THE C. D. E. A
TOTAL OF A THOUSAND SIXTIES TO
BILINGUAL ACCREDITATIONS FOR
ISSUES IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONLY 8% THAT'S
EIGHTY NINE OF THE
ACCREDITATIONS WEE AWARDED TO
ASIAN LANGUAGES THAT'S A
COLLECTIVE OF FIVE LANGUAGES WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME INVESTMENT WILL
SUPPORT PROFESSORS AND STUDENTS
IN THE PROGRAM INCREASE THE POOL
OF QUALIFIED TEACHERS WITH
EXPERTISE IN ASIAN CULTURES AND
LANGUAGES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
GRACE R. BRAUN- FROM THE POINT
THE PROJECT AS A COMMUTE A
FORMER COMING COLLEGE STUDENT
FORMER FACULTY MEMBER COMMUNITY
CALL CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGE I
PROBABLY REPRESENT THE POINT THE
PROJECT. WHICH SERVES FIRST
GENERATION AND OTHER UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS AT SEVENTY FIVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I WANT TO UP
LIFT THE PROPOSED AUGMENTATION
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR MY
PROGRAM AND TO THANK YOU THAT.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOW ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A STEM PROGRAM FOR OUR
STUDENTS AS WELL AS TO CONTINUE
TO EXPAND TO ALL HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
ALONG WITH ACADEMIC COURSES
THAT- INTENT THAT. DEBT
RECOGNIZE OUR OUR STUDENTS AND
SUPPORT THEM WE ALSO DO HAVE
PROGRAMMING TO SUPPORT AND
PROVIDE- SOUND FINANCIAL AID
ADVISING IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE GOING CULTURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
NAMES ON THE UNDERVALUE I'M A
PROFESSOR CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE
SO LIMITING BE TO ONE MAN THAT'S
GOING TO BE ATTACK. BUT I WILL
TRY- WE ARE I'M HERE TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
ABOUT AND ALLOCATED FUNDS THE
CSU- NUMBER ONE I THINK OUR
FACULTY AND OUR STAFF DESERVE A
FAIR WAGES SPECIALLY WITH THE-
INFLATION RATE THAT'S GOING UP
AND- THE COST OF LIVING IN THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A SURPLUS.
NUMBER TWO FOR STUDENTS RIGHT TO
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE CSU IS A
MECHANISM TO GET OUR STUDENTS
INTO CLASS AND WE- PROVIDE
COMPETITIVE. FOR FACULTY THEM
THEY'RE GONNA LEAVE OUR CAMPUS
THEY ARE LEAVING NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR
CHARLES TOMBS AND PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND I'M HERE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE TWENTY
TIME TWENTY THOUSAND PROFESSORS
COUNSELORS LIBRARIANS AND
COACHES THAT SERVE OUR STUDENTS
ON TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES FIRST
WE WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AN ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO THE STUDENTS
FACULTY AND STAFF OF THE C.
ISSUE. I AM HERE TODAY TO
REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY ALIGN
THEIR C. ISSUE BUDGET PROPOSAL
WITH THE SENATE PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN OWN GOING UNALLOCATED
BASE FUNDING ABOVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL THIS
INCREASE WILL ENSURE THE C.
ISSUE HONORS ITS COMMITMENT TO
THE FACULTY AND STAFF OF THE C.
ISSUE TO PROVIDE FAIR AND
COMPETITIVE COMPENSATION. IT
PROVIDES FOR NEGOTIATED SALARY
INCREASES AND POOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STAFF
SALARY- STUDY RECOMMENDATIONS
ACTING ON OUR REQUEST WILL AND
ABLE TO SEE ISSUE TO RETAIN THE
BEST AND BRIGHTEST FACULTY AND
STAFF AND TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THE HIGHEST QUALITY EDUCATION
FOR STUDENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S STEVEN FILLING I'M A
FACULTY MEMBER AT C. ISSUE
STANISLAUS. AS MY COLLEAGUES I'M
HERE TO REQUEST THAT YOU LOG THE
C. ISSUES RECURRING FUNDS WITH
ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS. THIS WILL ALLOW US TO
MEET OUR BARGAIN COMPENSATION
LEVELS FOR ALL EMPLOYEES AND
ALSO FUND THE- RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE STAFF COMPENSATION
SURVEY. THAT IN TURN WILL ENABLE
THE VERY DEDICATED AND COMMITTED
FACULTY AND STAFF OF THE C.
ISSUE TO CONTINUE TO EMPOWER
STUDENTS TO SUCCEED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING COMING
IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE WORKER
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
ACADEMIC PROFESSIONALS-
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING A FOR.
AND I'M HERE IN ONE OF THOSE
RARE MOMENTS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THIS ISSUE AND
UNITS ACTUALLY AGREE ON
SOMETHING. AND THAT IS THAT WE
NEED DESPERATELY THAT SEE IS THE
FULL ASK WITH THE CSU BUDGET IN
ORDER TO IMPLEMENT ALL THE
PROGRAMS AND AN OLDER LEFT
EIGHTY AS THE GOVERNOR HAS.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT DOES NOT TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THAT WE NEED. A
STAFF AND FACULTY THEY ARE WELL
TRAINED AND FOR THE LONG HAUL
WITH YOU- STUDENTS- EXPERIENCE
ON CAMPUS BECAUSE OUR CAMPUSES
HAVE TURNED PROVERBIAL.
REVOLVING DOORS THEY CAN JUST
AFFORD TO STAY WITH HER WHICH IS
THEY'RE BEING PAID SO HERE'S
HOPING THAT YOU WILL ALIGN YOUR-
REQUEST WITH A WITH A CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE'S REQUEST TO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TONY. CHAIR OF THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES OF THE CALIFORNIA
HISTORICAL SOCIETY. AND I'M HERE
TO REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE
APPROVED A ONE TIME TWELVE
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION TO.
UC RIVERSIDE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STARKEL SOCIETY TO IMPLEMENT TE
HISTORY EDUCATIONAL FIELD
SERVICES PROGRAM. THE DETAILS OF
WHICH WE'VE DISCUSSED IN
CONVERSATION BEFORE BUT WOULD BE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GENEVIEVE
CUTTACK CHAU FAIR I AM A STUDENT
AT UC SAN DIEGO AND A MEMBER OF
GENERATION UP IS STUDENT LED
EDUCATION ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION.
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU INCLUDED
THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK. I WAS HAPPY TO HEAR
IN TODAY'S HEARING THAT
ADDRESSING STUDENTS NON TUITION
COSTS WHICH ARE INCREASINGLY A
BARRIER FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING
OR COMPLETING COLLEGE IS A
PRIORITY OF THE ASSEMBLY AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
AVENUE TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN. MORE
PERSONALLY IN MY CAPACITY SIMPLY
AS A PROUD UCSD STUDENT I'M ALSO
HERE TODAY TO ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE UC'S FUNDING REQUEST
IN THE STATE BUDGET. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE INVESTMENT
PROPOSED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
REVISED BUDGET PROPOSAL AND I
HOPE THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL AS NEGOTIATIONS
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. OKAY NOW WILL GO TO
PEOPLE WHO WANTS TO WISH TO.
TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE. OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE.
CERTAINLY WE WILL GO FIRST LINE
THE SIXTY ONE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND I'M SORRY SIXTY ONE
CAN YOU PLEASE HIT ONE ZERO
AGAIN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ACTUALLY WILL COME BACK TO SIXTY
ONE WE WILL GO TO LINE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT CAN YOU
GUYS GIVE ME. YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I PERFECT GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN CARNIAN NUMBERS MY NAME
IS NELSON EVAN ON H. STUDENT
WITH THE UC SANTA BARBARA WILL
THE CORE ABOUT TO BEGIN THIS
COMING BY THINKING ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR
MAKING HIGHER EDUCATION MORE
ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL AS SOMEONE
WHO PERSONALLY SEES THE BENEFIT
OF STUDENT AID AND OTHER SUPPORT
SYSTEMS EVERY DAY I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO MAKE A FEW BUDGET ASKED
IN ORDER TO BUILD ON THE MISSION
OF MAKING HIGHER EDUCATION
POSSIBLE FOR EVERYONE. FIRST
PUBLIC TO ASK FOR TWENTY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR STATE THAT
PROGRAMS WHICH CURRENTLY HELP
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS REALIZE
THEIR FULL POTENTIAL NEXT I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
PROGRAMS AND FINALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
CONTINUED FUNDING PUBLIC CAL
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK TAKE YOUR
TIME AND HOPE YOU HAVE A
WONDERFUL DAY. THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY FIVE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SURE MCCARTY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JOHNSON PLAY ON BEHALF
OF SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
FOR EIGHTY MILLION FOR THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY CAMPUS- JUST AS
BACKGROUND INDICUS DATA CAMPUS
THERE FOR THE LAST SIXTY YEARS
THERE'S CURRENTLY A THOUSAND
STUDENTS ENROLLED WITH A SIX
YEAR GRADUATION RATE OF AROUND
85% THE CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW
STEM THIS. IS BASED UPON DOES
FROM THE COMMUNITY BUSINESSES
FOR THE NEED FOR THOSE TYPES OF
DEGREES SUCH AS NURSING PUBLIC
HEALTH ENGINEERING. SAN DIEGO
STATE OR A DEDICATED. MILLION
DOLLARS TO THIS PROGRAM AND
PLANS THAT THE FIRST CAMPUSES
CLASSES FOR THE CLASSROOM- THOSE
DEGREES STARTING IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- BUT AGAIN
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL AND STAND BY THE
ANSWERING QUESTIONS IF NECESSARY
THANK YOU. BUT. THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO NEXT A LINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHAMBER
GUARDIAN MEMBERS OF GREAT THANK
YOU MY NAME IS ALEX NILES I'M
NOT THERE YOU SEEN IT UC SANTA
BARBARA AS WELL AS THE CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. I LIKE THE
COLD TO ASK FOR TWENTY NINE
DOLLARS NOT GOING FUNDING FOR
USED TO SAY THAT PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY WE COME OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC SITAPUR MEANS-
CENTRALLY IMPORTANT TO ENSURING
THAT TRANSFER STUDENTS
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS FROM UNDERSERVED AND
UNDER RESOURCE BACKGROUNDS AND
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICTS. ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS AND DRIVE AT THE UC- I
DON'T LIKE DOCTOR FINALLY GOING
ON GOING FUNDING FOR THE UC'S ON
DOCUMENTS JUNE PROGRAMS THESE
PROGRAMS ADDRESS THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES UNDOCUMENTED. AT THE
UC AND HELP TO CLOSE GRADUATION
GAPS AND PROMOTE RETENTION
LASTLY I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT
ASSEMBLY INCLUDE FULL FUNDING
FOR THE PROGRAM EQUITY
FRAMEWORK- IN THEIR BUDGET
PROPOSAL YOU CSA IS- I LEAD
SPONSOR OF THE KARAIKUDI
FRAMEWORK. ALONG WITH OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE FIX FINANCIALLY
COME COALITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO
ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS A-
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TO ABIGAIL ALVAREZ FROM
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER I'M CALLING TO URGE YOU
TO INVEST IN PRODUCING MORE
EIGHTEEN ASIAN LANGUAGE
ACCREDITED TEACHERS TO TEACH IN
BILINGUAL AND DUAL IMMERSION
CLASSROOM. AS AN ORGANIZATION
THAT REPRESENTS ONE MILLION
SOUTHEAST ASIAN AMERICANS THAT
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THIS EVENING. IMPORTANCE
OF THIS INVESTMENT THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT SPENT
OVER FOUR YEARS INTO ASIAN LOGIC
AND LANGUAGE BILINGUAL PROGRAM
BUT REMOTE NOT ONLY LINGUISTIC
DIVERSITY ACADEMIC CULTURAL AND
SOCIAL GROWTH AMONG CALIFORNIA'S
YOUTH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU WE WILL
GO TO LINE TEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SURE MEMBERS CHARLES RIGHT
ON BEHALF OF CSU PALM DESERT WE
SUPPORT THE SEVENTY NINE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET PROPOSAL TO FUND
THE PALM DESERT CAMPUS STUDENT
SUCCESS CENTER THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU WE WILL GO
TO LINE. EIGHTY SIX AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS REBEKAH MARKETS
REPRESENTING CURRENT PSYCHOLOGY
TO THE AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK AND THE
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED ORGANIC
FARMERS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL TO
CONTINUE INVESTMENT IN
AGRICULTURE TECH EDUCATION
SENATE PROGRAM WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THESE DOLLARS ARE CONFINED.
AND NATURAL RESOURCES MANAGEMENT
TRAINING THAT INCLUDES THE STATE
OF ALL AN ORGANIC AGRICULTURAL
PRACTICES CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND
MITIGATION AND THE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PROVISION OF SERVICES
TO SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS AND RANCHERS. ADDITION
WE ASK THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
OUT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM AS YOU AND TRAIN. SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT IN ORDER TO MEET THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL FOR
WORKING AROUND YOU MUST TELL
CAPACITY OF THE ON THE GROUND
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE. SIXTY
ONE. AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KATHY VAN ON
REPRESENTING JUMBO AFTER FOR USE
- WORKS. THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION FOR THE NEXT
STEP PROGRAM- WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AEROSPACE TEN
MILLION BEYOND THE FUNDING WHICH
HAS BEEN INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE WILL
ALLOW FOUGHT TO USE THAT THE
ENTIRE STATE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS VITAL PROGRAM ENDED
DECEMBER OUT ABOUT OF THE BOX
YOU FUNDING BOTH YOU AND YOU SEE
. BECOME BY TWO BILL LANGUAGE
THAT MAKES CLEAR THE FUNDS MUST
BE USED FOR THE SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS TARGETING. TOP THREE
YEARS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT
THANK WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE OH
TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
SAMANTHA SAYING ANNEXING
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN REGARDS
THREE ITEMS FIRST WE HAD
SIGNATURE TO MARK TODAY IN
CONTINUE TO STAND STRONG SUPPORT
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
INCLUSION OF CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK AND THE FINAL BUDGET
AGREEMENT AND WE THINK YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND CONTINUE WORK TO
CREATE A PATH TO DEBT FREE CALL
IN CALIFORNIA. RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT IN OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION IN THE
STATE OF FINAL BUDGET TO
IMPLEMENT THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK WHICH WILL SUPPORT OUR
LOW TO ACHIEVE
THEIR COLLEGE GOALS SECOND WE DO
SUPPORT IF YOU NEED TO
OPERATIONAL STAFF TO ENSURE THE
EXPANSION OF THE PELL GRANTS AND
PASSED THE KID A COMPLETION IF
SUCCESSFUL AND THEN FINALLY WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE D. F. P.
I- TO CONDUCT STUDENT BORROWER
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION CAMPAIGN
WE DO REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY MILLION FOR THIS PURPOSE
FOR A TOTAL THIRTY MILLION. AS
WE HELP FUTURE AND CURRENT
COLLEGE STUDENTS ACCESS HIGHER
EDUCATION WE CAN'T FORGET THE
MILLIONS OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE
ALREADY GRADUATED HAVE BEEN A
REPAYMENT CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH A FINANCIAL CLASSIC AND TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF AN INVESTMENT OF
THIRTY MILLION TO GET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE
NOW. TWO YOUR LINE OPEN. MY NAME
IS CODY GRANDCHILDREN I AM THE
FORMER FOX YOU AND GRADUATED
FROM CONSUMERS RIVER COLLEGE AND
M. A CURRENT STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE. I AM IN
SUPPORT OF A THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR ARGUMENTATION FOR THE
NEXT PROGRAM IN TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT GUARANTEES THAT
FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR FOSTER YOUTH
AT FIFTEEN UC'S BUSH COOPER TO
THE PROGRAM BETTER. TO COLLEGE
FOSTERS ARE CENTRAL BECAUSE
BEING A BOSS YOU CREATE A LOT OF
DISADVANTAGED FOR US TO SOME
DEGREE THESE PROGRAMS HELP
MINIMIZE THESE DISADVANTAGES AS
WE NAVIGATE OUR COLLEGE CAREERS.
IT WAS NOT FOR NEXT I WOULD NOT
HAVE CONTINUED COLLEGE THE STAFF
AND OTHER STUDENTS NEED THE
PROGRAM FEEL LIKE A FAMILY AND
OF THE FOX NEWS THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT. FACTOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL GO
TO LINE EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
A- GOOD MORNING I CHAIR MEMBERS
AND COMMITTEE STAFF AS THIS IS
JENNIFER MELLIE WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION- WE
ARE CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S MADE PROVISION
THAT INCLUDED THAT THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR- GOING OUT THANKS
. OF THE COURT ARE YOU THREE
LABOUR ST. AND APPRECIATE AND
HOPE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON- FUNDING THAT
PROGRAM OR THOSE PROGRAMS ALSO
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ARE
ONLINE- INCLUDING THE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATIONS THE CSU E. YOU
FUNDING FULLY IMPLEMENT THE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO
PROVIDE. THE WAGES FOR THESE
ESSENTIAL NON FACULTY MEMBERS-
IN WHICH THEY DESERVE APPRECIATE. YOUR TIME AND HAVE A GREAT DAY
. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TIMELINE
THREE AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY FIFTY ONE L. OKAY. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MONICA SURE
I'M A THIRD YEARS USES I JOIN IN
WOULD YOU SEE STILL SINCE
ABSENCE OF COURSE OF IN TWENTY
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION ONGOING
FUNDING FOR STATE THAT AND FIVE
MILLION ONGOING FUNDING POINTS
ON DOCUMENTS AND PROGRAMS NO
BALL SUPPORT FOR THE FULL
FUNDING FOR THE COGNITIVE
GRAMMAR. THANK YOU. IF THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TIMELINE SIXTY EIGHT
AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH HELLO JERRY MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR PUBLIC SERVICE AND
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA
THIS IS TAMARA ROBINSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER.
SHARES I'M GOING TO VOTE THE
CLEAR COMMISSION'S SO OF INTO US
FOR THE SAID ASSEMBLY SUPPORT
FOR THE FUNDING OF THE
FOLLOWING. THE CSU NTPC
COLLABORATIVE TO SERVE ASIAN
AMERICAN NATIVE AMERICAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER STUDENTS. TO SEE IF YOU
ASIAN BILINGUAL TEACHER
EDUCATION PROGRAM CONSORTIUM THE
POINT A PROJECT IN THE CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK. ABUSING
PACIFIC ISLANDER INTO THE
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH EVERYONE
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
TIME. THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY NINE AND YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IF YOU. WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE CONTINUE UP VERY GOOD
MORNING AND THANK LA PALMA
PALMER THANK YOU AND THEN THE
FIGURE A COUPLE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WITHOUT A- COMPONENT OF
GETTING MILLION OBLIGATION FROM
THERE PROGRAM TRAILER BILL MY
THANK GUARANTEES FONG OUR THE
PHARMACY THAT YOU IF YOU GO TO
SUPPORT DIRECTOR COMPENSATION
THANK YOU THEIR NUMBER A CRUCIAL
TALK ABOUT. THANK WHAT THE
PROJECT THE HIGHER EDUCATION AND
MONEY BE.
THAT ECHO THE COMMENTED CODE
SINCE YET YOU USE THAT LATER
THAT N. AS HE ARE YOU- IN
SUPPORT OF ADOPTING THE SENATE
BUDGET I'VE MADE BY
AUGMENTATION- WITH RESPECT TO
THE INVERSION GAP AT THIS YET
YOU ITS LONGER. TO DO RIGHT BY
OUR MEMBERS THEN WE WOULD URGE
YOU TO FOLLOW THEIR LEAD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE ELEVEN AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ERIN YOUR
MENTOR AND I'M WITH THE THAI
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT CENTER
BASED IN LOS ANGELES I'M CALLING
TO URGE YOU TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER FOUR YEARS AT THIS
POINT- KEY ISSUES ASIAN
BILINGUAL TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM CONSORTIUM. ARGUING HERE
THAT WE'RE PRODUCING CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT
ASIAN LANGUAGE BILINGUAL
TEACHERS HOW TO INSTRUCT IN OUR
DUAL IMMERSION CLASSROOMS AND
PROMOTE ACADEMIC CULTURAL AND
SOCIAL GROWTH AMONG ALL OF OUR
YOUTH I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME HAVE A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU NOW WE WILL GO
TIMELINE. FOUR AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LIBBY KIRK AND I'M THAT UPS
KAREN NEXTSTEP COORDINATOR WILL
TO MY COLLEGE AND THE INCOMING
FOR THE ETHIOPIA STATED AS THE
ASIAN FIRST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ONGOING SUPPORT IT APPEARS TO
PRESHEAF YOUR DEDICATION TO
PROVIDING SERVICES TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS. I ASK
YOU TO PLEASE SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
OF YOUR PS WITH BUDGET CYCLE BY
SUPPORTING I REQUEST FOR TEN
MILLION ONGOING FUNDING TO
ETHIOPIA AND TEN MILLION ONGOING
FUNDING FOR CARE ARE SINGLE
PARENTS. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
REQUESTED ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
OUR NEXT STEP OUR. FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH STUDENT. YES THE ORIGINAL
CALL EQUITY PROGRAM PROBABLY
DELIBERATE. RAPPER SERVICES TO
BRIDGE GENERATION COLLEGE AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS THE
INCREASE. IN FUNDING WILL ALLOW
ALL OF YOUR PEERS TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING OUR COLLEGES MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. HE'LL BE AT
THE DOCTOR REQUESTING FIFTEEN
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
TARGETED ENROLLMENT AND
RECRUITMENT FOR OUR PROGRAM WE
HAVE A STRONG AND PROUD
TRADITION OF RECRUITING THE MOST
DIFFICULT TO REACH STUDENTS THE
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
STUDENT RECRUITMENT WILL
INCREASE EQUITABLE ENROLLMENT.
AT OUR COLLEGES THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THIS TIME AND SPACE TO
HEAR FROM THE FIELD. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
FIFTEEN AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME COULD YOU KNOW WIN
FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY AGENCIES
ISLANDER COMMUNITY LIFE OR
PROPERTY. I'M CALLING TO URGE
YOU TO AND FACT INTRODUCING MORE
ASIAN LANGUAGE CREDIT TEACHERS
TEACHING BILINGUAL AND DEAL
EMERGING CONTRA COSTA DATE- IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
ALL THE BILINGUAL ACCREDITATION
ISSUED IN CALIFORNIA ONLY 8%
WERE ONE. USING AND INVESTMENT
NEW TO AND INTERACTING. SORRY WE
LOST YOU THERE. I'M SORRY HER
OUR LINE DID DISCONNECT. SO WE
WILL CONTINUE ON I WILL GO TO
LINE ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO HI MY NAME IS
REPUTED TO MILLIE AND I'M A
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS I'M CALLING
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF FUNDING FOR
THE UC STATE PROGRAMS
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT PROGRAMS
AND ACCOUNT FOR EQUITY PRIMARK
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
. THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE NINETY SEVEN AND ONE MOMENT
. YOUR LINE IS OPEN- GEMMA PARTY
MANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS FOR SOME
A TRIED SERVICE VICE PRESIDENT
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
COUNTY TO DISSOCIATION. I'M
CALLING YOU TODAY YOUR QUESTION
LEGISLATOR INVEST THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS MAN CAL
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK WHICH
WILL ENSURE THAT HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS WOULD
RECEIVE A TELEGRAM AWARDS. AND
MAKE CALIFORNIA THE UNDENIABLE
LEADER IN JUNE EQUITY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
FOR STUDENTS. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME ONLY BUT THE FACT AND I AM-
CURRENTLY- HOMELESS STUDENT IN
UC SANTA CRUZ I AM- RENAISSANCE
SCHOLAR STUDENT- AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
ANY GO ON GOING ON TO GO TOWARDS
POSTURE YOU SERVING PROGRAMS AND
FOUR MILLION TO SUPPORT SYSTEM
IMPACTED STUDENTS PARTICIPATING
IN THE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
PROGRAM AND FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED OUR SYSTEM IMPACTED
STUDENTS THAT THE- WITH
INVESTMENT WILL IMPACT YOU TNCS
CURRENT FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. ONE
MILLION AND. INDEPENDENT IN THEN
THE FOLLOW WAY. ONE IMPROVE
OUTCOMES IN HEALTH HOW AND BY
NOW TO DURING AND I COLLEGE. TO
BUILD VALIDATE. A LOT WELL IT'S
THEIR TO GOALS AND THREE
INCREASE GRADUATION RATES. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THE COMMUNITY
ADOPTS LANGUAGE THAT GUARANTEES
THAT ON BOTH BELIEVE THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
. AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CARE MCCARTY AND BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
HENRY T<c.cyan> AND I AM A FRESHMAN AT</c>
UC BERKELEY STUDYING COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND ECONOMICS I'M
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF THE UC
FUNDING REQUEST IN THE MAY
REVISION OF THE BUDGET. AS A
STUDENT MY PEERS AND I ARE
SERIOUSLY IMPACTED BY STATE
FUNDING LEVELS AND I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE AN EXAMPLE WITH YOU ALL
TODAY. I THIRTY UNDER UC
BERKELEY DEPARTMENT OF
ELECTRICAL ENGINEERING AND
COMPUTER SCIENCES. WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATELY NOW CLOSE TO
COLLAPSING DUE TO ATTEND.
DRAMATIC INCREASE CONTENT
INTEREST. WE ONLY FOUR HUNDRED
GRAD A DECADE AGO. TODAY THAT
NUMBER IS NEARLY FOURTEEN
HUNDRED. THIS TRICKLING
ENROLLMENT NOT BEEN ACCOMPANIED
BY REQUISITE INCREASE IN
FUNDING. BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
TO RUN ROUGHLY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE GRANT EACH YEAR.
AND HAVE A SHRINKING NUMBER OF
COURSES AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS
HOPING TO GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS
. I WOULD GREATLY FOR INTRO
COMPUTER ARCHITECTURE. FEE OF
SIXTY ONE SEAT THIS SEMESTER.
AND I WAS ULTIMATELY CUT ONE
MONTH AND BECAUSE WE CAN EXPAND
TO MEET DEMAND. THE PROBLEM IS
SO BAD NOW THAT EARLY IT KIND I
CAN TAKE THIS INTRO CLASS IS IN
MY JUNIOR YEAR DUE TO NEW
RESTRICTIONS ON ENROLLMENT
CAUSED BY LACK OF FUNDING. SINCE
MOST COURTS DISCUSSION ARE RUN
BY FORMER STUDENTS CUTTING SEATS
NOW MEANS CUTTING KEY A ROLLED
LATER. ULTIMATELY CHOKING THE
PIPELINE OF STUDENT TALENT THAT
OUR COURSES RELY ON. THESE
RESTRICTION HARM DIFFERENT THE
STUDENTS THE MOST STUDENTS WHO
CAN'T AFFORD SUMMER TUITION TO
JUMP AHEAD OR CAN'T AFFORD AN
EXTRA SEMESTER CAL TO TAKE BACK
LOADED CLASSES. THAT'S WHY I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE UC
FUNDING REQUEST IN THE STATE
BUDGET. I'M GRATEFUL FORTY
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION AND I HOPE THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL AS BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY AND
AT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN
HEAR YOU PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE
ETHNIC OF LUCK HE FOLLOWED THE
GUEST SERVICE CENTER IN LOS
ANGELES MY SON WAS ENGINEER IN
GLENDALE HIGH SCHOOL NOW AT WENT
TO JAPANESE IMMERSION PROGRAM IN
GLENDALE FROM CANADA TO TENTH
GRADE. THANK YOU LEARN JAPANESE
WRITING AND READING THE LONG
WITH THE RICH CULTURE OF JAPAN
NOW- HE'S ABLE TO READ JAPANESE
BOOKS IN THE COMMUNICATE AND
ALSO- WITH MY FAMILY IN JAPAN
THANK YOU CELEBRATING HIS
BIRTHDAY. WITH A JAPANESE
IMMERSION PROGRAM IS BEING
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
PASS OUR CULTURAL HERITAGE TO
HIM SO I'M CALLING TODAY TO URGE
YOU TO INVEST THE FUNDS THAT IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE WE ARE
PRODUCING CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT HM
LUGGAGE BILINGUAL TEACHERS OR
ARE YOU IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LIVE ONE TWO EIGHT. AND THAT
YOUR LIFE IS OPEN. IN MORNING
MEMBER MY IS CANDACE TRIAL I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY COUNSEL
AT EIGHT EQUITY ALLIANCE. WE ARE
COALITION OF OVER FORTY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THIRTEEN A ONE AND A HALF
MILLION ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. CALLING THAT- JUNE TWO
INVEST IN. MORE ASIAN LANGUAGE
ACCREDITED TEACHERS TO TEACH AND
BILINGUAL AND DUAL IMMERSION
CLASSROOM. ONLY 8% OF ALL
BILINGUAL ACCREDITATION
STATEWIDE ARE FOR ASIAN
LANGUAGES. FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER AND DIVERSITY OF
QUALIFIED TEACHERS WITH
EXPERTISE IN ASIAN CULTURES AND
LANGUAGES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY NINE AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FONG THE INSTITUTE FOR ARE
ACT AND SUCCESS CALL INTEREST
ASK FOR THE INCLUSION OF A THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THE FINAL STATE
BUDGET AGREEMENT TO IMPLEMENT
THE CABIN EQUITY FREE MARKETS
AND TO BUILD ON THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO MAKE COLLEGE
AFFORDABLE COLLEGE THE REALITY
FOR ALL UNDER RESOURCE
CALIFORNIANS. THE FRAMEWORK
WITHIN TO FIND STREAMLINED THE
COVER PROGRAM MAKING IT EASIER
TO UNDERSTAND AND COMMUNICATE TO
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES REMOVE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO GRANT
ELIGIBILITY THAT KEEP WITH AND
NEED FROM ACTORS EIGHT AND
BETTER COVER NON TUITION COLLEGE
COSTS THAT MAKE UP THE MAJORITY
OF COLLEGE COSTS FOR MOST
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR ON
GOING LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT
TO IMPROVING COLLEGE ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND. SUCCESS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MAX WE
WILL GO TO LINE. THIRD FIVE AND
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING MR SHARE THIS IS GETTING
OUT THE LAST OF THE CALIFORNIA
TOGETHER BUT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION WE'RE
HEARING A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR-
NEED FOR BILINGUAL TEACHERS
SPECIFICALLY IN ASIAN LANGUAGES
OVER ASKING. FOR THE ASSEMBLY TO
INCLUDED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
APPROPRIATION AND THAT IF YOU
BUDGET TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT IN
THE BILINGUAL. AUTHORIZATION
PROGRAM. BERMAN AND RETENTION
AFFECT AND FORTH AND BACK
THROUGH THE COLLEGE ABOUT YOU.
RECREATION OF THE PROGRAM WILL
MOVE. OUR STATE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BY CREATING MORE-
FACULTIES WILL BE ABLE TO OFFER
MORE CLASSES IF SUPPORTERS
STUDENT. FOR- MORE STATE MORE
GOING BILINGUAL STUDENTS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TOLD
BLIND ONE THIRTY NINE AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
RAVI THING AND I'M WITH THE
CAMBODIAN FAMILY COMMUNITY
CENTER. I'M CALLING TO URGE YOU
TO INVEST IN PRODUCING MORE
ASIAN LANGUAGE ACCREDITED
TEACHERS TO TEACH IN BILINGUAL
AND DUAL IMMERSION PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY OF ALL
THE BY LEGAL ACCREDITATION
ISSUED IN CALIFORNIA ONLY 8%
MORE WARD AT THE ASIAN LANGUAGES
. AND INVESTMENT IS NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE PIPELINE ISSUE AND
INCREASE THE POOL OF QUALIFIED
TEACHERS WITH EXPERTISE IN ASIAN
CULTURE AND LANGUAGES THANK YOU
AND HAVE A GOOD DAY. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING SURE NUMBER WHO SHALL
MAKE IT UNDER WITH ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
PROVIDING FUNDS TO DISTRICTS IN
THE MOST FLEXIBLE WAY POSSIBLE
AT THE TOP FOR AKKA THEREFORE WE
SUPPORT THE INCREASED FAFSA.
PROPOSED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM WE
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS GEN MCCARTY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL TO
MAXIMIZE THE FUNDING INTO THIS
GAS AND GET MORE DISTRICT OFF OF
ALL PARTNER WITH AFTER A TWEAK
TO THE HOLD HARMLESS TO BRING IT
CLOSER TO TODAY. BUT PERHAPS IT
WILL BE LESS RELEVANT IF THE
ASSEMBLY SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASES
THE GAS. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
DISCRETIONARY BLOCK GRANT AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDS TO
SUPPORT LOCAL NEED FINALLY WHAT
THE STATE FUNDING SURPLUS WE
CONTINUE TO CALL FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FUSION OF RESOURCES
AND ACCOUNTS CERTAIN CALPERS ON
BEHALF OF EDUCATION EMPLOYERS
THE STATE IS MAKING A WISE
INVESTMENT OF RESOURCES THAT
PAID OUT ITS FUTURE OBLIGATIONS.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. THE
THING THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TYLER SEVEN. AND LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE'RE
CONCERNED WITH THE MAY REVISED
DID NOT INCLUDE AUGMENTATION FOR
UPS CARE OR MAKE THAT WERE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
NATIVE AMERICANS CAN SUPPORT
PROGRAM. WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATE INCLUSIONS OF THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE PUTTING WELL TO
WORK PLAN AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ADOPT THE SAME INVESTMENTS AND
PRIORITIZE ON GOING FUNDING IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT CAL GRANT REFORM
INCREASED STAFFING AT THE CHANCE
OF OFFICE WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
SOME OF THE PRIORITIES DETAILED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
INCLUDING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR PART TIME FACULTY HEALTH
CARE SIX POINT 5% COLA THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA BASED
ALLOCATION. ALTHOUGH WE
RECOGNIZE THE FORMULA CONTINUES
TO BE PLAGUED BY STRUCTURAL
SHORTCOMINGS THAT ARE UNRESOLVED
AND FINALLY WE SUPPORT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
TEACHERS. PENSION RELIEF ME
BECAUSE DISTRICT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NECK WE WILL GO TO
LAW. IS SIXTY SIX AND YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JENNY
AN AMNESTY AT THE END THE
COLLEAGUES I'M HERE TODAY ASKING
FOR INCREASED FUNDING FOR CAL
GRANT I JUST WHO RECEIVES CAL
GRANT SUPPORT I CAN SPEAK FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE BUT AN
EXTREMELY. IMPORTANT INVESTMENT
FOR ALL COLLEGE STUDENTS. AND
COUNTRY BY EXPORT THE NEED IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE TO HIGHER
EDUCATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTEEN AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE BUTTON. THE MORNING
CARE MCCARTNEY AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS DAVID MARBLE THE CHARGE
SERVICE CENTER I AM THE CHIEF
GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY WHERE
OFFICER RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF INVESTING FIVE
DOLLARS OVER FOUR YEARS TO
SUPPORT THE CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN STUDENTS PROFESSORS
AND THAT ITS INVESTMENT
INCREASED BY BIRTH HE TO THE
TEACHER. PIPELINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A GOLD LINE
ONE FORTY FOUR AND YOUR LINE IS
. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
IMRAN MAJID AND I WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CAN COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR. WELL WE ARE GREATLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INVESTMENT IN OUR SYSTEM
WE BELIEVE THERE REMAINS
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADDRESSED THE TRUE TOTAL COST
FAST. FOR ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION SIR STUDENTS. REMAIN
GRATEFUL TO SOMEONE MEMBER
MEDINA AS THE MCCARTY LEADERSHIP
AND COMMITMENT TOWARDS
IMPROVISING FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEMS IN WHICH WE STRONGLY
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO FUND THE
COW GRAPHICALLY FOR MARK I
SUPPOSE BUT AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX. IN THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO STATE BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NECK WE WILL GO TO LAW
ONE THIRTY EIGHT AND YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO NAME IS STAGE
FROM COUNTY UNIVERSITY BEACH I'M
OF COURSE AND CORNY CRITIC AS
BILINGUAL. COULD PROGRAM AND
ALSO REPRESENT THIS IF YOU BY
WHICH EACH EDUCATION PRO CONCERN
. I'M CALLING TO URGE YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT THE ASIAN
LANGUAGE FUNDING A PROGRAM THIS
INCLUDES TEACHERS STUDENTS AND
PROFESSORS TO TEACH AND
BILINGUAL AND DUAL IMMERSION
CLASSROOMS ACROSS THE STATE
INVESTING THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S CRUCIAL TO SUPPORT
THE CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
CURRENTLY IS. THE THING ABOUT
THE FUNDS THEY NEED ESPECIALLY
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN STUDENTS
AND PROFESSORS. IN ADDITION THE
COST OF TAKING EXTRA REQUIRED
COURSES AND TRANSPORTATION
BILINGUAL CREDENTIAL PROGRAM IS
A FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR STUDENTS
TO SUPPORT IS AN INVESTMENT TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY TO THE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING PIPELINE
pQUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO LINE
THIRD SEVEN AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND NINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON.
AGAIN LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MY NAME'S MICHAEL SIGN I AM A
SENIOR AT THE UC SANTA BARBARA
HI HERE TO UPLIFT THE EXISTING-
UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION ASK FOR
TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR SAFE
PROGRAMS. FIVE MILLION ONGOING
FOR UNDOCUMENTED PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS THE UPDATED CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK- OTHER STUDENT
I WITNESSED TREMENDOUS ENERGY
STRONG THESE PROGRAMS AND I
THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONCE AGAIN NINE ONE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MA'AM I THANK YOU COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M MY NAME IS
THAT I BLOOD THAT I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE UNDENIABLE. OUR
JUNIOR STRONG SUPPORT OF
INCREASING D. S. PR. FROM TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ONGOING
SUPPORT. FOR STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS ACROSS THE STATE. I
DIDN'T THE VERY AND STUDENTS
CONTINUE TO THE LAWN THEIR
RESEARCH WE COME MORE AND ISSUE
WE HAVE THE RIGHT- SUPPORT OF A
THIRD BILLION DOLLARS THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT- WE
WILL GO TO ONE OF FOUR NINE AND
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI. YOUR LINE. ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE WILL CONTINUE ON LINE
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON NAME IS KEVIN
WHERE I'M NOT BACK REMEMBER AS
SHE IF YOU SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY
REQUEST THAT YOU WOULD MIND THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
PROPOSAL WITH THE SENATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE THE CSU WITH
AN ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION OF UNALLOCATED FUNDING
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
JANUARY OF TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS THIS INCREASE
WILL ENSURE THAT THIS YET YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO FULFILL ITS
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDE THE
FACULTY AND STAFF AND TO SEE A
FEW. WITH A FAIR AND COMPETITIVE
SALARY THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE OH EIGHT N.
E. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH THANK
I'M DOCTOR DIE BLAIR AND I'M A
FACULTY MEMBER AT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY I STRONGLY REQUEST
THAT YOUR MIND THAT TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET PROPOSAL WITH THE SENATE
BUDGET PROPOSAL IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THAT THE WITH IN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
OF ALLOCATED BASED FUNDING. THIS
INCREASE ONCE THAT THE CSU WILL
BE ABLE TO DEVELOP A COMMITMENT
TO PROVIDE THE FACULTY AND STAFF
AT THAT THE ISSUE WITH THE FAIR
AND COMPETITIVE SALARY AS YOU
HAVE HEARD YOUR INVESTMENT IN
THE CSU AND PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION IS AN INVESTMENT IN
OUR STATE FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO LINE AT
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
TURN MEMBERSHIP COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MARKET MONTEZ AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE COLLEGE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE CHECK AND
WORK ON CALL SUPPORT THE K.
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOU TO
INCLUDE THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION ACTIVE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS A HUNDRED NINE
THOUSAND AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
UNEXAMPLED STUDENT POPULATION
BUT TO A TREMENDOUSLY BENEFIT
FROM THIS PROPOSAL IS ESTIMATED
SEVENTY THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS ATTENDING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE. ONE OH
FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JOE PATTERSON
CALLING ON BEHALF OF COKE
TWITCHES CONGREGATIONS ORGANIZED
FOR PROSTHETIC ENGAGEMENT- YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE INCLUSION OF THE
CALIBRATE EQUITY FRAMEWORK IN
THE FINAL STATE BUDGET AGREEMENT
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND CONTINUED WORK TO CREATE A
PATH TO DEBT FREE COLLEGE IN
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT INVESTMENT OF
THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND THE FINAL STATE
BUDGET TO IMPLEMENT THE CAL
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK. WHICH
WILL SUPPORT OUR LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS TO ACHIEVE THEIR
COLLEGE GOALS THANK YOU SO MUCH
. THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY LEE WITH THE
LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
CSU TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE OPERATING BUDGET
REQUEST THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
BYE BYE. THANK YOU AND WE WILL
TAKE A FINAL RESPONSE AND THAT
WILL BE FROM LINE ONE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS AND
STAFF MY NAME IS TRENT MURPHY
AND I'M A STUDENT AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY STANISLAUS AND
I CAMPUSES ASSOCIATED STUDENTS
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS
COORDINATOR. I'M CALLING TODAY
TO REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
INVEST THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK. THIS WEEK ABOUT THE
ENORMOUS INCREASES THE COST OF
LIVING EXPENSES AND INFLATION.
BUT A FINANCIALLY DEVASTATED OUR
CSU STUDENTS BUT ALSO IMPACTS
MENTAL HEALTH GRADUATION RATES
AND OVERALL STUDENT SUCCESS.
IMPLEMENTING THESE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK WILL
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO HAVE AN IMPROVE UPON. THE
MOST EQUITABLE PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION. SYSTEM IN THE NATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I THANK YOU
THAT WE WILL TURN. WHEN YOU HAVE
A- THAT DOES CONCLUDE YOUR
CONFERENCE YOU MAY NOW
DISCONNECT.